Na, es ist total voll da vorne schon, ey. Kommen die alle zum FreakShow treffen?
Aber zum Glück nicht so politisch wahrscheinlich.
Ja, da war früher nicht so politisch der Kongress.
Viel mehr Technik.
Viel mehr.
Ich will von den Stars begrüßt werden, oder?
Na gut, die haben wir auch schon begrüßt, ja.
Na von wem?
Na, der Holgi hat schon mal Hallo gesagt.
Der Holgi?
Ich will von Tim begrüßt werden, von Roddy oder Clements oder was? Wo sind die überhaupt?
Was ist für ein Lachacht?
Na gut, die Letty steht da vorne mit Holgi zusammen und eigentlich kommt man hier mit allen ganz gut ins Gespräch.
Näh komm, neh, neh, pack ich jetzt fast aus.
Und jetzt die Fortsetzung.
Da kommen wir glaube ich zu diesen Faltechniken. Klar, doch.
Also ich glaube auch, dass sich dahinter verbirgt. Also genau, was heißt richtig? Ich glaube, dass Dinge eine Chance haben, einen Platz zu haben, wenn man sie überhaupt wahrnimmt und sieht und finden kann. Also richtig verstaut ist nicht im Küchenschrank hinter dem Teesieb, was ich sowieso schon seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr benutze. Das dann wegwerfen. Also wenn die Dinge, die du nicht siehst, von denen weißt du irgendwann auch nicht mehr, dass du sie hast und dann neigst du zum Doppelkauf oder so.
Auch noch so ein Problem. Man kauft sich immer irgendwas, weil man sowas schon immer mal haben wollte. Und in dem Moment, wo man es dann das erste Mal versucht, wegzuräumen, stellt man fest, dass man sowas schon lange hatte.
Ja, kenn ich auch.
Ja, bzw. ich kenn halt auch den Effekt, etwas zu besitzen bringt dir nichts, wenn du es nicht findest, wenn du es brauchst.
Absolut. Genau. Und das spricht extrem für diese These, dass es einen Platz hat. Und es muss, mein Verständnis, natürlich auch einen logischen Platz haben.
Als ich beginne jetzt langsam Lust zu verspüren, diese Serie auch mal zu gucken, weil ich mich frage, wie geht es hier um mit jetzt wirklichen Besitztümern und Verbrauchskütern? Weil das sehe ich hier noch nicht. Denn diese Doppelkäufe sind zum Beispiel bei mir in der Regel bei Verbrauchskütern. Also eine Rolle Gaffer, die ich verlegt habe oder die irgendwo im Auto ist, die ich aber jetzt in dem Moment im Haushalt brauche. Dann gehe ich mir also eine Rolle Gaffer kaufen, weil ich nicht weiß, dass ich schon einen im Auto habe. Nein, noch einen im Auto habe. Ich habe aber keine emotionale Bindung zu einer Rolle Gaffer. Also die Sparkles, no joy in my life.
Gaffer macht dich nicht glücklich.
Ich bin total inneren widersprung, aber er meint es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Gaffer und Kabelbinder, Alter. Das sind die glücklich machend Gegenstände überhaupt.
Ich weiß, dass ich nicht Spanngurte bin.
Megaseriöse Sendungen, die ich hier eingeladen wurde.
Da kann man mal richtig spannen.
Ich wusste schon, warum ich hier nur Gast bin.
Okay, wir können einfach gleich wieder gehen.
Lass sie doch allein über ihre Ordnung reden.
Ja, drüber reden hilft nicht.
Also was mir auch total fehlt, ist das ganze Thema Kinder im Haushalt. Seitdem hat einfach die Entropie ein Maß angenommen, dass wirklich sich auch so einem zyklischen Aufräumen, was du eben gesagt hast, Tim, für mich irgendwie völlig entzieht.
Du hast das aufgebracht mit dem zyklischen Aufräumen.
Ich hab nur gesagt, ich handele im Affekt, irgendwann ist es mir zu viel. Dann mach ich es aber auch besser.
Ja, aber das heißt ja, ich habe dir nur ein anderes Wort gegeben, dein Zyklus ist immer dann, oder der...
Das ist nicht regelmäßig, aber es ist ein Zyklus.
Du hast einen unregelmäßigen Zyklus, Tim.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal, dass das jemand zumindest sagt.
Aber dann stellt es jemand fest.
Aber dein Bedürfnis nach Aufräumen bemisst dich ja an deinem, es reicht dir mit deiner eigenen Unordnung.
Das ist ja auch ziemlich privilegienblind. Man muss sich auch leisten können, zu sagen, jetzt räume ich auf und ich werde die nächsten 16 Stunden nur aufräumen.
Und ich finde auch total privilegiert, ich finde es immer noch relativ materialistisch. Ich glaube, es zahlt so in diese Minimalismus-Schiene ein. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich trägt. Weil wenn ich tatsächlich alles weggebe, was keine Freude in mir auslöst, dann fehlen mir einfach ein paar Güter, die ich aber brauche. Also Küchengeräte sind zum größten Teil unfassbar hässlich. Aber ich brauche einen Wasserkocher. Tatsächlich habe ich mir mittlerweile, nach vielen Iterationsstufen, den schönsten, den ich für mein Geld kriegen konnte, gefunden.
Bei mir macht mein Wasserkocher glücklich.
Wenn heißes Wasser rauskommt, kann ich mir einen Tee aufgießen.
Der Wasserkocher war ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil dazu habe ich auch eine Beziehung. Aber der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus wollte, ist, dass ich finde, dieses, dann gebe ich es weg, nicht thematisiert, was danach passiert. Ich habe zum Beispiel... Was ist Thema Kleidung? Bisher hat man nur über Gegenstände gesprochen, die hatte ich zumindest im Kopf. Aber was ist mit Kleidung? Ich habe definitiv Hosen, die ich nicht leide. Da hängt mein Herz nicht dran, aber ich kann die nicht ersatzlos weggeben, dann habe ich nämlich keine mehr. Hosen kaufen ist einfach mal ganz schlimm. Und zusätzlich gibt man noch Geld aus, obwohl man eigentlich was Funktionierendes noch zu Hause hat. Deswegen würde ich eher dafür werben, aufzutragen und nicht neu anzuschaffen.
Also dann macht dich das glücklich, keine andere Hose als Ersatz für die weggeschmissene Hose kaufen zu müssen.
Das ist vielleicht sehr klug.
Das ist klug, aber das verkauft sich jetzt auch kompliziert.
Aber ich finde die Kondometode funktioniert sehr gut, auch mit Mode und mit Kleidung. Weil wenn ich bei Mode könnte, bringt das mir Freude. Habe ich einen emotionalen Bezug, nehme ich es gerne in die Hand. Da finde ich, ist das relativ einfach. Ich hatte eher das Problem, es gibt einfach auch Graffel, zu dem man möglicherweise keinerlei Bezug hat, die man aber einfach braucht. Und was weiß ich, irgendwelche Steckerleisten. Aber da wäre dann wieder das.
Steckerleisten?
Ich hab doch gar nichts gesagt.
Aber da käme ja wieder das Prinzip von Roddy zum Tragen, dass es dich glücklich macht, zu wissen, dass du nicht die eine an einem anderen Ort suchen musst.
Ich finde, an der ganzen Sache ist auch interessant. Erst mal, es gibt offensichtlich Methoden, die dieses Mass, also dieses zu viel an Dingen loszuwerden. Und das muss nicht die einzige Methode sein, aber es ist doch schon mal ein ganz guter Einstieg. Also im Modebereich kenne ich einen sehr guten und klugen Satz. Wenn du es seit einem Jahr nicht angezogen hast, außer einem Smoking, einem langen Abendkleid oder irgendeinem Funktionskleidung, wie ein Taucheranzug, was halt nicht tauchen, aber du willst irgendwann vielleicht doch mal wieder tauchen oder surfen, also solche Spezialfälle kann man ja anders. Aber das, was unter normaler Bekleidung fällt und du hast es seit einem Jahr nicht benutzt, dann ist das ein ganz, ganz klarer Kandidat für einen Recall. Quatsch, zum Rausschmeißen. Und dann gibt es quasi, das ist so ein Triageprinzip, also was man ein Jahr lang nicht reingeht, kommt alles auf den Haufen weg. Und dann gibt es vielleicht so Signature, so ein Kongress-T-Shirt, das hat man auch seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr angehört, weil das schon zu staub zerfallen könnte oder weil der Aufdruck schon so zerknittert ist. Aber das ist natürlich hoch emotional und das kommt natürlich dann in diesen in diesen preziosen Haufen.
Du meinst, wie die Poster von Konzerten, wo man vor 25 Jahren war, die man gar nicht mehr aufhängt, aber wegschmeißen kann man sie auch nicht?
Ich habe diese Störung nicht, aber ich kann sie intellektuell nachvollziehen.
Ich glaube, ich habe die auch nicht, aber...
Ich habe tatsächlich auch so ein Ding, vielleicht auch eine weibliche Addition dazu. Ich hatte jetzt über ein Jahr einfach super viel Krempel in meinem Schrank, weil ich schwanger war und dann passen halt nicht alle Sachen. Das heißt, ich hatte so zwei Partitionen. Jetzt habe ich immer noch irgendwo so Schwangerschaftskleidung rumliegen und jetzt muss ich aber auch zurück in die alte Kleidung morfen. Das ist auch nicht so Minimalismus geeignet. Also generell Schwangerschaft und das, was dann daraus folgt.
Was ist denn diese Minimalismus-Idee dahinter, die mit dieser Kondo-Methode verbunden wird?
Also mit Kondo kenne ich mich überhaupt nicht aus.
Aber du hattest das gesagt. Das hätte irgendwie so einen Bezug zu einem Minimalismus-Trend.
Also weniger Horten, weniger Besitzen. Und ich versuche tatsächlich weniger zu konsumieren. Aber das ist jetzt so ein Reines, weil ich einfach Besitz nicht mehr er trage. Und das liegt auch daran, dass wir einen Bulli haben, in dem wir halt die Sommer verbringen und jetzt zum Beispiel im Sommer eben sehr, sehr lange durch Europa gefahren sind. Und immer wenn ich dann aus diesem Bulli wieder zurück in meine Wohnung falle, kriege ich einfach einen Anfall, weil ich einfach den Platz und das Graffeln nicht er trage. Und deswegen habe ich so zwei fest installierte, große Flohmarktkisten, in die ich dann immer, wenn ich aufräume, kommen Dinge zurück an ihren Platz oder in die Flohmarktkiste oder in Müll. Ich habe so drei Töpfen, die das fallen kann. Und das ist so mein Verständnis von Minimalismus, dass ich einfach diesen ganzen Besitz nicht mehr trage und versuche, eben langsam abzutragen und nicht neu zu kaufen. Oder noch ein anderes Prinzip, dass ich habe, ist, wenn ich etwas Neues kaufe, dann muss etwas anderes dafür weg. Ja, auch bei Klamotten, aber tatsächlich dann eher bei Gegenständen. Also sowas wie, ich kaufe mir kein neues Duschgel, bevor das Alte nicht wirklich verbraucht ist. Oder ich...
Das sind typische Verbrauchsgegenstände.
Ja, aber auch Küchengeräte.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das mache ich anders, weil ich will ja nicht unter der Dusche stehen und mir überlegen, oh Scheiße, du hättest gestern Duschgel kaufen müssen und das hast du vergessen.
Na gut, das ist wie Butter, das sind diese One More Produkte. Da kaufe ich dann immer eins mehr, damit immer wenn das verbraucht ist, ich schon das nächste da habe und dann kaufe ich dann schon wieder das nächste.
Aber noch so eine Methodik ist, dass man wirklich alles, was man im Haushalt hat, mal nicht auf einen Haufen, aber zumindest an einen Platz auch schichtet und nach Gruppen und vielleicht auch Verbrauchsgüter, Mode und so weiter entsprechend aufteilt, dass man dann aber mal durchzählt. Wie viele Gegenstände sind das denn? Und dann gibt es so verschiedene Zielgrößen, ein Mensch braucht eigentlich nur 200 Gegenstände oder braucht vielleicht 1000 Gegenstände. Aber bei dieser Erstzählung bin ich sicher, dass man nicht unter Messi Verdacht geraten muss, dass man zweieinhalb tausend Gegenstände hat. Kommt ja auch darauf an, was man vielleicht, du hast wahrscheinlich noch Schallplatten in rauen Mengen.
Ich habe Schallplatten in rauen Mengen, weil meine Mutter sie nicht mehr haben wollte und mir den Schallplattenspieler und ihre Schallplatten übereignet hat.
Du musst das jetzt nicht auf deine Mutter schieben.
Nein, vorher hatte ich drei Schallplatten oder vier.
Weil bist du schon aus der CD-Generation?
Nein, also als...
Ich meinte jetzt Tonträger, physische Tonträger.
Ja, ja, schon klar. Also eigentlich bin ich mehr die CD-Generation. Aber ich war früh dran. Also ich bin so ein krankhafter Early Adopter. Und als dann die CD vorgestellt wurde, dachte ich mir, also das mit den Platten, das hat ja irgendwie keinen Sinn mehr. Und das war aber noch lange bevor die CD sich dann durchgesetzt hat.
Wenn man einfach sagt, ich bin ein wahnsinniger Musik-Fick, dann würde ich sogar ganz radikal sagen, meine Musiksammlung ist ein Gegenstand.
Also alles weg?
Nein, das wird einfach, wenn ich eine Zielgröße habe und ich will nur 250 Gegenstände, dann wird natürlich quasi meine Platten-Sammlung, die 400 physische Tonträger umfasst, als ein Gegenstand.
Das macht es einem auf jeden Fall leichter, das in Gruppen von eins zusammenzufassen.
Ich glaube, wenn man die Frage umformuliert und nicht sagt, macht mich der Gegenstand glücklich, sondern ist mir der Gegenstand vielleicht egal?
Oder belastet er mich sogar?
Ich kann diese Frage, ist mir der Gegenstand egal, nahezu ja beantworten, dann kann ich ihn auch wegtun. Wenn er mir sowieso egal ist.
Ich hab letztens meine Platten-Sammlung ausgemistet und zum Teil auch verschenkt. Ein großer Teil, so ein Bulk ist noch da, aber das ist quasi ein Gegenstand, weil da ist eine Regaltür vor, belastet mich nicht. Aber ich bin auf die Idee gekommen, meine wirkliche Schallplatten, also diese schwarzen Vinylscheiben, auszumisten, weil mir irgendwann mal aufgefallen ist, dass ich seit über 20 Jahren gar keinen Schallplattenspieler habe.
Du hast den Highscore.
Die sind ja zu verschenken, also du bist eingeladen.
Nee, ich hab auch keinen Plattenspieler, das weiß ich aber schon.
Ich hab ja jetzt keinen.
Dann war es aber so, dass es einfach Schallplatten gibt, die mir aus bestimmten Gründen, als ich sie damals gekauft hatte, sehr, sehr wertvoll waren. Und das heißt, ich habe jetzt eine Schallplattensammlung. Das sind dann nur noch vielleicht 20 oder 30 Stück. Die habe ich aber auch bewahrt. Die bleiben in meinem Ewigkeitsfach. Einfach als Kunstwerke, weil das große Vinylalbum hat für sich auch noch so eine plakrative Wirkung. Also das ist ja nicht einfach nur Musik, sondern da ist das Platten, das Albumdesign. Das ist auch haptisch interessant. Das ist einfach auch ein Gegenstand, ein Zeitdokument. Und davon habe ich so ein paar. Ich würde sagen, vielleicht 20 oder 30 sind bei mir in so einer Ewigkeitsbox. Und dann gibt es noch so eine verhandelbare. Das heißt, wenn Musikfans bei mir sind und dann sagen würden, das ist das letzte fehlende Album in meiner Sammlung zur Gruppe, dann könnte ich das vielleicht abgeben. Und dann gibt es irgendwie so 200. Da bin ich bisher einfach zu faul gewesen, es an die entsprechenden Plattenhändler weiterzugeben. Aber was wirklich toll war und was mich für mich so richtig glücklich gemacht hat in dem Moment war, ich habe ja keinen Schallplattenspieler, habe aber Freunde eingeladen, doch meine Schallplattensammlung durchzugehen. Und was kommt? Das ist ja ein interessantes Cover. Was ist denn das für eine Band? Wie klingt denn das? Am Anfang habe ich noch so ein bisschen, ja, das ist so ein bisschen Musik, so eine Mischung aus Rolling Stones, Treffen, was weiß ich, die Blur. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, da kommt man nicht so richtig weiter. Und dann habe ich gedacht, okay, ich habe ja Apple Music und bestimmt wird es das Album da drin geben. Und wirklich jede Frage, jedes Album, das wir in die Hand genommen haben, war in der Apple Music Bibliothek drin und ich konnte es vorspielen. Und das heißt, selbst wenn ich einen Schallplattenspieler hätte, ich würde sowieso, weil ich einfach zu faul bin, aufzustehen und so eine Schallplatte aufzulegen, ich würde sie gar nicht spielen, sondern ich würde sowieso alles aus dem digitalen Archiv herausnehmen. Und das finde ich faszinierend. Und unglaublich toll, dass es halt in diesem digitalen Archiv all das hinterlegt ist und dass es mich befreit von den physischen Medien.
Warte mal, ich muss mal den Mikro wieder anmachen. Geht dir genauso, was du gerade gesagt hast?
Geht mir genauso. Ich finde das extrem erleichternd, dass mir Bücher nicht mehr so viel bedeuten, also dass mein Bücherregal nicht wächst. Also da tausche ich auch ziemlich radikal aus. Also ich habe viel weniger Drang, als früher Exemplare zu behalten. Also ich behalte wirklich sehr ausgewählt nur Bücher. Und deswegen hält sich die Menge an Büchern, die eben bei mir zu Hause sind, so relativ konstant. Aber es ist eben auch, es hängt daran keine, kein Prestige mehr. So, das finde ich, ich habe gestern erst in meinem Heimat-Hackspace im X-Hain aus Kathrin Passigs Standardsituation der Technologiekritik vorgelesen. Das war irgendwie ein total cooler Abend. Und Kathrin Passig war auch da, um danach zu sagen, dass sie das heute so nicht mehr schreiben würde. Aber genau, es war jedenfalls ein total cooler Abend. Aber deswegen habe ich das so präsent, weil sie halt auch darüber schreibt, dass sie keine Bücher, also dass dieser haptische, fetische, einfach ersatzlos mit dem sozialen Prestige in die Vergangenheit geflossen ist.
Das hatte ich nie. Bücher waren für mich immer Gebrauchsgegenstände. Ich behandle meine Bücher auch meistens so, dass sie hinterher keiner mehr haben will, wenn ich sie gelesen habe. Und ich mache die dann auch weg, wenn ich mir sicher bin, dass sie sie nicht noch mal lesen will. Weil die Bücher, die ich habe, sind alle ungelesen, weil ich die Bücher halt wegtue, wenn ich sie gelesen habe. Oder wenn ich ab einem bestimmten Punkt weiß, das Buch lese ich jetzt nicht mehr weiter.
Es wird unangenehm, weil du gerade sagst, Bücher bearbeiten. Ich weiß nicht, wie du deine Bücher bearbeitest, aber...
Ich verhandle sie einfach nur schlecht.
Aber die Buchstaben sind ja noch drin.
Die Buchstaben sind noch drin, ja. Aber ich meine, ich pack die halt in den Rucksack und dann...
Fallen die manchmal aus, die Buchstaben bei alten Büchern?
Nein, aber dieses Bearbeiten... Also ich lese, wenn ich intensiv lese, mit Stift. Also wenn ich noch auf Papier lese, dann lese ich mit Stift. Und das ist tatsächlich relativ unangenehm, wenn man die dann ausleitet. Weil das ist dann so leicht tagebuchartig.
Also mir fällt da jetzt noch eine ganze Menge zu ein. Ich muss das irgendwie erstmal alles sortieren.
Sortieren, haha. Trag deinen Haufen jetzt ab. Dann hast du es hinter dir.
Dafür bin ich bekannt. Also, kurze Anmerkung zu dieser Schallplattengeschichte ist sehr interessant. Was sich ja zeigt, ist, dass so haptische Dinge, also Sachen, die man so anfasst, nehmen, zu sich ziehen, genauer betrachten kann. Geiles GUI sind eigentlich. Oder ein geiles User-Interface vielmehr. Gäbe es zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, sich einfach seine Cover aus seiner Bookmarktliste in dem Streaming-Dienst seiner Wahl einfach mal auf Karton auszudrucken, dass man sich quasi so einen Blätterordner einfach mal ins Regal stellt, dann hätte man sozusagen so ein Äquivalent. Ähnliches könnte man auch mit Büchern machen. Was wirklich jetzt nicht unbedingt erforderlich ist, Bücher haben jetzt auch nochmal eine Präsenz mit ihrer Dicke und Schwere und wie sie jetzt gebunden sind. Die Diskussion wollte ich jetzt gar nicht gerade aufmachen. Das fiel mir jetzt nur dazu ein. Ich wollte aber nochmal so ein bisschen zu unserem Aufräum-Thema kommen, weil ich nämlich nebenbei diesen Trailer hier auf Netflix mal kurz habe laufen lassen, ohne den Ton zu hören. Ich spiele euch das jetzt auch nochmal kurz vor. Mir fallen da gleich mehrere Sachen auf einmal auf. Vor allem, und ich habe da schon fast mit gerechnet, diese Marie Kondo, die ist ja besessen. Ihr müsst mal darauf achten. Also es sind so mehrere kleine Szenen.
Ach ja, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Jetzt wird es unseriös.
Wieso wird es jetzt unseriös?
Ich finde, sie sieht so ein bisschen aus wie diese Designerin aus The Incredibles, aber das ist nur am Rande.
Was, wie Edna Mode?
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Darling!
Das kannst du so nicht sagen.
Darling! Whatever, spiel den Trailer.
Ja, genau, also ich mach das hier mal ganz stumm. Nur für euch hier auf meinem iPad, weil ich das gerade nicht auf dem großen Bildschirm machen kann. Aber da sieht man, wie sie so schubladen rausnimmt. Sie ist offensichtlich bei anderen Leuten. Ja, und wirft Dinge auf den Haufen. Vielleicht rennt sie in so einen unaufgeräumten Raum rauf.
Und jetzt guck mal, dieser kurze Hüpfer, habt ihr das gesehen?
Mit welcher Begeisterung sie in so einen Raum reingegangen ist.
Hab liebfälziger Arschbombe gemacht.
Wie geil!
Und ehrlich gesagt, mir geht's ein bisschen so ähnlich, wenn ich so anderer Leute Buchhaltungssituationen oder irgendwie Dateilsysteme, weißt du, ab und zu wird man ja auch zu so einem digitalen Clean-Up auch mal berufen. Und ich hab grad so in den letzten zwei Jahren relativ viele Leute auch grad so in Buchhaltungsdingen so ein bisschen inspiriert, sag ich mal, weil ich bin kein Buchhalter, darf das auch nicht machen, tue ich in dem Sinne auch nicht, aber man kann ja mal schauen, wie sozusagen die Lage ist. Und im Prinzip ist dieser Ansatz, den sie da hat, auch in digitalen Dingen so falsch nicht. Also muss es im Rush machen. Wenn du irgendwie dein Zeug, deine digitale Verwahrlosung auflösen möchtest, dann gibt es nichts anderes, besseres als wir setzen uns jetzt hier eine Woche zusammen und wir gehen alles von A bis Z durch. Wir schaffen einmal einen großen, dicken, fetten Haufen. Nicht unbedingt, indem du jetzt die ganzen Bits zusammen schiebst, aber sozusagen nichts außerhalb dieses Problems belässt. Und dann geht man da durch und schafft sich ein System und dann wird alles da reingegossen. Bis nichts mehr in dem alten System ist, sondern alles ist irgendwie in dem neuen System. Und wenn ich sie so in diesen Raum hüpfen sehe, in dieser einen Sekunde und ihre Augen leuchten, dieses Geil, was man hier alles entflechten kann. Hammer! Ich mag die Frau jetzt schon, auch wenn ich sie noch nicht habe sprechen gesehen. Aber ich finde den Ansatz fantastisch. Ich bin begeistert. Vielleicht wird es die erste Netflix-Serie sein, die ich mir überhaupt anschaue.
Ich wüsste auf jeden Fall gerne, ob sich das auf deinen, also wie lange das anhält, deine Begeisterung für die Serie und ob es dich dazu verleitet, die Meta-Ebene aufzuräumen. Also ich finde es übrigens hier nicht unordentlich, aber du scheinst ja selber so ein bisschen unzufrieden zu sein.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen Overload. Es sind ungefähr zehn Prozent mehr Dinge drin, als dieser Raum verkraftet derzeit. Ich habe aber schon eigentlich eine sehr gute Ordnung, wo Sachen sind. Ich habe nur noch, ich habe derzeit nur von allem ein bisschen zu viel. Ich habe ein bisschen zu viel altes Gerät, was ich nicht mehr benutze, aber noch nicht verkraftet habe.
Aber du kannst dich nicht trennen.
Doch, ich könnte mich schon trennen, aber man muss ja auch mal dazu kommen und dann muss man Abnehmer finden und man muss sich halt mal kümmern. Zeit ist ja auch knapp bemessen. Ich nutze sie ja primär, um Sendungen zu machen. Und was weiß ich, es gäbe ja noch tausend andere Sachen, die mal genauso viel Liebe gebrauchen könnten in meinem Leben. Ja, dann hilft aber dann auch eigentlich nur dieses, ich müsste mal einen großen Haufen machen mit all den Dingen, die ich jetzt rauswerfe. Und dann halt eBay. Habe ich auch schon mal gemacht, also so ist es nicht. Und ich habe auch die Mitteilbene schon zweimal neu verkabelt.
Also ich möchte nochmal dafür plädieren, statt sozusagen zyklisch aufzuräumen, egal ob regelmäßig oder unregelmäßig, jeden Tag ein ganz bisschen so Zähneputzen auf dem Weg, wie man Dinge von A nach B trägt, das mache ich jetzt seit ein paar Monaten und das erspart mir diesen immer wiederkehrenden Frust von boah jetzt reicht es aber, weil es einfach, es ist nie perfekt, aber es ist immer unter der Schwelle meiner Aufregung.
Interessant, ich kann das nicht. Ich habe eine andere Herangehensweise. Ich habe Tabuzonen. Das heißt, mein Schreibtisch muss immer leer sein. Auf meinem Nachttisch neben dem Bett dürfen nur ganz wenige ausgewählte Objekte, meine Armbanduhr, mein Handy, die kleine Hülle, wo mein Handy reinkommt und meine Brille liegen. Ansonsten hat dieser Nachttischschrank auch leer zu sein. Ich versuche gewissermaßen über ein Flächenmanagement, Oberflächenmanagement, was im Endeffekt dazu führt, dass ich natürlich auch jeden Tag Dinge entsprechend in die Hand nehmen muss und sie von diesen Plätzen, wo sie temporär mal, das ist ja wie bei der Desktop-Metapher. Da gibt es ja Leute, die sagen immer, Desktop ist immer leer und wirklich nur für den Moment, dass man vielleicht doch mal was kurz abgelegt hat an der Stelle. Aber wenn das dann entsprechend final bearbeitet ist, kommt das dann in seinen entsprechenden Projektordner. Oder was ich momentan, deswegen war ich bei Tim so vielleicht jetzt so ein bisschen picky, ist es super aufgeräumt und ziemlich richtig ziemlich clean. Und deswegen fällt mir das vielleicht auch dann auf. Aber ich verlotere auf dem Schreibtisch, also auf dem Desktop.
Auf dem digitalen oder auf dem?
Auf dem digitalen. Das hängt aber auch damit zusammen, dass ich mein neu erworbenes MacBook Pro 13 Zoll, diese neue Klasse, die alle hassen, mit der Tastatur, die der Tim verdammt. Aber das ist für mich überhaupt kein Problem. Aber ich habe sogar, das wird euch wieder gefallen, euch Fundamentalisten, ich habe ohne diese Blinkleuchte das gekauft. Weil ich war nämlich in Eile und habe quasi ein bestelltes, aber nicht abgeholtes, vorkonfiguriertes Gerät gekauft, das beim Händler rumgegammelt hat. Und habe es auch eigentlich dann deswegen gekauft, weil es eine Terabyte Festplatte drin hatte. Weil meine Idee ist, das wird mein letzter Rechner gewesen sein. Weil die Rechner-Evolution ist so langsam. Mein altes MacBook Pro von 2009, das benutze ich immer noch. Ich musste das jetzt abgeben, weil da diese komische Touch-Fläche, die hat uns irgendwie gesponnen. Aber der Rechner war nach wie vor okay. Und ich glaube, der wird 15, 20 Jahre durchhalten. Und bis dahin sieht wahrscheinlich die digitale Welt so aus, dass es diese Club-Rechner kaum noch gibt.
Also ich benutze ja immer die Desktop-Sediment-Methode. Wenn zu viel auf dem Desktop rumliegt, mache ich einen Ordner, wo alles reinkommt, inklusive dem Ordner von dem, wo vorher schon alles drin war. Und dann ergibt sich so eine Sedimentierung von Desktop-Ordnern, weil halt immer wieder ein neuer Ordner angelegt wird. Und immer weiter, je tiefer man in diese Hierarchie reingeht, desto älter ist der Kram. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt. Vor allen Dingen, man kann dann auch relativ gut sehen, wie viel da an Platz verbraucht wird und kann dann die älteren Sachen irgendwann wegschmeißen.
Also Leute, wir räumen auf. Um nochmal Frau Kondo zu zitieren, sie schreibt, nein, also sie sagt, ich lese das hier im Untertitel, sie sitzt auf einem Sofa und sagt, Hallo, ich bin Marie Kondo. Meine Mission ist, durch Ordnung Freude in die Welt zu bringen. Ist sie nicht unglaublich?
Ich glaube, er meint es nicht ironisch.
Nein, ich kann sie gut verstehen. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch immer so diese...
Das ist aber auch sehr japanisch, oder?
Mit Sicherheit ist das jetzt auch sehr japanisch. Ehrlich gesagt, wir kennen uns ja jetzt auch noch nicht so lange. Aber was ich ja immer wieder ganz schön finde in dem Zusammenhang, ist ja immer so dieses Gleichnis von Chaos und Ordnung. Das ja auch so eine generelle Fehlwahrnehmung ist. Und vielleicht ist es an dieser Stelle auch einfach mal wieder angemessen, auf die irrisische Delusion und die anirrisische Delusion hinzuweisen. Ein Konzept, was nicht unbedingt jederzeit geläufig ist. Aber ich finde, an dieser Stelle passt es mal wieder sehr schön. Denn die irrisische Delusion, wie ihr euch ja sicherlich alle erinnern werdet, also die Annahme, dass das, was Ehres verkörpert, nämlich das Chaos, dass das sozusagen das einzig wahre und gute in dieser Welt ist. Und nur wenn die Dinge sich in einem vollständigen Chaos befinden können, dann sind Dinge gut, ist aber eine Delusion. Und dann gibt es aber auch die anirrisische Delusion, die wiederum annimmt, dass nur in Ordnung alles gut werden kann. Also nur wenn man klare Strukturen hat und alles in einer perfekten Ordnung aufgelöst ist, nur dann kann alles gut werden. Auch das ist eine Delusion oder Illusion, wie auch immer man das genau benennen möchte. Und die Auflösung ist, dass es halt nicht das Chaos und die Ordnung im Gegensatz zueinander stehen und man zwischen allem dieser beiden wählen muss. Sondern sich das hier um eine zweidimensionale Matrix handelt. Denn sowohl im Chaos als auch in der Ordnung gibt es immer eine kreative und eine destruktive Komponente, die es zu entdecken gilt. Von daher können wir ja auch keine abschließende Beurteilung dieser ganzen Aufräumplopomatik machen. Denn manchmal mag diese Phase des Ungeordneten auch eine positive Kraft entfalten. Man muss nur wissen, wann damit dann Schluss ist. Weil es definitiv auch eine destruktive Komponente im Chaos gibt. So wie es auch eine destruktive Komponente in der Ordnung gibt. Leute, die alles immer aufräumen, sind einem auch ein bisschen suspekt. Von daher muss ich auch sagen, vielleicht geht die Marie Kondo auch ein bisschen zu weit.
Ansonsten hast du eigentlich wunderbar dieses Yin und Yang jetzt beschrieben.
Genau, das ist es.
Man kann sich gar nicht richtig mit dir streiten.
Das Yin und Yang des Podcastings.
Vielleicht brauchen wir halt auch einen Ordnung Computer Club.
Jetzt kommen wir vielleicht auch langsam mal auf den Kongress hin. Wenn man und ich habe das ja auch mal eine Weile lang gemacht, nicht so viel wie Linus jetzt oder Frank oder so, aber auch ich stand oft einmal so in diesem Öffentlichkeitsfrontend, sei es durch Vorträge oder irgendwie, dass man der Presse zugeführt wird oder so. Und es ist immer ganz putzig, wenn die Leute immer so, hö hö hö Chaos Computer Club ist ja alles ja alles chaotend, ist ja total chaotisch oder dann, wenn sie dann sehen, wie so ein Kongress abläuft, ist ja gar nicht so chaotisch bei euch. Hört man immer wieder. Und das ist natürlich die aneristische Delusion, die da vollständig greift. Also die Mehrheit ist schon wirklich so in dieser Wahrnehmung. Andererseits kann man natürlich auch vollkommen unter den Lasser geraten, wenn man halt der eristischen Delusion anhängt und denkt, es müsste das Ordnung an sich einen schlechten Menschen aus einem macht. Und wenn nicht alles irgendwie stinkt und rumliegt, dann kann auch nichts aus einem werden. Trotzdem der Chaos Computer Club. Ich sage ja immer, jetzt habe ich zwei Dinge verwechselt. Aber trotzdem, der Chaos Computer Club, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was WAU damals getrieben hat, wirklich auf diesen Titel genau zu kommen. Aber ich finde es super gewählt, weil man sich ja quasi eines der unpopulärsten Worte genommen hat und quasi zu so einer, Religion will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber so zum Prinzip, zum ersten Prinzip, das erste Wort, was diesen Verein führt, ist Chaos. Und ich finde es auch mal wieder ganz lustig, wenn man eigentlich so innerhalb des Clubs davon spricht. Also wenn wir das Wort Chaos benutzen, dann bedeutet das ja, es ist ja zum Beispiel auch gleichbedeutend mit der Community. Ich bewege mich ja schon länger im Chaos.
Weil ich sage im Club. Das ist vielleicht so eine Generationensache.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eher eine Kontextsache. Also Club würde ich jetzt vielleicht sagen, wenn man jetzt konkreter auf die sich daraus herausbildenden Strukturen. Auf das jeweilige Airfahrt-Chapter zum Beispiel. Der Club funktioniert so, der Club funktioniert so. Aber vom Chaos zu sprechen und damit quasi diese gesamtkulturelle Phänomen vielleicht zu beschreiben, indem man sich eben bewegt, das ist auf jeden Fall auch so ein Ding.
Aber nochmal zu diesem Namensursprung. Damals war natürlich der Computer das Ordnungsding per se.
Ordinateur, wie der Franzose sagt.
Und dem das Chaos voranzustellen, war vielleicht überhaupt die einzige Möglichkeit, auch zu zeigen, es gibt einen anderen Ansatz an diese Computerei überhaupt. Weil aus dieser ganzen alternativen linken Szene war das einfach auch ein Feind. Als Technik und als Technologiefeld war das verbunden mit Rasterfahnung, mit Atomstart, also mit allen Dingen, die der Feind waren und die Idee über den Chaos-Computer, sich in einem Club zusammenzufinden, um quasi diese Technik für sich anzueignen und einfach eine ganz andere Perspektive auf dieses Feld drauf zu werfen. Weil das vorher komplett anders gelabelt war. Und auch in der Vorstellungswelt, das gehört nicht zu uns. Die Mainframes, Wissenschaftler in weißen Kitteln, Ende der 70er Jahre, das war höchstes Expertentum kurz vor irgendwelchen Atomfabriken. Und dass dann entsprechend irgendwelche selbsternannten Hobbyisten, Amateure, Freaks dann einfach hingehen und sagen, wir machen aber einfach ungeahnte Dinge, wir machen eine Chaos-Komputerei. Deswegen ist der Name von der Alliteration mal abgesehen so eingeschlagen, weil ich glaube, das fanden alle auf einmal befreiend. Zu sehen, dass allein schon der Name zeigt, wir können diese Technik aus den bisher gewohnten großindustriellen, großinstitutionellen Händen befreien und uns selbst aneignen.
Ich finde ja, es ist manchmal auch etwas hinderlich, dass der Name Computer da drin ist, gerade in Bezug auf den Kongress und überhaupt auf diese Community, weil daraus dann eben schnell diese Annahme entsteht. Es müsste immer alles was mit Computern zu tun haben. Ja, was man ja bei von Erstbesuchern auf den Kongress auch oft hört, ist so dieses, ich mache ja eigentlich gar nichts mit Computern oder ich bin ja gar nicht so gut mit Computern oder ich kann ja nicht hacken oder ich programmiere nicht oder so. Und dann automatisch annimmt, das würde dazu führen, dass man irgendwie nicht qualifiziert für diesen Kongress. Was, wenn man erstmal da war, also man merkt glaube ich relativ schnell, dass das überhaupt gar nicht relevant ist. Deswegen ist so meine Deutung der Sache auch aus meinem Verständnis der 80er. Würd mich jetzt auch mal wundern, wie du das so siehst. Für mich ist so ein bisschen in der Erinnerung der Computer in den 80er Jahren auch einfach das Symbol der Zukunft gewesen. Computer gab es ja nicht, war kein normales Ding. Es war ein Wort, was so keiner kannte. Heißt auch ja eigentlich irgendwie einfach nur Rechner. Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist Computer das Synonym für Zukunft. Also es ist eigentlich der Chaos Zukunft C wie Zukunft.
Zukunft mit C schreiben.
Da hat doch die CDU schon aufgebracht, den Spruch. Aber nur so vom Übersetzen her. Klar, das Wort ist jetzt da, das geht auch nicht mehr weg. Aber meiner Meinung nach bedeutet, hat es das vor allem bedeutet. Man hat es genommen. Einerseits, weil man sich mit Computer beschäftigt hat, aber für den Club ist es ja jetzt nicht unbedingt so, dass man sich da nur mit Computern beschäftigen würde. Eigentlich beschäftigt man sich ja mit der CDU.
Stell dir vor, wo hätte andere Interesse, hätte er einfach den Chaos-Raketen-Club gegründet. Dann hätte doch, ich glaube, das hätte dieselbe Reaktion ausgelöst, im Sinne von, was? Raumfahrt? Man muss nicht eine supranationale ESA oder sonstige Raumfahrtbehörde mit 4.000 Bürokraten und sonst was haben, sondern man kann einfach aufs Tempelhofer Feld gehen und anfangen, Raketen in die Luft zu steigen. So wie Werner von Braun oder der ganze Truppe. Das haben die ja angefangen. Und deswegen, Raketen gibt es auch schon ganz schön lange. Also für mich wäre das jetzt, der Computer war für mich jetzt nicht Zukunft, sondern das ist eine Gegenwartstechnologie. Auch schon Ende der 80er Jahre gewesen, weil sowohl popkulturell als auch in der Realität hatte man schon seit 30 Jahren mit Computern zu tun. Aber es war halt nichts für uns. Und mit dem Chaos Computer Club hatte ich das erste Mal das Gefühl und auch durch diese Bezeichnung, das ist was für uns. Und wir machen damit auch coole Sachen. Und wir bringen auch ein bisschen, ja nicht nur Spaß am Gerät und ins Gerät hinein, sondern wir zeigen auch den Etablierten, wir stiften auch ein bisschen Chaos, weil dafür sind die Dinge eben auch da.
Ja, man spielt natürlich auch ein bisschen damit, ganz klar, das Chaos zu sein.
Ich glaube aber, diese ersten Hacks, und ich weiß ja, auf welche Resonanz das damals, also eine Sparkrassenhack, ich bin da nur als normaler Spiegeleser draufgestoßen und das wurde immer begeistert quasi über diese, über die Medien gespielt. Und ich glaube, der Name war wirklich wichtig. Hätte das die kritische EDV-Nutzergemeinschaft gewesen, der Sparkrassenhack wäre nicht so eingeschlagen.
Absolut, da bin ich ganz bei dir. Da bin ich ganz bei dir.
Die progressive Dingsdergemeinschaft, peng.
Stellt sich raus, nach mittlerweile 35 Jahren, 37 Jahren, gibt es den Club immer noch. Und nicht nur das, es gibt auch den Kongress noch.
Ja, man braucht aber auch sieben Leute um einen Verein wieder zu beenden.
Ist das so?
Die kriegen wir zusammen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie du drauf kommst, aber ich wollte ja nicht auf den Kongress überleiten. Oder wollten wir das jetzt erleiden?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe kurz nachgedacht, aber es wirkte dann doch nicht so schlau in meinem Kopf und dann habe ich es wieder sein gelassen.
Okay, gut, dann bin ich jetzt wieder gezwungen, irgendwas Schlaues zu sagen. Okay, also es war Kongress. Wir waren alle da, also wir vier waren alle da.
Ja, wart ihr alle da?
Ich kriege noch mal bestätigende Blicke. Dennis wollte nichts sagen zum Kongress, weil er meint, er hat davon nichts gesehen. Aber ich glaube, so geht es den meisten dann doch immer auch irgendwie, weil das alles so groß ist. Ich habe mit Linus schon mal einen kleinen Rückblick gemacht auf den Kongress. Deswegen würde ich es euch gerne erstmal ein bisschen überlassen, vielleicht mal auszuwählen, was vielleicht rückblickenswürdig aus eurer Perspektive ist. Gerade den ganzen Teil netzpolitische Talks können wir glaube ich komplett überspringen. Wen das interessiert, mag man bei Lochbruch Netzpolitik reinhören. Der Kongress ist ja auch mehr nur als Talks und mehr nur als Community-Treffen, finde ich mittlerweile. Wie ihr das so erlebt mittlerweile.
Also ich fahre vor allen Dingen hin, um die Leute zu sehen.
Welche Leute? Alle?
Na die, die ich so kenne und die, die ich noch kennenlernen möchte vielleicht auch, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe, ich glaube, die letzten drei Kongresse keinen Talk gesehen. Doch, vorletztes Mal habe ich einen gesehen, einen oder zwei. Also insofern hat sich das für mich irgendwie so die Wichtigkeit der Talks irgendwie so weniger geworden. Aber es liegt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen an der Zeit, also gerade die letzten Jahre in Berlin, wo man sowieso nirgendwo mehr hinkam, weil alles zu voll war. Da habe ich mir so ein bisschen das Talk angucken abgewöhnt.
Du warst ja jetzt aber auch ganz fleißig. Du hast ja meine Aufgabe gesucht.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, die Aufgabe wurde so ein bisschen an mich herangetragen. Also um mal konkret zu werden, das Sendezentrum hatte ja vorletztes Mal keine Bühne, weil die Orga Power da irgendwie gefehlt hat. Das Sendezentrum, das die Podcast-Assembly, wo alle Podcaster sind. Also nicht alle, aber viele. Und ich hatte irgendwann genau auf deiner Geburtstagsparty, hatte ich irgendwie so im Scherz zu Ralf gesagt, wie ist denn das, gibt ja wieder keine Bühne, ist ja schade und so. Und dann meinte er nur so, naja, organisier du sie doch, dann haben wir eine Bühne. Und ich so, na gut. Jetzt muss man sagen, das war der 25. November. Also das war dann irgendwie fünf Wochen bevor der Kongress losgehen sollte. Das ist dann schon auch eine Stallvorlage. Da hat sich Gott sei Dank noch eine zweite Person gefunden, der Jörn Schaar. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, okay, dann machen wir das jetzt zusammen.
Das ist doch toll, da hast du doch auf einmal ein ganz anderes Kongress-Feeling jetzt bekommen, weil du musstest auf einmal mit der Orga in Verbindung treten?
Ja, gar nicht so viel. Also das Ding war, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, aber so genau weiß ich es nicht, dass wohl C-Punkt auch geäußert hatte, dass er das schade findet, dass es keine Bühne gab und er das gut fände, wenn es eine gäbe. Und da hat doch der Deutschlandfunk diese große Halle, also große Halle, sagen wir mal einen nicht ganz kleinen Vortragssaal und überhaupt und ob wir uns die nicht mit denen teilen wollen. Und dann haben wir halt mit denen gesprochen und die waren extrem entspannt. Also für so eine deutsche Institution, die schon einige Jahrzehnte auf dem Buckel hat.
Die Truppe, die da ist, sind ja auch irgendwie...
Sind die, die da sein wollen, klar.
Ja und die auch externer sind und so weiter.
Das habe ich dann auch alles gelenkt. Nur meine Erwartungshaltung war jetzt nicht, dass ich da auf so lockere Leute treffe. Wir haben uns da relativ gut verstanden und sind uns da auch nicht in die Quere gekommen. Ganz im Gegenteil, der Manfred, der das mehr oder weniger hauptamtlich da organisiert hatte, der hat irgendwie seinen eigenen Podcast und meinte dann so, ja, er wird jetzt noch gerne eine Folge aufnehmen, aber die könnte er, wer nicht erlaubt, dürfte er nicht mit der DLF-Technik machen und ob er sich denn bei uns hinsetzen könnte. Und ich so, ja, steht da alles rum, kein Problem, setzt euch hin, macht eine Sendung. Und da war er super happy. Also das war, ja, genau. Es war auch deutlich einfacher, als ich es erwartet hatte. Also es war dann letzten Endes gar nicht so schlimm. Man hat halt so mit den Verdächtigen gesprochen und gesagt so hier und da und kannst du nicht das, kannst du nicht das. Und dann irgendwie fiel das alles so zusammen. Und dann haben wir am Tag Null, ja, da haben wir schon ein paar Stunden verbracht, dann den Kram aufzubauen. Aber es gab jetzt auch keine direkten Probleme dabei. Also da war hier noch so ein bisschen Brumm, da haben wir noch ein paar Kabel umgesteckt und da war gut. Also das fand ich sehr gut. Jörn hatte sich vor allen Dingen um die, um die Organisation der Slots gekümmert. Also wer ist wann auf der Bühne. Und ich hab mich mehr so um den technischen Teil gekümmert. Also die Leute, die sich da gemeldet hatten, dass sie gerne eine Sendung fahren würden und so. Und insofern, klar, da ist man dann schon auch unter Strom und hat dann auch irgendwie nicht den Kopf frei, sich Sachen anzugucken. Aber ansonsten war es jetzt kein hektischer Kongress für mich. Klingt nicht so, ne?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Aber wie schön es ist, oder? Also wie schön es ist, dass du es gemacht hast. Also nicht hörbaren Applaus dafür. Weil es braucht halt genau diese eine Person, die sich das dann annimmt. Und wie schön, dass es halt auch dann nicht zu einer Überforderung führt.
Also wir haben natürlich, ich sag mal, so ein bisschen fast die Minimallösung gemacht. Das Ding war natürlich, wenn wir Ende November ankommen und dann mal beim Vogue, also die, die jetzt den Videokram machen, das Video Operations Center, da mal anfragen, wie ist denn das und so weiter? Und können wir da auch eine Kamera haben und so? Dann sagen die natürlich, Leute, ihr seid viel zu spät und das können wir jetzt nicht mehr leisten. Aber dann ist es so, dann ist völlig klar, dass die, dass die alles Recht und allen Grund haben zu sagen, nee, geht nicht, kriegen wir jetzt nicht mehr hin.
Das ist auf jeden Fall was, was ich sehr mag am Chaos im Kongress. Dass es nicht so eine, dass Erwartungshaltung irgendwie nicht so a priori dann bedient werden. Dass etwas, was schon mal da war, dann mindestens so oder noch größer passieren muss. Es darf auch wieder kleiner sein. Das sind so Kleinigkeiten. So ein Beispiel fand ich, dass die Fairy Dust dieses Jahr bei weitem nicht so toll stand wie im letzten Jahr. Auch wenn dieses Projection Mapping wirklich toll war. Aber jetzt kann man sagen, objektiv. Das hat letztes Jahr irgendwie die geileren Fotos gemacht. Das fand ich auch sehr repräsentativ, wenn das da so in der Halle war. Aber ich finde das hervorragend, dass es möglich ist, dass es wieder eins zurückgeht und auch noch mal anders wird. Und dass man sich immer nicht dem vermeintlichen Norm oder dem vermeintlichen Diktat, wie es zu laufen hat, unterwirft. Und ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall auch diesem Chaos zu verdanken. Also es klingt jetzt so nach so was Strukturiertem. Ich glaube, es ist auch einfach, weil Dinge dann einfach nicht stattfinden. Aber ich finde, ich kenne das bisher aus keinem anderen Kontext, dass so etwas numerisch und finanziell Großes immer wieder auch Erwartungen unterlaufen kann.
Naja, ich glaube, nachdem das Mal davor es gar keine Bühne gab, war jetzt die Erwartungshaltung vielleicht auch nicht so hoch an uns. So nach der Art, wir fangen damit jetzt wieder an, fangen von einem neuen Punkt aus an und fangen damit eher kleiner an und gucken mal, wie es sich entwickelt. Also mein Ziel wäre schon, dass Vogue nächstes Jahr oder dieses Jahr ja eigentlich wieder im Boot zu haben. Ob das dann klappt oder nicht, das muss man natürlich sehen. Aber ich glaube, wenn man mit einer anderen Vorlaufzeit an die Leute rangeht und dann warum sollte das nicht klappen?
Wie ist denn der Kongress für dich bisher immer so gewesen?
Ich? Ich habe nicht mitgezählt, aber ich würde sagen, es war irgendwie mein vierter, fünfter Kongress. Bei mir beginnt die Zeitrechnung in Hamburg. Also ich habe die ganze Berliner Zeit selber nicht mitgemacht. Und für mich war das auf jeden Fall der schönste Kongress, weil ich das erste Mal als so Privatperson da war. Vorher war ich immer im Auftrag von Jugendhackt unterwegs. Was ja auch super war, aber sich dann zum Beispiel aufgesehene Talks oder so niederschlägt. Also ich finde Talks auch einfach völlig überschätzt als Livesache, weil dafür gibt es halt einfach diese große, freie Unimedia. Und Gespräche lassen sich eben nicht wiederholen. Und Talks kann man noch so beliebig ins Jahr ziehen. Und das ist halt auch ein Weg, um runterzukommen für total viele Leute. Das noch nachzuholen. Das ist halt zeitsouverän und Leute treffen nicht. Und deswegen ist es auch sinnvoll, dass man sich dafür entscheidet.
Aber es gibt schon Talks, die ihre eigene Atmosphäre haben. Also gut, ich war dieses Jahr in keinem. Vielleicht gab es einen, ich weiß es nicht. Letztes Mal gab es diesen einen Talk über die Ladesäulen. Und weil mich dieses ganze Elektroauto-Thema auch ein bisschen interessiert, war das halt total spannend zu sehen. Das war so einer dieser Groundbreaking-Talks. Da hat mal jemand eine neue Technologie sich angeguckt und stellt natürlich fest, alles ist kaputt. Und zwar wirklich alles so sicherheitsmäßig jetzt. Von der reinen Elektrik sind die ja gut, die Standards, die wir haben. Und das macht schon so eine Stimmung im Raum, die so ganz eigen ist, finde ich. Also wenn so dieses Wow, da geht jetzt ein neues Kapitel auf. Jetzt vielleicht für den Talk ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ich hab's so empfunden. Und dann den nur im Stream oder im Recording nachzugucken, ist dann schon was anderes. Also das ist dann das Erlebnis dabei gewesen zu sein, als in Anführungszeichen Geschichte gemacht wurde. Das ist schon was, wo ich sagen kann, das ist dann mal ein Talk wert, aber nicht alle Talks sind so.
Absolut.
Also genau, das heißt, für mich war das der erste Kongress in Leipzig, weil letztes Jahr ich nicht konnte. Und für mich war es der schönste, weil ich irgendwie so rein privater, ich hatte mir irgendwie so genau eine Sache vorgenommen, die ich tun wollte und das habe ich geschafft. Und alles andere war dann irgendwie zusätzlich auf der haben Seite.
Das heißt, es hat dich auch nicht gestört, dass es jetzt woanders war und viel, viel größer war. Ich meine, die Veranstaltung hat sich ja nahezu um 50 Prozent der Teilnehmer vergrößert und von der Fläche her fair x-facht.
Also die Fläche hat mich überwältigt. Das ist jetzt natürlich auch eine 100-mal gehörte Story, aber das hätte ich mir, das weiß ich für alle nächsten Male besser. Das nehme ich halt ernst, wenn Leute vorher sagen, besorgt er halt einen fahrbaren Untersatz. Also ich kam halt in diese Halle rein, also in diese Eingangshalle, und mich hat einfach die Überforderung links und rechts gehauen. Man muss dazu sagen, ich habe auch ein schlechtes Knie, und mir war einfach völlig klar, ich stand da, ich habe gar nicht viele Schritte gemacht, und mir war klar, ich würde einfach diesen Kongress physisch nicht überleben, wenn ich mir nicht sofort irgendwas besorge, und dann habe ich auf Ebay klein anzeigen, mir noch einen Roller zusammengeklickt und zusammengerufen, und ein Telefonat, was ich dann geführt habe, war auch so, ja nee, meine Frau sagt, der Roller, der ist gerade weg, ja komisch, der hatten wir noch gar nicht rausgenommen, die Anzeige, und dann meinte ich, ja Gott, Kongress ist in Town. Genau, also ich habe noch einen Roller gefunden. Und na, es ist halt schön, dass die, also Architektur macht ja auch soziale Räume, und da war Hamburg schon einfach übertrieben gut geeignet, weil es einfach viele natürliche Ecken gab, die man jetzt irgendwie durch Abhängen und so versucht zu simulieren. Aber das ist noch nicht richtig, also da merkt man, das ist noch nicht, das ist halt nicht organisch. Das muss man sich jetzt irgendwie zu eigen machen, und das wird sicher noch ein paar Jahre dauern. Also das ist halt einfach so eine architektonische Limitation, würde ich sagen. Aber ansonsten...
Das ist keine Limitierung, sondern du musst...
Du kriegst es nicht geschenkt.
Du musst das Konzept...
Man kriegt es...
Also in Hamburg wurde es einem auf jeden Fall... Dufte man den Ball irgendwie sehr nah vor das Tor legen, und jetzt in Leipzig muss man irgendwie dafür arbeiten. Oder man muss vielleicht... Ist diese Idee. Man geht halt zuerst hin, um irgendwie Menschen zu treffen, die halt einfach maximal zwei Meter groß sind. Aber das findet immer in diesen Hallen statt. Das ist halt einfach so ein unauflöslicher Widerspruch. Ich finde, Räume machen schon echt viel. Und ich fand das auch interessant, dass immer da, wo Ecken angeboten wurden in Assemblies, die waren halt auch voll. Also egal, ob das irgendwie diese Hängematten waren, in dem einen Atrium oder irgendwelche anderen bequemen oder irgendwie heimelig anmutenden Sitzecken, da war halt immer was los. Und das war dann nicht unbedingt irgendwie das Heimatpublikum der jeweiligen Assemblies, sondern Leute suchen halt Closure.
Gerade Hängematten waren extra. Ich hab nie eine freie gesehen. Ich auch nicht. Alle Hängematten waren immer voll. Tag und Nacht, das war krass.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall eine Herausforderung, sich diese Räume so zu eigen zu machen. Aber ansonsten gilt das, was halt Sandra Trostlin All Creatures Are Welcome eigentlich so rausgestellt hat. In diesem Doku-Gameification-Film über den Chaos Computer Club und diese Szene, die so heterogen auch, wie sie ist, irgendwie da so gezeigt wird über das Chaos. Wie sie halt sagt, jeder erlebt einen eigenen Kongress. Und ich glaube in Leipzig, dadurch, dass es so groß ist, wird das halt noch klarer. Notwendigerweise so. Genau, es gibt einfach noch viel mehr Kongresserfahrungen jetzt. Und das finde ich halt gut, weil das noch mehr Heterogenität reinbringt. Aber da kommt man natürlich dann auch schnell zu so Diskussionen zu. Boah, der Kongress wäre jetzt aber wirklich zu politisch und die anderen empfinden das halt gar nicht so. Also einfach, weil sie Technologie völlig anders bewerten, weil sie aus einer anderen Ecke kommen, weil sie das für selbstverständlich halten, dass man irgendeinen politischen Impetus hat. Aber auch, weil sie einen völlig anderen Kongress erlebt haben. Es gibt halt einfach Leute, die habe ich einfach nicht gesehen vier Tage lang. Und ich war jetzt nicht, wie nicht, ich bin jetzt echt, also ich kenne jetzt nicht nur eine Person und ich weiß nicht, ich hatte einen schnellen Roller. Also ich habe schon Strecke gemacht.
Vielleicht bist du an allen vorbei gerollert.
Sagen wir mal die persönlichen Eindrücke von allen.
Eine kleine Sache noch zum Sendezentrum und den ganzen Podcasts. Ich paste mal eben noch einen Link in den Chat. Da hat jemand einen Feed kuratiert, wo alle im Sendezentrum aufgenommenen Podcasts drin sind.
Gibt es das auch einfach als Liste mit Links auf die Episoden auf den jeweiligen Seiten? Das habe ich nämlich schon gesucht.
Na es gibt von FÜD oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, fyyd.de gibt es diese Kuration.
Ja, ist das nur ein Feed oder gibt es das als Seite?
Das ist eine Seite. Aber man kann es irgendwie auch als Feed abonnieren. Ahja, ok. Ok.
Okay, das ist das, was ich gesucht hab.
Sehr schön.
Gregor, du bist ja jetzt schon eine Weile dabei. Seh ich das richtig?
Das war mein 20. Kongress.
Hätte ich dich dazu gerufen zum 15C3?
Nee, zum 16C3, also ich bin quasi mit der, als diese Ordinalnummerierung, weiß nicht, wie nennt man das? Diese Ziffernfolge, von der eingeführt wurde mit dem 16C3, deswegen jetzt der 35.
Wobei ich gleich dazu sagen muss, die Idee hatte Tom. Tom Lazar, der formelte die ganze Zeit, wir saßen irgendwie zusammen und grübelten über den Kongress und Motto und nichts fiel uns ein.
Das ist ja voll lustig. Einer der ersten Mentoren bei Jugendhackt.
Tom Lazar. Ja, und Tom pummelte dann irgendwie rum und zeigte mir, ich glaube, das war schon so ziemlich dieses Design, was es dann auch war, hat er einfach mal so gemacht. Ist ja auch so einer, der sowohl mit Programmieren als auch mit Gestaltung viel anfangen kann. Es sind nicht immerhin so viele Leute immer im Chaos, die das können. Und er zeigte mir das und es war einfach sofort klar. Man musste keine zehnte Sekunde darüber nachdenken. Es war klar, dass das einfach Fuss aufs Auge war. Auch weil es die 16 war. Weil es auch irgendwie in der 2er-Podcast alles passte zusammen. Ich fand es geil, wie unmittelbar und genau mit der selben Selbstverständlichkeit, dass auch alle sofort, jeder, der das gesehen hat, wusste sofort, das ist es und das wird es für immer sein.
Und dann auch diese retrograde Vereinnahmung aller anderen Kongressen, die bis dahin...
Ja, der 15C3 und so, den gab es nie.
Bericht am Anfang ein bisschen so 1C3, 2C3, das Vok hat das irgendwie, glaube ich, mal irgendwo automatisiert. Das ist keine gute Idee.
Ja, also ich hatte einen extremen...
Also es war jetzt der 20.
Das ist mal mein 20. also persönlich mein 20. Kongress in der Reihe, weil ich einfach weiß, dass ich nie gefehlt habe. Und ich hatte aber eher so ein, muss dazu sagen, ich war ja beim letzten Kongress, hatte ich so das Gefühl, jetzt habe ich Kongress durchgespielt, weil relativ spät kam quasi die Anfrage, ob ich das Kongressdesign machen sollte. Und das war dann doch, das war ein ganz schöner Ritt. Und so, dass ich dann auch so ein bisschen, ja mit einem gewissen Abstand in das Folgejahr gegangen bin. Und ich weiß, dass ich überhaupt nicht in Kongressmut war und auch nicht so mit niemandem gesprochen hatte, was jetzt das Motto sein könnte und dies und jenes. Also ich habe mich da auch nicht so weiter drum gekümmert und habe mir so, das weiß ich noch, die ersten CFP-Geschichten oder dann und dann beginnt die Karten-Geschichte und ich habe wirklich diesmal, ich würde mich bestimmt ärgern, wenn ich dann doch nicht hingehe, also buche ich mir erst mal eine Unterkunft. Ich habe einfach im September oder August als das erste Raun, so hörte, ja, der Kongress kommt wieder, buche ich mir eine Unterkunft, aber mehr so als Pflicht. Und dann hatte ich ja schon die Unterkunft, dann bekam ich auch freundlicherweise so einen Engel-Voucher und konnte dadurch relativ sicher eine Karte für mich bestellen, dann war ich halt drin. Und dann kam halt irgendwie Weihnachten und dann bin ich quasi mit so komplett, ich würde mal sagen, ich habe das wie so einen Urlaub genommen, weil ich war in nichts eingebunden und hatte so das Gefühl, jetzt lasse ich mich mal überraschen, ich gehe dahin, quasi so lean back und ich habe das so sehr stark wie so ein Indoor-Festival wahrgenommen. Und ich finde, das ist ja auch zum Teil, passt das ja ganz gut zu den Leuten, die auch den Kongress so tragen und dass die ja zum Teil auch aus dieser professionellen Festivalszene kommen, dass denen eigentlich diese Messehallen schon wieder viel näher sein müssten, weil sie keinen Raum mit Einrichtungen und Möbeln gestalten müssen, sondern einfach Fläche. Das sind jede Halle hat anderthalb Hektar.
So kann man es natürlich auch ausdrücken.
Und da ist doch so ein Fusion-Macher oder so Nation of Gondwana-Mensch, außer dass der Boden härter ist und er nicht weiß, wie er, was weiß ich, die Dinge da einschlagen soll, eigentlich schon wieder in seinem Element. Und deswegen ist es für mich, hat die Veranstaltung jetzt spätestens mit Leipzig, ist sie viel, viel näher dem Open-Air-Chaos-Communication-Camp als den früheren Kongressen.
Man sieht auch mehr Zelte, ne?
Es sind, jede Halle hat 2, 25 Hektar. Ich hab gerade mal nachgerechnet, weil ich in Hektar nicht so gängig bin, aber es sind 150 mal 150 Meter pro Halle. Davon haben wir eins, zwei, zwei komplett, richtig komplett bespielt. Dann die Halle eins, wo ja nur dieser große Saal drin ist.
Ja und wenn man quasi mit, ich war jetzt ja nicht unvorbereitet, ich kann das ja schon vom letzten Jahr, und ich finde sogar diese räumliche Entzerrung hat dem Ganzen nochmal gut getan, dass also diese zweite Halle ebenfalls für die Assemblies geöffnet wurde. Das heißt, es entspricht mehr so diesem Festivalmood. Man weiß, man braucht mal mindestens 20 bis 30 Minuten, um mal so eine Runde abzulaufen und so an den entsprechenden Bezugspunkten mal zu schauen, was da so passiert. Man kann nicht mehr auf den Zufall vertrauen, dass man seine Lieblingsmenschen trifft, sondern man muss sich wirklich gezielt verabreden. Ich habe einfach ein paar Leute, die ich gerne gesehen hätte, überhaupt nicht gesehen. Das war jetzt aber auch nicht so, dass ich dann gesagt habe, jetzt muss ich, das kann ja gar nicht sein, dass man sich nicht trifft. Das ist aber passiert. Mehrere Leute haben das nie gesehen. Was auch wiederum unter Umständen so ein Festivalmood ein bisschen ist.
Das Problem hatte ich schon mal nicht.
Es ist mir auch nicht unternimmt. Aber dadurch entwickelt sich für mich und ich fühle mich da überhaupt nicht, hab da auch gar kein Problem mit, dass für mich auch das offizielle Konferenzprogramm damit und die Veranstaltung heißt ja nach wie vor Kraus Communication, Kongress, also für mich ist es weniger ein Kongress als wirklich ein Festival oder hat diesen Indoor-Camp-Charakter. Aber beim Camp gibt es ja auch so eine Programmschiene und die kann man ignorieren, ohne dass man dafür schön angesehen wird. Und so habe ich dieses, das ist jetzt ein optionales Ding. Ich habe ein, zwei, vielleicht, ich habe ein paar, der, der, also vielleicht auch fünf, ich habe schon jeden Tag was gesehen, aber ich bin nicht reingegangen in dem Sinne, ich mache jetzt hier Programm und gucke mir Dinge an, sondern habe mich mehr so treiben lassen und ich finde auch generell der Kongress, dieses, die Eins-zu-eins-Gespräche oder die Gespräche, die man in kleinen Gruppen führt, die sind so viel wertvoller und wichtiger, vor allen Dingen fürs persönliche Leben, weil sich da aus Ideen oder Konzepte entwickeln. Und ich war halt wirklich so in so einer, in so einer, wie soll ich sagen, anspruchslosen Haltung, dass ich erst am vierten Tag auf einmal mit Leuten in so ein Projektgespräch Geschichte kam. Das heißt, eigentlich hätte für mich der Kongress noch zwei, drei Tage weitergehen können. Wie halt so ein richtiges Festival, das dann irgendwie eine Woche dauert oder über zwei Wochenenden, hätte ich jetzt gar nicht schlecht gefunden, um quasi noch ein bisschen mehr aus der ganzen Veranstaltung rauszuziehen. Und generell, was für mich auch wichtig war, diese ganze Genussschiene. Also zumindest im Trinkbereich gibt es da ein paar gute Sachen. Leider ist die kulinarische, das Essen, das ist halt schwierig, das ist nicht schlecht, aber es ist halt nichts, wonach man sich zählt. Das ist ja inzwischen bei Festivals teilweise schon anders.
Wir können den Aspekt vielleicht noch mal kurz zurückstellen, weil ich wollte mal kurz darauf eingehen, was du sagst. Weil es ist ja auch so eine, wir werden jetzt noch einiges aufgreifen. Ich habe auch ein paar Fragen von Twitter noch mal notiert, was so Leute bewegt. Es ist ja so groß und man trifft nicht mehr die Leute. Das ist auch so eine Sache, die man häufiger hört. Ich frage mich halt, ob das eigentlich so schlimm ist.
Ich habe es überhaupt nicht so erlebt.
Ich verstehe schon und das ist auch sicherlich bei jedem so. Du musst schon einen gewissen Level an Vertrautheit wieder vorfinden. Sonst ist das nicht mehr dein Event. Ohne jetzt irgendwie an Leute anzudocken, wo du weißt, wie die ticken und wo du dich eigentlich auch darauf freust, die zu sehen, weil die einfach mit ihrer Art und so weiter immer wieder zu inspirieren wissen. Oder du weißt schon, so treffe ich X auf dem Kongress, dann gibt es wieder irgendeine schräge Story. Und das ist auch etwas, was ich mit dem Kongress verbinde. Alles super, muss man vielleicht ein bisschen anders organisieren, muss man vielleicht mehr suchen und nicht einfach nur geschehen lassen. Dass man einfach bestimmte Assemblies ansteuert oder sich eben explizit veranstaltet, ist vielleicht auch einfach mal mehr eigene Aktivität gefragt, wo man es vorher hat einfach treiben lassen können. Andererseits finde ich halt diesen neue Leute kennenlernen Aspekt. Auch das hatte man sonst natürlich auch. Aber ich kenne das auch von Veranstaltungen, die zu puffig sind und zu sehr. Wenn du da immer deine Peer Group um dich herum hast, dann spielst du auch immer wieder dieselbe Veranstaltung ab. Und ich habe gerade jetzt diesmal mehrere Male so Congress Buddies mir eingetreten. Man kommt so ins Gespräch und dann so, ach und eigentlich können wir ja irgendwie ganz gut und nochmal hier in der Story und bla bla bla. Und irgendwann merkst du, hast schon die dritte Halle abgeklappert zusammen. Und dann bleibt man auch einfach mal so ein paar Stunden. Und jeden Tag hat man sozusagen so einen neuen Freund, mit dem man über den Kongress zieht und dadurch natürlich auch die Veranstaltung wieder mit anderen Augen sieht. Und dann auch immer gleich wieder so, was dann immer besonders Spaß macht. Das ist natürlich so ein bisschen das Privileg, wenn man schon so länger da ist, die Szene ganz gut kennt. Da hört man so, ja hier, okay, du hast die Vorliebe. Guck mal, da läuft hier gerade einer vorbei. Zeig dem mal irgendwie deine Postkarte, die du gemalt hast. Oder übrigens hier. Guck mal, das ist die Person, die hat das Design gemacht. Und das ist hier irgendwie ein Telefon. So hier, zack, bumm, Pock kommt gerade vorbei. Dass man die auch alle gleich irgendwie wieder so neu in diesen Kongress reinpusht, ist so ein bisschen wie Autoscooter fahren. Macht irgendwie auch total Spaß. Bam, überall erst mal rein, dunnel. Also mir hat das irgendwie dieses Jahr sehr gefallen, auch wenn ich auch beim letzten Mal so ein bisschen so diese Unsicherheit gespürt habe. Bei allen so, wo entwickelt sich das hin? Aber ich glaube halt auch fest daran, dass du hast gerade gesagt, dass Maria, das muss ich erstmal einspielen. Man muss erstmal sehen, so das und das fehlt. Wie zum Beispiel so diese kleinen verwunschenen Ecken und so weiter. Dann bauen wir uns halt einfach mehr kleine verwunschen Ecken, bis sie dann irgendwann da sind. Bis alles nur noch viele, viele Landschaften ist. Da hat man gar nicht das Gefühl, da war jetzt die Halle, die hatte diese Struktur. So dass du wirklich in so ein Labyrinth von Abenteuer ziehst und jeder Bereich komplett anders ist und immer wieder von einer anderen Gruppe gestaltet wird. Da gibt es natürlich auch Grenzen, Brandschutz und so weiter. Hat schon viel Spaß verdorben. Aber ich glaube, das ist schon eine Zukunft.
Aber das klappt ja schon. Also wenn ich mir einige der Assemblies angucke, Comona, das ist halt voll so ein...
Künstlerchaos, Deluxe.
oder so Anti-Globalisierungscamp mit ganz viel Teach-in und Laden. Und dann gibt es auf einmal, was ein ganz großartiger Geste war, war diese Flotte der Open-Infrastructure-Leute, die quasi ihre gesamte Assemblée, auch die Tische mit... als Segelboot gestaltet, weil in dem quasi auch noch so eine Art Kiel so als Modell vor die Stirnseite des Tisches gestellt wurde. Und es waren irgendwie so zwölf so Spitzsegel, die wirklich erkennbar in dieser riesen Halle, 2, 25 Hektar, wie wir jetzt gelernt haben, da richtig herausgestochen haben. Und generell habe ich mich richtig wohl gefühlt in den Hallen. Das war einfach, ich kam da ja über mehrere Tage immer wieder rein und das hatte wirklich so ein Heimatgefühl. Also da fühlte ich mich wohl. Und das ist ja, und auch zumindest abends, wenn es dunkel war, war auch diese Transitionszone in der Glasrotunde sehr angenehm. Die Wurst. Ja, war dieses Outdoor-Feeling ja noch viel besser, weil dann ja auch diese beiden Bars waren. Eine richtig exzellente Cocktailbar, die ich gern frequentiert habe. Und gegenüber der Späti mit der Punk-Musik, der dann auch musikalisch einfach das Spektrum erweitert hat dadurch. Und wirklich auch eine gute Anlaufstelle, zumindest für mich war, um so meine Bekanntschaften irgendwo abzuholen, ohne die jetzt unter Druck setzen zu müssen, indem ich sie über welchen Messenger auch immer irgendwie auffordere, komm mal dorthin oder komm mal dorthin. Das passt ja auch irgendwie nicht so zu diesem Flow. Es soll ja einfach so passieren. Und dieses, jetzt verabreden wir uns mal für dann und dann, passt eigentlich nicht, weil es kann ja genauso eine Zufallbegegnung genau passieren. Also das macht man nur, wenn man wirklich, wenn es wirklich dringend ist. Und da hatte ich den Späti so für mich als als guten Anfangsmittel und Endpunkt für meine Tage auf dem Kongress. Da konnte man auch noch mal so am Späti echt die letzten Leute noch so abholen.
Kurz, wir müssen immer mal bedenken, es gibt auch Leute, die hören hierzu, die wissen vielleicht, waren auch gar nicht auf dem Kongress oder kennen diese ganzen Orte nicht. Aber Späti ist natürlich auch schon tausendmal erwähnt worden. Wer mit den Hallen zu Ort und nicht klar kommt, ich empfehle euch einen kleinen Google Earth-Flug über dem Leipziger Messegelände. Das ist ja relativ logisch aufgebaut. In der Mitte ist diese große Glashalle, links und rechts davon große Messerhallen. An der einen Stelle gibt es noch das CCL, also das Kongresszentrum, was etwas kleinteiliger ist, demgegenüber die Halle 1, die noch mal ein bisschen anders aufgebaut ist als die anderen Hallen. Und eigentlich wird alles bespielt. Und in dieser Glashalle in der Mitte gibt es halt dann seit dem letzten Jahr eben diesen großartigen Späti da, Anna und Wetter, also so eine geile Idee. Diese Berliner oder ist ja gar nicht mal nur so eine Berliner Kultur, aber hat so schon eine gewisse Berliner Prägung. Zumindest hat es den Berliner Namen dafür. Einfach so der Ort, wo man irgendwie spät abhängen kann, wo immer irgendwie schlechte Punk-Musik läuft und wo es halt irgendwie auch...
Da lief ziemlich gute Punk-Musik.
Wo es einfach immer diesen ganzen Bedarf gibt. Ob es Kaugummis ist oder Kondome, Kondome, Zahnbürsten, Lahnkabel.
Aber zwei Sachen, Gregor, wollte ich noch ergänzen, die ich gerade interessant fand, als ich dich sprechen hören habe. Also ich fand dieses... Du beschreibst ja eigentlich ein Flanieren.
Genau, ich hatte keinen Roller. Ich habe auch extra darauf verzichtet, weil ich wirklich langsam mich dann so durchbewegt habe.
Er steht halt zu so einem krassen Kontrast zu Tims manischer Barcelona- Vorbereitung mit Google Earth und so. Es ist halt das Gegenteil. Also alle bemühen sich um Geheimhaltung, es gibt eine No-Photo-Policy und es soll für alle ein Ereignis sein. Und es ist irgendwie so schön gleichzeitig. Also die Hallen sind halt sehr symmetrisch, es ist quasi nicht möglich, sich zu verlaufen, insbesondere wenn man noch diese geile C3-Nav-App irgendwie hatte. Also es war wirklich eine große Freude, zumindest auf Android, ich weiß nicht, ob das zu iPhone lief.
Ich glaube, als Web-Anwendung konnte man das benutzen.
Und das fand ich zum Beispiel viel, viel angenehmer. Man hat sich nicht verlaufen, aber gleichzeitig ist dieses Flanieren halt so eine total nicht aussterbende Kulturtechnik. Und man genießt es irgendwie richtig. Das finde ich total schön. Genau, und das waren eigentlich meine zwei Punkte. Also Flanieren und verlaufen, also hat sich irgendwie, also beziehungsweise nicht verlaufen, fand ich, hat diese Entdecken überhaupt keinen Abbruch getan. Also für meinen Orientierungssinn war das hervorragend, immer zu wissen, wo ich bin. Aber zu wissen, wo man ist, bedeutet nicht, dass es nichts zu entdecken gibt.
Ich fand aber verlaufen, also gerade in Hamburg, als ich das erste Mal in Hamburg war, war dieses, gehört dieses Verlaufen mit zum Programm. Sich in dem Ding verlaufen und Ecken zu finden, von dem man nicht gedacht hat, dass es sie gibt und die man auch nicht entdeckt hätte, wenn man immer den korrekten Weg genommen hätte. Das war, das fand ich relativ großartig. Also ich möchte hier eine Lanze für das Verlaufen brechen. Weiß ich nicht.
Mir hat das, ich weiß, also ich fand auch, das ist sozusagen, das war, das war standortkritisch, dieses Verlaufen in Hamburg. Aber mir hat das jetzt in Leipzig überhaupt nicht gefehlt, weil ich finde, dass es mir nichts vom Entdecken irgendwie weggenommen hat. Also ist vielleicht so anekdotische Evidenz, weil wir es halt einfach unterschiedlich finden.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also ich fände halt mal, dass das Experiment spannend, die Hallen so zu gestalten, dass man sich verläuft.
Da wäre ich sofort dabei.
Wenn man nicht aufpasst, was man tut.
Da wäre ich sofort dabei und das spielt ja.
Weil die eine Halle, die war ja so super rund und symmetrisch und strahlend und haste nicht gesehen. Und wenn man mal so, um jetzt nicht zu viel Tangente zurückzumachen, mal einfach totales Chaos in einer Halle veranstaltet, sodass man sich tatsächlich verläuft mit Wänden, die so gebaut sind, dass man keine Sichtachsen hat, sondern dass man wirklich in einem Labyrinth ist. Das fände ich eigentlich mal ganz cool.
Und zahlt halt auch auf dieses in Ecken willst du sein Ding ein.
Ja gut, Brandschutz.
Ist das B1 zertifiziert? Also in meinem Heimat-Hackspace-X-Hain gibt es viele Aufkleber.
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn man ein B1 zertifiziertes Labyrinth, chaotisches Labyrinth bauen könnte, das wäre mein Traum.
Aber was mir auch noch hinsichtlich der Vorträge noch aufgefallen ist, dass unglaublich viele quasi nichtkanonische Vorträge in den einzelnen Assemblies stattgefunden haben. Und die wunderbarerweise, aber fast alle, in der von Toto, Thomas Kolhoff, jedenfalls, das ist ein Mensch, der diese Mobile App da seit Jahren irgendwie pflegt und dafür sorgt, dass man auf dem Smartphone dann entsprechend das Programm so halbwegs in den Händen hat. Und der nimmt halt sehr, sehr viel von diesen einzelnen Assembly-Veranstaltungen auf, die so in dem offiziellen CCC-Veranstaltungsblock, jedenfalls so, nicht in einer zentralen Programmschedule drin sind. Und dadurch bin ich einfach viel öfters in so in so Nebenspaces gelandet und das war auch interessant. Dann gab es sogar eine, ich sag mal, Nebenbühne, die aber einfach so groß war wie früher ein normaler Vortragssaal, nämlich Chaos West, die das ziemlich gut gemacht haben. Und dadurch auch so eine Diversität auf einmal mit rein kam, mit so, dass ich schon sage, ich war bei Veranstaltungen, aber das sind halt nicht die in den großen Arenen, anders kann man es ja gar nicht mehr sagen, dann könnte es ja ganze Boxkämpfe stattfinden lassen. Und ein bisschen ist es auch das Problem, weil die klassischen Konferenzzentren, die wir mit dem Haus am Kölnischen Park, mit dem BCC und auch mit dem, wie ich es sag, CCH hatten, die sind ja quasi die Foyers auf die großen Veranstaltungsräume zugeschnitten. Die sollen ja die Menschen da hinführen, die sollen in den Pausen dafür sorgen, dass die Leute mal kurz schnell rein und raus können. Hier wird das ja alles gebaut. Aber es ist auf einmal ein Riesending, dass man sagt, oh, in einer Viertelstunde beginnt ja in Halle 1 der große abgefahrene Talk von wem auch immer. Und ich hänge noch hier im Assembly XY rum. Und das ist dann schon ein ganz schöner Weg, weil da gibt es durch ein sehr, sehr professionelles Crowd-Policing-System inzwischen. Du wirst einmal ums ganze Gelände geführt, um zur Halle 1 an der richtigen Stelle quasi reinzukommen. Hat den Vorteil, es gibt viel, viel weniger Gerempe als im letzten Jahr. Also meine persönliche, meine persönliche, ich hatte ein bisschen so Bedenken aus dem letzten Jahr, dass ich gesagt hab, oh, das ist aber nicht mehr so fluffig, so auf den Zu- und Abwägen, wenn man dann irgendwelchen Leuten nicht ausweicht, dann kriegt man, fühlt man sich wie auf dem Berlin-Alexander-Platz, so zur Waschauer. Und das hatte ich jetzt nicht mehr, weil wirklich, sie haben sehr, sehr viele Gelbwesten. Ja, Engel im Gelbwesten, also die ganz positive Dinge gemacht haben und wirklich dafür gesorgt haben, dass da weniger Friktionen waren und aber dadurch...
Es lag weniger an den Engeln, das lag einfach an der anderen Zugangslogik. Man konnte halt in Halle 1, die war ja das Hauptproblem, gleichzeitig raus und rein. Und diese Einbahnstraßen-Logik hat super funktioniert. Da kann man sicherlich noch ein oder andere rumfeilen, aber im Prinzip sind wir komplett von großes Problem auf überhaupt kein Problem gewechselt.
Auf jeden Fall, weil so viel anderer toller Kram ist, kann man sich den Kongress inzwischen auch ohne Kongressprogramm vorstellen. Also ohne diesen offiziellen großen Arenen mit den Hallen, die quasi, das sind so Programme, da muss man sich wirklich zu zwingen. Die haben ja auch keine in sich, so eine intrinsische Attraktivität, dass man mal sagt, ach, da muss ich gewesen sein. Also du kannst im BCC, das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen, wenn du nicht wenigstens einmal in diesem Kuppelsaal gewesen bist. Weil das gesamte Haus ist auf diese Kuppel hin ausgerichtet. Das ist jetzt anders, sondern das sind explizit so, oh, da will ich hin, das muss ich mir auch...
Das war auch bestimmt der schönste Saal, in dem wir je waren, also das Saal 1 im CCH mein ich jetzt.
Für mich ist Hacpe...
Ach so, BCC hast du jetzt gerade...
BCC, der Rundesaal. Für mich ist der schönste immer noch der... Haus am Königspark. Haus am Königspark, diese Orange. Für mich hatte der was von, vor allen Dingen, wenn überall die Tischchen ausgeklappt waren. Die Tischchen aufgelaufen und die meisten, viele hatten ja schon Laptops in der Zeit. Das hatte für mich immer was von Houston. Von diesen großen Mission Control Geschichten.
Das weiß ich noch. Das war das erste Foto, wo wirklich der ganze Saal voll war. Alle ihre Laptops draußen hatten. Das war so unsere Zukunft irgendwie. War da...
Aber der war gar nicht viel kleiner als dein Sendezentrumsaal. Von dem, von dem du vorhin so despektierlich gesprochen hast. Ich bin mir...
Ich hab gesagt, er war nicht riesig. Der war schon nicht klein, aber... Also irgendwie hieß es, da passen 400 Leute rein. Ich glaub, wir haben nur für 200 bestuhlt oder so.
Ja, und ich glaube, im HP waren es wie viel? 600, ne? Die so da reingepassene... Also was du jetzt quasi als nicht riesig so ist, der Zweidrittel des...
Schon klar, wir reden natürlich von anderen Dimensionen jetzt.
Ja, aber das Tolle ist, dass der Kongress dann doch für sich als Veranstaltung für mich eine Kontinuität hat, dass sich das, obwohl es so skaliert ist, der Charakter dann sich nicht verloren hat. Und ich muss mir das immer wieder klarmachen, wenn ich dann in eure Sendezentrum-Nische reingeschaut habe, das war von der Fläche, etwa im HRP, Haus am Kölnischen Park, im Untergeschoss das Hackcenter. Und wenn man da Leute über so eine Wendeltreppe in das Hackcenter runtergeführt hat, dann waren die komplett geflasht, weil man kannte diese Bilder von den großen Lahnpartys, die gab es so noch nicht, meine ich, zu der Zeit. Also, dass man so viele Menschen mit Computern in einem Raum und dann auch noch so zusammengefärscht und jeder mit seinem eigenen. Nur, dieser Raum war nicht viel größer als eure Nische, die quasi so ist.
Übrigens zu unserer Nische, das Radio Mono, wie heißt er eigentlich? Egal. Der hatte für seinen Sende-Garten eine Feuerschale mitgebracht, eine elektrische mit so komischen gelben, orangen LEDs und so einem Lüfter, der so ein Tuch zum Flattern gebracht hat. Und das war total faszinierend. Erst haben alle gelacht und zum Schluss haben die Podcasts aufgenommen, in dem sie alle um die Feuerschale rumsaßen, so im Kreis, im Gemütlichen.
Das ist ein total guter Punkt, weil ich glaube, dieses heimelige, vielleicht folkloristische, das fällt auf jeden Fall schwerer, in diesen Hallen zu realisieren. Aber ich wollte auf noch einen anderen Punkt hinaus, was so durch diese kleinen Subbühnen irgendwie passiert. Also geht mir genauso wie dir, Gregor, ich war zum Beispiel häng ich in der Chaos Zone Bühne viel ab. Das war halt noch mal so eine miniere Bühne. Und da lief halt ein 1A Programm. Da hab ich einen total tollen Talk gesehen von Simon Jokos über einen Daten-Guide oder Data-Guide heißt das. Und ja, ganz fokussiertes Publikum, das ist eben nicht, wo man hingeht für die großen Namen, sondern man ist am Thema interessiert, da gibt es einen inhaltlichen Austausch. Aber was bedeutet das für die großen Bühnen? Also wenn man das weiter ermöglichen will, dass es diese Konferenz im Kongress-Settings gibt, dann wäre es vielleicht eine Überlegung wert, mehr Agenda-Settings auf den großen Bühnen zu betreiben. Also das dann einfach zu bedienen und zu sagen, okay, wir können dieses Subversive oder so auf den großen Bühnen sowieso nicht abdecken, aber dann machen wir es gleich richtig und dann nutzen wir das für Agenda-Settings und dann sind wir gleich bei diesem leidigen Thema, ob jetzt irgendwie der Kongress politisch ist oder nicht. Also ich meine, jede Aussage ist eine Aussage. Aber genau, also das fände ich irgendwie einfach eine spannende Überlegung, ob man sich das dann sozusagen nicht in der Zukunft strukturierter überlegen will, was man auf den großen Bühnen sendet. In dem Wissen, dass das eben nicht auf diese subversive Schiene einzahlt, sondern viel auch auf Strecke machen und Außenwirkung.
Naja, Agenda, also der Kongress, also die Talks des Kongresses, die offiziell unter dem Level Kongress laufen, sind ein einziges Agenda-Setting. Das ist sozusagen die Auswahl der Themen, die eben der Club für die Szene und die Öffentlichkeit natürlich auch als relevant, als am relevantesten angesehen hat. Da sind immer viele dabei, die man vielleicht auch noch gerne genommen hätte, auch wenn ich glaube, dass dieses, bei dem Kongressprogramm mehr jetzt gar nicht unbedingt besser wäre. Das ist für meinen Geschmack schon fast zu viel. Es wäre vielleicht manchmal besser, mehr über den Kongress nachzudenken, als wir machen nur so viele Vorträge, wie eine durchschnittliche Teilnehmerperson danach innerhalb eines Monats auch nachgesehen bekommt. Da sind wir sicherlich schon weit darüber hinaus. Die 150, 160 Talks wird sich niemand komplett anschauen, außer ein paar völlig enttämmten. Auch wenn ich verstehen kann, warum man das will. Und man kann ja im Prinzip auch sagen, okay, wer sich jetzt nur für den Technik-Computer-Security-Kram interessiert, da ist ja dann das potenzielle Auswahlfeld auch wiederum schon viel kleiner. Eigentlich hast du schon mehrere Kongresse in einem durch diese Kategorisierung, der ganze Artbereich und eben auch der Politikbereich. Die interessante Dualität, die jetzt entstanden ist, dadurch, dass durch den Platz auf einmal so viele kleine Bühnen da sind, die ja im Prinzip auch Last vom Kongressprogramm wegnehmen, weil auf einmal Gruppen, was weiß ich hier, wie Freifunk oder so, die früher dann drauf gedrungen haben, vielleicht auch irgendwie einen Talk zu kriegen, um im Kontext dieses Kongresses auch einmal eine eigene Botschaft formuliert zu bekommen. Und dann muss man das immer so kodieren, dass es sozusagen als Gesamtaussage für den ganzen Kongress ist. Jetzt ist es völlig okay, wenn man sagt, ja okay, wir gehen jetzt hier mal zwei Stunden lang die Konfiguration von dieser blöden WLAN-Box durch. Das ist das, was wir euch irgendwie sagen wollten. Und hier ist irgendwie ein neues Release von unserer Software. Und jetzt gibt es drei Stunden Logfiles und Update-Informationen. Ist dann auch völlig okay für die Gruppe von 50 bis 100 Leuten, die sich das anschauen wollen. Und das finde ich einen super Trend.
Was anderes haben wir beim Sendezentrum ja auch nicht gemacht. Den einzigen Fehler, den wir gemacht haben, war, dass wir im Call for Podcasts nicht geschrieben haben, dass die Leute unbedingt ein Ticket brauchen, weil sie sonst nicht reinkommen. Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen blöd gelaufen. Da hat dieses Mal keiner dran gedacht, dass das unbedingt nötig ist. Uns haben sich ein paar beworben, denen wir das dann verklickern mussten, dass das irgendwie nicht geht. Und ein paar haben sich ein Ticket besorgt, ein paar haben gesagt, okay, dann geht es halt nicht.
Es ist wirklich eine Entspannung, zwar auf beiden Seiten. Das Programmteam, das kannonische, das offizielle, wo vielleicht dann auch im Zweifelsfall jemand vom CCC für gerade stehen muss, im Sinne von, wir haben das verantwortet, Herrn Sonneborn bei uns sprechen zu lassen. Das ist ja auch ein gewisses Endorsement. Wenn Sonneborn aber bei Chaos West spricht, kann man sagen, das ist ein Mitglied des Europäischen Parlaments, wir bezahlen den nicht, das macht die Allgemeinheit. Und warum soll der nicht auf einer Bühne in einer Veranstaltung sprechen? Also dadurch...
Moment, kurze Anmerkung, er ist auch auf der anderen Bühne nicht bezahlt worden.
Nein, ich meinte, bezahlt wird er von der Öffentlichkeit.
Schon klar, ich wollte nur den Eindruck jetzt hier nicht entstehen lassen.
Okay, also man sieht schon an Tims Einwurf, also man bewegt sich dann schon auf schwierigen und verminten Gelände teilweise und da ist eine hohe Intensität da, weil auch bestimmte politische Dinge da inzwischen auch tagesaktuell und von der Relevanz her mit rein strömen und das ist auch gut so. Aber gleichzeitig wird auch das offizielle Konferenzprogramm dadurch gezwungen, im Zweifelsfalle sich relevanter aufzustellen, zeigen, dass es besser ist und ja, es ist vielleicht auch ein Gesund... Also einerseits ist es eine Entspannung, aber gleichzeitig muss dann das Programmteam auch zeigen, dass es diese anderen Plätze eben mit guten Vorträgen halt füllen kann. Und wenn das halt irgendwie nicht klappen sollte, dann kann man vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen früher Schluss machen.
Wurde Chaos West denn vom zentralen Programmteam bespielt? Die haben ihr eigenes Programm gemacht?
Genau. In der Kongress App, was du hier vorhin erwähnt hast, ist diese Trennung so nicht gemacht worden. Kann man jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, ob das überhaupt wünschenswert wäre, das so zu tun. Aber stimmt schon, man muss schon mal gucken, dass man klarmacht, hier, ich will jetzt gar nicht so von offiziell sprechen, aber es ist glaube ich schon ein Unterschied, ob man sich quasi den Aufwand macht, wirklich mit einer Kurationsjury aufwendig mit einem CFP-Prozess Talks auszuwählen. Oder ob es halt so eine, naja, wir machen mal hier eine Bühne, mal gucken, wenn wir so kriegen, da haben wir so ein paar von unseren Buddies, die unbedingt was machen wollen. Ja, ist natürlich auch ein Problem, weil manchmal ist es halt auch so, was weiß ich, dann reichen Leute in den Talk ein, finden denen den geilsten seit geschnittenen Brot, aber findet sich sonst leider niemand, der das so sieht. Und dann kommen die halt irgendwie reingewatschelt und suchen sich dann irgendeine andere Bühne und posen dann groß in der Öffentlichkeit, dass sie auf den CCC einen Vortrag gehalten haben. Weil guck mal, hier ist ja irgendwie auch auf media.ccc.de, das ist natürlich in den meisten Fällen nicht ein Problem, aber es ist halt manchmal ein Problem. Weil du kannst ja natürlich damit auch Spinner eintreten. Wäre jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass wir uns irgendwelche Spinner eingetreten haben, die dann irgendwie Problem sind. Spinner jetzt nicht unbedingt vielleicht nur mit dem, was sie erzählen, sondern vielleicht auch Leute, die vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt so sehr aus inhaltlicher Erwägung heraus nicht ausgewählt wurden, sondern aus anderen Gründen. Und ja, das ist ein Problem, was jetzt diskutiert werden muss und wo ein Modus gefunden werden muss. Aber da bin ich auch mal relativ sicher, dass man ihn auch finden wird.
Aber ich glaube, ich glaube, wenn, wenn da sagen wir mal vom zentralen Orga-Team die Ansage kommt, wir wollen die Trennung stärker zwischen in Anführungszeichen offiziellen Bühnen und in Anführungszeichen inoffiziellen Bühnen machen, ich glaube nicht, dass es da großes Pushback gäbe.
Nö, das nicht, ist ja eine technische Frage.
Dann muss man halt irgendwie beim Vogue da vielleicht auch ein etwas anderes Design haben für den Vorspann und dann ist, glaube ich, läuft das.
Das ist ja eh so, das ist ja eh so. Aber irgendeine Bezeichnung, ich habe da schon mit Linus drüber gesprochen im Logbo-Nespiathek.
Nö, aber ich bin da total bei dir, dass das wahrscheinlich Not tut, das zu tun.
In irgendeiner Form.
Man muss natürlich auch verhindern, dass jetzt nicht die andere Wahrnehmung einsetzt, so ja hier irgendwie die feine Truppe meint, sie macht da jetzt was ganz Tolles und möchte sich da irgendwie abheben von dem ganzen Schmutz der Straße. Das ist damit natürlich nicht gemeint. Es sind natürlich, diese eigene Initiative ist super und natürlich sind da viele tolle Sachen. Aber es ist sicherlich auch sinnvoll, in irgendeiner Form eine Sprachregelung zu finden, die eben die Besonderheit des eigentlichen kuratierten Kongressprogramms, was ja auch ein Ausdruck ist, der ist ja auch so eine kuratierende mentale Gesamtleistung, dieses Chaos.
Platin Sponsortalk.
Nein, eben nicht das, sondern... Über Jahre wachsen ja auch diese Teams auch und erneuern sich und holen neue Leute rein und lernen besser zu arbeiten und so. Du wirst dich an diesen Übergang vielleicht noch gut erinnern können, der Wechsel vom 20 auf den 21C3. Ich meine, da warst du ja auch aktiv begleitet. Also Gregor hat ja schon... Wie viele Kongressdesigns hast du jetzt schon gemacht? 21C3 war das der erste?
Ich hab zwei. Zwei wirklich, wo ich sagen würde, da hab ich so das Lied. Und ich glaub, zwei oder dreimal hab ich dann noch in einer größeren Gruppe quasi mitgearbeitet. Könnte man jetzt sagen, so als Gremium.
Was wurden die beiden?
Welche beiden?
21C3 und 34C3. Und bei, ich glaub, bei zwei oder drei anderen Gelegenheiten war ich in so einem Klüngel oder Gremium und hab zwar Ideen reingeworfen, aber... Camp hab ich mal gepitcht, aber das ist dann irgendwie nicht...
Ach so, das war der...
Hat sich nicht realisiert.
21C3, das war mein erster, glaub ich, mit diesen...
Mit den Apple...
An die Apple Werbung abgelehnten...
Das war es. Okay, ich bringe noch kurz zu Ende, was ich gerade sagen wollte, dann müssen wir gleich noch mal auf das... Das bringt mich nicht gerade auf was anderes. Also der Wechsel vom 20 auf ein 21C3. Der 21C3 war ja mir und ich glaube im Nachgang kann man das auch sagen für alle sehr wichtig, weil ich hatte den damals so ausgerufen als Kongress 3.0, weil wir halt den nächsten Schritt gegangen sind so ein bisschen. Also wegzukommen von dem reinen Chaos-Chaos hin zu einem etwas besser organisierten Chaos. Das ist nämlich der erste Kongress, wo es eine Content-Jury gab, wo das erste Mal, oder stimmt jetzt auch nicht so ganz, also vorher bestand die Gruppe von Leuten, die den Inhalt des Kongresses definiert haben aus drei eigentlich nur einer Person. Das war so ein bisschen die Situation über mehrere Jahre hinweg und das war nicht ausreichend.
Die hat nämlich diese Konferenzplanung so gemacht, wie du aufräumst, diese eine Person und quasi innerhalb.
Die Kondom-Methode oder was?
Alles auf einen Haufen und was mich bewegt, geht durch.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der Vergleich so gut trifft.
Ja, aber die kamen so. Also es war dann irgendwie, man wartet dann auf einmal innerhalb von Bestätigung. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich hatte nämlich aus dieser Art und Beauty Schiene, da hatte sich über Seabase und Tims Camp-Organisation einfach so ein Untersub-Element Art und Beauty entwickelt, das erstmal nur so ein, ja was man heute ein Assembly nennen würde. Ich fand aber, dass diese Art und Beauty Schiene auch im offiziellen Kongressprogramm in irgendeiner Weise auch mit ein paar Vorträgen, ein paar Präsentationen drin sein könnte und hat dann einfach Vorschläge gemacht und die quasi an Programm.et, ccc.de oder wie man das nennt, quasi hingeschubst. Und dann dauerte es aber wirklich irgendwie bis gefühlt 21. Dezember, aber da kamen dann die Zusagen und zwar immer nur so ak ak ak, ja. Im 15 Sekunden Takt anhand der Mailheader war das dann ja zu erkennen, dass dann quasi die Vorschläge, wo dann bei mir als quasi so, ja so, so Vorschlagenden bei mir wieder die Leute schon, soll ich jetzt noch, soll ich jetzt in den Urlaub fahren zwischen den Jahren oder wird das noch was? Und ich, ja, ich werde mal nachfragen und so. Und dann kamen die. Deswegen hatte ich so diese Beobachtung, dass das etwas, ja, auf Last eines einzelnen Personen mit einem gewissen Bottleneck so versehen, dann nicht mehr, nicht mehr so zeitgemäß war, ab einer gewissen Größe.
Aber ich meine, wo soll es denn jetzt perspektivisch hin? Also wenn wir uns irgendwie einig sind, dass es eine Organisationsentlastung fürs Content-Team ist, aber auch eine inhaltliche Herausforderung. Wo soll es denn hingehen, Herr Pritlove? Also was...
In Bezug auf Content?
Ja genau, also ich meine, was wollen wir nächstes Jahr hören? Ein bisschen früh oder kurzer Einschub noch zu, warum ich glaube, die Stimmung auch so cool war in Leipzig und auch so ein bisschen Ferienlager, Indoor-Camp-mäßig ist, weil halt alle wissen, es ist noch ein halbes Jahr bis zum Camp. Also ich glaube, das schafft man. Das schafft man und es ist auch Vorfreude. Also es war ein total häufiges Motiv, über das Camp zu reden. Ich weiß nicht, ob das eben eine Räumlichkeit und zeitliche Nähe. Bin ich noch mal gespannt, wie es dann sozusagen wieder so der Recap vom 36C3 wird, wenn das Camp dann vorbei gewesen sein wird.
Das mag sein, über das Konferenzprogramm jetzt in voller Breite und Tiefe kann ich ja gar nicht so viel sagen, weil ich davon zu wenig mitbekommen habe. Und es gibt eine Idee, ich weiß nicht, ob die mal irgendwie länger, schon mal tiefer besprochen war, ob man nicht vielleicht den Kongress mit dem Camp quasi in eine Kategorie Großveranstaltung mercht und dann einfach sagt, wir machen nur noch alle zwei Jahre die Veranstaltung. Einmal im Sommer und dann einmal im Winter. Einfach um, weil inzwischen das so viele Kräfte bindet, auch im Verein, weil dazu will ich auch noch später noch was sagen, es ist die meines Erachtens die größte Konferenzveranstaltung, die jährlich stattfindet in Deutschland.
Nee, in Europa mindestens, wenn nicht über weltweit.
Okay, weil alles andere sind irgendwie ein Tages-Aktionärsversammlung, die sind aber nur einen Tag. Oder du hast Ärzte-Kongresse, da kommen auch 12.000 bis 15.000 Leute, die sind aber, selbst wenn die jährlich sind, finden die immer in einem anderen Land statt. Also das heißt, die gehen weltweit auf Tour. Also das ist so etwas, jährlich in einem Land stattfinden, das ist einzigartig und das wird aber von einer nicht professionellen Gruppe organisiert und man sieht das ja bei einer kleineren Veranstaltung wie die Republika zum Beispiel, die haben halt über das Jahr eine Vollzeit-Team von mindestens fünf bis sieben Leute, schätze ich mal, die rund ums Jahr nur dafür arbeiten. Und das ist eben nicht der Fall beim Kongress, sodass die Idee gewesen wäre, wir entlasten das, machen das nur noch alle zwei Jahre. Und dann bekam ich aber wirklich das auch glaubwürdig, dass eben der Kongress auch als Sicherheitskonferenz in diesem ganz speziellen Kernbereich, Hacker, Technik, IT, braucht man so eine jährliche Recap. Weil sonst, und daraus ist diese Veranstaltung auch erwachsen und es braucht diesen Kern und diese Aktualität, da kann man nicht irgendwie zwei Jahre warten. Dann ist das verbrannt, das hat sich so eingebürgert und das ist auch nach wie vor, glaube ich, ein wichtiger Punkt auch für viele, die dahin gehen wollen.
Also nicht nur in diesem Hacker- und Security-Bereich, denke ich, alle Bereiche, die der Kongress, auch gerade politischen Dinge ist, dieses jährliche Bilanzziehen, gerade am Ende des Jahres, füllt einen riesen Bedarf.
Gut, aber ich sag mal bei Wissenschaft und bei jetzt heißt es irgendwie Art and Culture, würde ich jetzt sagen, da werden nicht die Trends gesetzt für die Gesamtszene. Ja, also die Wissenschaft wird auch weiter forschen, wenn es keinen Zweck gäbe.
Also der Kongress ist auch schon längst entkoppelt von dieser Szene, die sie geschaffen hat. Der Club in meinen Augen stellt den Kern, die Kernleitkultur sozusagen für diesen Kongress. Und das meine ich ganz positiv, weil vieles von dem, wie der Kongress eben ist, daraus entstanden ist. Wie die Leute sich begegnen, die Art der Kommunikation, dieser Perfektionsdrang, all das, was so diesen Kongress ausmacht, ist halt daraus entstanden. Aber der Kongress ist schon längst nicht mehr nur in der Hand des Clubs selber, sondern das fängt in meinen Augen seit ein paar Jahren an, einfach ein Gesellschaftskongress zu werden, der sich in zunehmendem Maße einer breiteren, aufgeschlossenen, mitdenkenden Öffentlichkeit stellt. Und das sehen wir dann halt auch durch Präsenzen von Leuten und Künstlern und meint wegen auch Politikern, also zumindest Spaßpolitikern, die verstanden haben, dass der Kongress der Ort ist, wo man die Leute trifft, wo man wirklich, wirklich, wirklich über den Zustand der Welt und die Zukunft und wie man es ändern kann, reden kann. Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass man auf einen Kongress, oder was, so kann ich es hier gar nicht formulieren, aber es gibt so viele Kongresse in der Vergangenheit, wo Themen diskutiert wurden, die zehn Jahre später absolute unbestrittene gesellschaftliche Relevanz hatten. Nicht nur Technik, auch Technik, aber auch andere Sachen. Und das ist ein visionäres Potenzial, das meiner Meinung nach auch diesen jährlichen Rhythmus einfach benötigt, damit diese Maschine auch weiter läuft.
Aber es waren ja auch zwei Sachen, die du angesprochen hast, Gregor. Also das eine, finde ich, ist der Turnus und das andere ist so das Thema Burnout-Kultur, ja. Also solange es so Begriffe wie bezahlter Aktivismus gibt, um sozusagen bezahltes Engagement zu diskreditieren, finde ich, nimmt man sich was weg, was man auch eleganter lösen könnte. Also ich sage nicht, dass Bezahlung die Lösung ist. Also das habe ich jetzt gerade keinen Bock aufzumachen, aber das war ja definitiv eine Komponente, die du in dem Zuge mit erwähnt hast. Deswegen fand ich das so gut. Roddy meinte eben so, ja das war ganz entspannt und super spät eigentlich benachrichtigt worden oder super spät noch gezuckt und war alles entspannt. Deswegen so, also genau, toll, dass du es gemacht hast, aber auch toll, dass es halt so ging, ne? Aber ich weiß halt nicht, ob es allen so geht. Ob es allen, ob der Kongress ist rein von Ehrenamtlichen getragen, ob das für alle so entspannt ist.
Das ist glaube ich eine Typfrage. Also ich glaube, dass da sehr viele Leute sind, die haben halt Spaß daran, sich in ihrem Ding zu engagieren oder aber mit Technik zu spielen, mit denen sie sonst nicht spielen können. Also man hört es gerade aus diesen ganzen Operation Centers, dass die Leute halt einfach super viel Spaß daran haben, diesen ganzen Kram aufzubauen und zu tun und zu machen.
Und du hast das nur mit Leuten zu tun, die das tun, weil sie Spaß daran haben.
Sicherlich kann es den einen oder anderen geben, der aus einer irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, falsch empfundenen Pflichtbewusstsein sich überarbeitet und am Ende sagt, irgendwie hatte ich dann doch nichts dafür von. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht die Regel.
Die Leute steigen dann auch irgendwann aus und das ist dann auch meistens kein Problem. Also auch Leute, die jetzt so zwei, drei Jahre irgendwelche neuen Spaces aufgebaut haben und dann jetzt zu diesem Kongress gesagt haben, nenne ich jetzt mal keine Beispiele, aber gab es. So ist mir jetzt alles zu viel. Ihr könnt mich anrufen, aber ich mache nichts. Und dann ist der Bereich danach noch toller irgendwie, weil immer wenn man so ein Vakuum erzeugt und dann Leute so, oh Gott, jetzt könnte das, was ich toll finde, auf einmal nicht gut werden und so. Da stürze ich mich jetzt rein. Dann wird es meistens noch, noch besser. Das ist das Irre. Aber trotzdem hat das eine Bedeutung oder finde ich den Hinweis ganz gut, diese Diskreditierung von bezahlten Aktivismus, das steckt natürlich ein bisschen in den Begriff unbezahlter oder freiwilliger Aktivismus drin. Ich finde es jetzt auch generell nicht schlecht, wenn Leute dafür eine finanzielle Unterstützung bekommen, dass sie Aktivismus betreiben, weil das unter Umständen ist, sie ihn überhaupt erst ermöglichen. Da gibt es auch viele, viele gute Beispiele, wo das hervorragend funktioniert. Das ist natürlich jetzt eine spezifische Sache mit dem Chaos Computer Club, die schlicht den Grund hat, dass man eben nicht möchte, dass Leute, die dann aus irgendwelchen Gründen für was bezahlt werden, dann die Dinge dann immer so weiter machen und auch so gestalten, damit diese Bezahlung und diese Position so erhalten bleibt und es sich nicht organisch ändert. Und damit ist der Club insgesamt halt sehr gut gefahren. Und deswegen finde ich es auch in Ordnung, dass es als Prinzip beibehalten wird.
Das finde ich als Ordnungsprinzip auch völlig legitim. Ich wollte nur dazu anregen, dass das auch einfach...
Dass man nicht daraus schließen sollte, dass wenn es bezahlte Modelle gibt, dass die automatisch schlechter sind.
Dass die ersten schlechter sind und dass man sich auch klarmacht, dass es einfach eine privilegierte Geschichte ist. Also ich habe auch während des Kongresses nur ein paar Tweets abgesetzt. Der populärste war der, wo ich gesagt habe, dass das Essen echt besser sein könnte. Also dann kam auch der sehr gute Hinweis, dass es halt einfach nicht zu verhandeln war. Jetzt würde ich halt sagen, es gibt immer Verhandlungsmasse, da könnte man einfach noch mal sozusagen die Hinten mal reinstecken, weil es einfach nicht so nahehaft war, wenn man eben nicht geengelt hat. Und das können einfach eben nicht alle. Aber das andere Tweet, den ich abgeschickt habe, war, dass ich gesagt habe, ja so danke an alle, die machen, dass die Anwesenden da sein können. Also das habe ich mir irgendwie so einen Blick angewöhnt, in den letzten Jahren immer zu gucken, wer ist eigentlich gerade da und wer ist deswegen halt auch nicht da. Und es ist halt auch eine nette Geschichte, dass es halt Leute gibt, die sich dann zu Hause um Zeug kümmern, was man so an Pflichten hat. Und das erstreckt sich natürlich auch auf so diesen unbezahlten Aktivismus. Das muss man sich halt leisten können. Und ich sage gar nicht, dass das illegitim ist, überhaupt nicht. Also das Ordnungsprinzip gibt es auch bei, keine Ahnung, ich habe irgendwie Jahre meines Lebens für Transparency Deutschland gearbeitet, so eine Antikorruptionsorganisation. Da musste ich also, ich weiß nicht, ich habe meinen Vortrag in Jena Paradies gehalten für Transparency und dafür habe ich 50 Euro von der Gruppe bekommen und die musste ich auch noch abgeben, weil man gar nicht anziehen will, weil man einfach gar nicht Leute anziehen will, die das für Geld machen, weil daraus dann ja irgendwie auch so so ein Ding entsteht, dass man sich diesen Job erhalten will und so. Also da ist der Club gar nicht singulär, aber man muss sich das halt leisten können. Ehrenamtlich tätig zu sein und das einfach zu reflektieren und wer kann sich das leisten und was heißt das wieder über was wir abbilden? Das ist nur alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, das führt halt auch dazu, ab einem bestimmten Punkt, dass nur Leute, die genug Geld im Hintergrund haben, dann ein Arbeitspensum leisten können, dass halt darüber hinausgeht, dass du nebenher noch noch jobben kannst. Und das ist natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch ein, wie soll ich sagen, eine Auswahlkraft, die dazu führt, dass halt dann bestimmte Leute bestimmte Sachen machen, weil die haben halt genug Geld im Rücken, als dass sie die Zeit sich nehmen können, das zu tun. Das ist halt so die Kehrseite der Medaille.
Ich hatte vorhin gesagt, dass ich noch einen Punkt aufbringen wollte. Da geht es auch um die gesellschaftliche Relevanz der Veranstaltung, aber auch letztlich das gesamten Chaos, also Club und chaosnahes Umfeld. Und da ist mein Gefühl, dass aus dieser Graswurzel-Nischenentwicklung heraus der Club sich gar nicht im Klaren ist, welchen Einfluss er eigentlich haben könnte. Weil, wie ich eben schon gesagt habe, es gibt keine vergleichbare Veranstaltung. Und manchmal, nicht nur das zwanzigste Mal, das irgendwie so mitgemacht und miterlebt hat, für mich war im letzten Jahr so ein Moment, der mir das klar gemacht hat, da war nämlich Christian Ströbele auf einem Halle 1-Panel mit Constanze Kurz und ich glaube noch mit dem ehemaligen Datenschutzbeauftragten, bin mir nicht so ganz sicher. Und eigentlich sollte die Constanze schon quasi im Fragemodus und wollte eigentlich schon loslegen und da hat der Christian Ströbele, also wirklich noch vor, bevor er bei den Grünen war, war ja, er ist ein richtiger 68er, war ja Anwalt der AHF, Terroristen, stand also schon seit geraumer Zeit wirklich eine umstrittene Person und auch bei den Grünen ist er das geblieben und dann sagte er also erst mal, Moment, ich kenne diese Veranstaltung noch, da war ich vor vielen Jahren mal, das muss irgendwie in Hamburg gewesen sein, da war irgendwie so ein kleines Gemeindezentrum oder sowas und jetzt bin ich hierher gekommen und ich kann es gar nicht fassen.
Und Christian Ströbele ist ein Politprofi, der ganz genau, es gibt keine gesellschaftliche, zivile, gesellschaftliche Organisation in der Bundesrepublik, die auf jährlicher Basis so eine Veranstaltung überhaupt stemmen kann. Das heißt, der war regelrecht geschockt, weil er genau weiß, dass diese Szene, die sich da irgendwie manifestiert, ich nenne sie jetzt einmal Szene, kann man auch Chaos nennen, dass das eigentlich eine gesellschaftliche Kraft ist, die allein, dass sie sich so organisiert, jährlich in so einer Qualität eigentlich auf einem Level spielen könnte mit anderen großgesellschaftlichen Organisationen, wie Parteien, Gewerkschaften, große Sozialverbände. Der DGB wird es nicht schaffen, jährlich zum 1. Mai so eine Veranstaltung. Der könnte kein Festival der Arbeit für fünf Tage veranstalten, wo die Messenhallen in Leipzig gefüllt wären.
Taz schrieb ja schon letztes Jahr, irgendwie vergesst den Kirchentag, der wahre gesellschaftliche Zukunftskongress, das findet in Leipzig statt.
Genau, aber diese Kraft ist halt ungenutzt.
Genau, das ist etwas, was ich sehe, und das eigentlich auch schon länger. Und das ist, um es jetzt mal auch kritisch zu sagen, auch in der Rückschau auf 20 Jahre, es ist immer sehr viel Besserwisserei. Und worüber wir werden, wir letztes Jahr wieder gelacht haben, dieses Told You So Geschichten, aber die Dinge werden in diesem Land nicht besser. Und da muss man fragen, warum sind denn die Leute, die im Chaos aktiv sind? Was machen die denn unterm Jahr? Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, da verdingen sie sich irgendwo in sicherlich ehrenvollen Projekten und kommerziellen Strukturen, die aber die bestehenden Verhältnisse offensichtlich nicht verändert haben in den letzten 20 Jahren. Und da würde ich eigentlich verlangen, weil die Politik in Deutschland, die Gesellschaft, verschläft diese Digitalisierung. Und ich würde mal sagen, die Leute im Chaos machen auf mich zumindest den Eindruck, als hätten sie das verstanden, das besser zu tun. Dann müssen sie es aber auch tun. Und nicht nur, dass sie einmal im Jahr ein tolles Festival veranstalten, sondern irgendwie muss deine Organisation, Institution, irgendetwas muss diese Kraft, die da ist, in die Gesellschaft übertragen, damit es eine bessere Gesellschaft wird.
Ich habe, also um dir da so ein bisschen zu widersprechen, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ein Teil dieser Kraft aber auch daherkommt, dass es eben nicht gerichtet genutzt wird, sondern dass die Leute auf den Kongress kommen, weil sie das Gefühl haben, aus diesem Ganzen, hier ist eine Bewegung, die will etwas erreichen und so weiter, mal rauskommen, unter Leute kommen, die einfach nur da sind. Sind zwar Gleichgesinnte, aber es geht nicht um Kampf und es geht nicht um Einfluss und es geht nicht um, sondern man hat halt einfach mal Spaß miteinander. Also du hast durchaus recht, wenn du sagst, es gibt hier Sachen, die haben wir verschlafen. Aber ich glaube, gerade dieser Vergleich zum Kirchentag, also so eine Kirche, die weiß ich nicht, wie viele Milliarden von der Bundesregierung jedes Jahr bekommt, also vom Bund, aufgrund von Verträgen von 1800 Dunemal und es dann aber nicht hinkriegt, so ein Festival zu bespielen und dann halt der Kongress, der das eigentlich mehr oder weniger nur aus sich selbst heraus macht. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Kraft kommt daher, dass es von innen herauskommt und weil auch so ein Pluralismus an Meinungen und Nicht-Meinungen auch gelebt wird.
Ja, aber können wir uns das leisten? Und vielleicht ist das auch so der Hintergrund dieser Frage, ist der Kongress zu politisch geworden? Vielleicht ist das ein Spannungsfeld, dass die einen sagen, wir brauchen so eine Art private Sandkiste, wo wir uns quasi spielerisch austoben können und andere sagen, es gibt einfach dringende Probleme und da wird unsere Nerd-Kompetenz für gebraucht, um sie zu lösen. Mal nehmen wir die Sea-Watch, Seebrücke, Luft, also diese ganzen Rettungsmissionen, um Menschen zu helfen, die in Seenot geraten sind im Mittelmeer und wo was getan werden muss, weil es ein exzellenter Rechtsbruch ist, der da stattfindet. Mal ein Beispiel, wo ich einfach sage, da hätte man anders reagieren können vom Club. Es gab immer mal irgendwelche Leute, die gesagt haben, könnte der CCC unserem Webshop nicht so einen Vertrauenssiegel geben. Da haben die immer gesagt, was ist Quatsch, wer sind wir? Aber eigentlich hat sich doch etwas artikuliert in der Gesellschaft, in der Wirtschaft, dass in diesem neuen Feld digitaler Infrastruktur eigentlich sowas fehlt wie ein TÜV, wie so eine Stelle von unabhängigen Experten, die eigentlich so das mal durchgehen und sagen, hier ist ein Vertrauensding. Eigentlich hätte der in den 20 Jahren und seitdem höre ich immer mal von diesen Anliegen, hätte er nicht der CCC, er hat zivilgesellschaftliches BSI gründen können.
Ja, nee, hätte er nicht. Hätte er nicht.
Ja, das glaube ich auch nicht.
Nein, nicht als CCC, sondern als einen Stakeholder mit irgendwelchen anderen.
Aber wo willst du denn die Finanzierung dafür hernehmen? Also, du meinst so eine Stiftung Datentests?
Zum Beispiel, ja. Du kannst aber auch zum TÜV gehen und sagen, hier, ihr TÜV-Leute, was habt ihr denn? Wir könnten mit euch zusammen ein entsprechendes...
Wie super unabhängig der TÜV ist, haben wir ja gesehen im Diesel-Skandal. Schlechtes Beispiel.
Also vielleicht ist BSI auch tatsächlich nicht so die Zielgröße, die da so die Herzen irgendwie bewegt, aber...
Ich weiß schon, was du meinst. Nur man muss halt auch sehen, eben reden wir noch darüber, sind wir nicht überfordert, wenn wir zwei Großveranstaltungen im Jahr machen und was muten wir denn allen zu und als nächstes Stiftung Datentest und irgendwie BSI ablösen, man darf sich da auch nicht übernehmen. Also derzeit ist der Club extrem gut aufgestellt, was die Aktivierung der Community betrifft, die Breite der Community, die Bereitschaft da mitzumachen. Wir haben da eine mehr oder weniger breite aufgestellte Sprecherriege, die in der Lage ist, mit jedem aktuellen Hackerangriff, Skandal klarzukommen und in alle wichtigen Talkshows und Tagesschau, Berichterstattung, irgendwie kompetente Sprecher zu entsenden. Aber das ist ein Zustand, der nicht unbedingt immer auf demselben Niveau so bleiben muss.
Ja, aber andere zivilgesellschaftliche Bewegungen, wie z.B. Amnesty International oder Greenpeace, haben in jedem Fall mal organisatorisch und institutionell andere Strukturen entwickelt und sind aus meinem Gefühl dadurch einfach handlungsfähiger.
Ja, die sind aber gegründet, um eine Agenda zu haben.
Handlungsfähiger, das würde ja jetzt bedeuten, der Club hätte ja nichts bewirkt. Und da bin ich überhaupt nicht bei dir.
Nein, das will ich nicht sagen, ich meine auch sogar mehr bewirkt, im Sinne von eine quasi digital, also eine Gesellschaft mit zu formen, die den Ansprüchen der Digitalisierung gerecht wird. Und dafür sagt unsere jetzige Politik und die wird auch nicht mehr wach werden. Also wenn sie denn so wach ist, ist unser Land definitiv abgehängt. Und Demokratie liegt auch vom Mitmachen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, da war so eine Verweigerungshaltung. Und ich weiß ja, dass sehr viele Leute haben, die waren alle im CCC, aber sie haben aus beruflichen Gründen haben sie sich, haben sie Start-ups gegründet, sind bei großen Konzernen ein und ausgegangen, haben wichtige digitale Infrastruktur-Geschichten, aber immer nur so als die Experten, die in einem teilweise komplett gegen die Wand gefahrenen Megastruktur dann irgendwie noch was fixen sollten. Ja gut, das forderst du also. Ich hätte jetzt gefordert, dass man quasi schon, dann sagt, wir setzen Standards. Zum Teil gab es das ja auch, zum Beispiel mit dieser Kultur-Flatrate gab es ja auch Ansätze mal, so ein Grand Design im Bereich Urheberrecht auszurollen. Aber das ist nicht schlägkräftig genug passiert. Der CCC ist jetzt so eine Art Feuerwehr-Experte.
Der Vorschlag war auch nicht gut genug.
Okay, aber zumindest war wenigstens das Problembewusstsein da und auch mal der Mut, eine Gesamtlösung zu präsentieren. Das sehe ich aber auch bei vielen anderen, nicht nur beim CCC. Ich hatte vor längerer Zeit mal so eine Art Wikimedia-Stellen-Ausschreibung. Wie nennt sich das? So ein Pitch, wo man sich quasi für eine Stelle bewirbt. Da wird man ja in solchen Interviews auch gefragt, was erwartest du, was würdest du denn da machen? Und da habe ich gemerkt, die haben immer noch so ein Graswurzel-Denken, aber sie sehen gar nicht, dass ihre blöden Samen mit ihrem Gras die gesamte Gesellschaft überwuchert haben. Und sie denken immer noch, sie wären die Kleinen. Sie haben aber alles. Sie haben in Wikimedia hier in Berlin, gibt es einen Raum, da sind die alle erlegten großen Enzyklopedien der Welt als Trophäen ausgestellt. Die haben sie alle gekillt. Und das sehen die nicht mal. Ich glaube, dass die denken, das wäre eine Ehrbietung. Nein, die sind tot, weil es Wikipedia gibt. Und wenn Wikipedia einfach sagen würde, aus dem IP-Bereich von Bundesbehörden seid ihr mal für einen Tag gesperrt, dann funktioniert in Deutschland nichts mehr. Weil kein Beamter mal nachschlagen kann, was wo Phase ist. Die haben überhaupt kein Gefühl dafür, welche gesellschaftliche Macht sie eigentlich haben. Sie machen dann Kooperationen mit dem Oberbürgermeister von hast du nicht gesehen, über die Nutzung von der öffentlichen Library, anstatt zum Bundeskultur, gibt es halt nicht, zum Bundesforschungsminister zu gehen und zu sagen, gibt uns mal eine anständige Strukturförderung von unseren Server. Unsere Nutzer können und ihr selber könnt es auch nicht mehr er tragen, wenn ständig diese diese Inserts kommen. Gibt uns mal Spenden. Gibt uns einfach mal genauso viel Geld in realer Kaufkraft, wie ihr vor 30 Jahren für Encyclopedien in der gesamten Bundesrepublik ausgegeben habt. Und davon 80 Prozent an uns und 20 an die 100 anderen Pedias, die es noch gibt. Das wäre eine Forderung und so nirgendswo gibt es so einen. Das ist was ich...
Ich hab jetzt so ein bisschen den Track verloren, wo dein Rant und deine Kritik eigentlich hingeht.
Die Kritik ist, dass man halt in einer komplett unvorbereiteten Welt, die offensichtlich unsere Gesellschaft im politischen Bereich nach wie vor ist, obwohl die Digitalisierung im Privatleben schon praktisch komplett vollzogen ist, ist sie auf institutioneller Ebene noch nicht angekommen. Und sie wird auch weiterhin verschleppt werden und es wird nie was passieren.
Also deine Kritik ist vor allen Dingen, der Club und der Kongress ist nicht politisch genug. Oder was ist jetzt die Kritik?
Ja, die sind immer dagegen, aber sie sind mitgewachsen. In den 20 Jahren sind aus jungen Leuten jetzt mit 40er, Anfang 50er, die quasi in ganz entscheidenden Positionen der Gesellschaft sind. Und in den 20 Jahren ist Facebook, Google sind mega Plattformen entstanden. Und die selben Checker, die vor 20 Jahren schon genau wussten, worüber wir letztes Jahr wieder gelacht haben werden, die sitzen immer noch da und erzählen, worüber man nächstes Jahr gelacht haben wird. Aber die gesamte Gesellschaft drum herum hat sich in Form der Digitalisierung komplett gewandelt und die gesamte Gesellschaft umgestrukturiert. Und da kann man nicht einfach nur als Beobachter dabei stehen, sondern muss man versuchen, dann wirklich auch die Gesellschaft mit zu verändern und nicht nur mit an bestimmten Nadelpunkten, mit Expertise und sicherlich gut gemeintem Aktivismus versuchen, die schlimmsten Problemstellungen zu verhindern. Die Politik schafft es nicht. Die Piraten waren ja die Idee dahinter. Sie sind ja leider auch, man ist ja auch nicht geschafft.
Bevor ich das vergesse, ich habe gerade Stiftung Datenschutz gesagt und das war in meinem Kopf ein generischer Begriff. Jetzt stelle ich natürlich fest, es gibt eine Bundsstiftung Datenschutz.
Deswegen habe ich mich auch eben so gewundert, wo das herkommt.
Sorry, das war jetzt einfach frei assoziiert und tatsächlich habe ich mich innerlich vertan. Der Arbeitstitel im Club war immer Stiftung Düstentrieb. Aber egal jetzt, also habe ich vorhin nicht konkret das gemeint, was da jetzt ist.
Man konnte vor 20 Jahren auch nicht wissen, dass die Politik und die Gesellschaft so eklatant versagen würde und man konnte vielleicht auch nicht wissen, wie sich alles so entwickeln würde, dass quasi die Digitalisierung dann wirklich doch so rasant passiert. Zwar arbeitet man selber in dem Feld und man hat aber auch mal so einen gewissen Bias. Man lebt ja schon selber in der Zukunft und dann sieht man aber alle anderen, die noch im Dampfmaschinenalter sind. Und dann auf einmal kommt so was wie das Smartphone und auf einmal ist die gesamte Gesellschaft auf einem anderen Level.
Ich kann deinen Frust, der hinter diesem Rand steckt, total gut nachvollziehen. Mir geht es nicht viel anders. Mir ist da nur jetzt zu wenig Konstruktives drin.
Ich habe Gregor, ich versuche dir zu helfen. Ich habe das gar nicht so sehr als das oder so verstanden, sondern einfach eher so die pure Verzweiflung, wie wir halt irgendwie dieses Schiff nach vorne bringen, wo wir doch so viele fähige Individuen eigentlich am Start haben.
Da muss doch mehr gehen, das ist das, was du sagen willst.
Genau, da muss, also wenn es nicht hier geht, wo geht es dann? Ja, also ich glaube, das ist dieses, wie Gregor, wie ich das verstanden habe, auch auf dieses Thema gekommen ist. Wir waren so bei diesem Thema individuelle Verantwortung und ich finde es völlig legitim für Individuen zu sagen, ich habe hier einmal im Jahr, zeige ich, was ich das Jahr über gemacht habe. Ich habe Spaß am Gerät, ich habe Spaß so in meiner Kohorte und das ist auch irgendwie eine interne Veranstaltung so, das darf irgendwie ohne, das darf nach außen, muss das keine Bedeutung entfalten oder ich darf das erstmal für mich machen, also dieses ganze Frickeltum auch. Ich finde das völlig legitim und nicht jeder muss politisch sein, aber demgegenüber steht eine institutionelle Kraft und eine Institution ist eine auf Dauer angelegte Problemlösung. Das ist irgendwie die Definition und es gibt einen institutionellen Platz und ein riesiges Gelegenheitsfenster, das gerade gefüllt wird von digitalen Heimatvereinen, von Bertelsmann, dann gibt es noch so ein paar deutlich staatsnähere Träger noch, aber es gibt einen institutionellen Platz für politische Forderungen und für auch die Operationalisierung von Forderungen. Also nicht nur, wir wollen irgendwie oder es muss, weiß ich nicht, es muss Thema X geben, also hier insert politische Forderung und Folgendes muss passieren für die Umsetzung. Also das ließe sich auf so einem Kompetenzlevel halt mit Leichtigkeit machen und du hast die fette Bühne, das machst du dann einfach mal um 20.15 Uhr irgendwie in Saal 1. Und noch begnadet fähige Sprecher dazu und das ist glaube ich einfach nur dieser Leerraum, an dem du verzweifelst oder, das habe ich richtig verstanden und das kann ich emotional und als politisches Wesen wirklich vollkommen nachfühlen. Ohne dass ich selber, ich habe diesen Forderungskatalog innerlich auch nicht am Start, aber es gibt, ich habe das gestern in dieser Veranstaltung im X-Hain auch noch mal gesagt, also dieses Umgang mit Zukunft. Also in Finnland gibt es jetzt irgendwie ein Budget, um die Bevölkerung so an die Basics von künstlicher Intelligenz heran zu führen. Einfach als Bildungsprogramm und in Deutschland wird halt über das Cyberabwehrzentrum plus gesprochen und zwischen... und Leute, das also das ist einfach, das ist der Grund und Boden, auf dem wir irgendwie Zeug machen.
Oder nehmen wir deinen Jugendhack. Irgendjemand muss doch mal vor was weiß ich, wie viele Jahrzehnten gesagt haben, Sport ist toll und wir machen Bundesjugendspiele. Es gibt aber keine politische Institution, wahrscheinlich die Nazis. Es gibt keine politische Institution, die quasi so eine zivilgesellschaftlich interessante Blaupause, wie Jugendhack, nimmt und sagt, das ist eine tolle Geschichte. Wir wollen das in jeder Schule in der 7. Klasse haben.
Also das G in NGO steht halt auch für non-governmental organization, deswegen können viele kommen oder wollen auch nicht ohne Staatsgelder auskommen. Dein Wikimedia Beispiel zielt ja auch auf staatliche Zufinanzierung. Viele gehen deswegen auf den Begriff NPO, also Non-Profit Organization. Das finde ich ist auch bei vielen einfach viel treffender. Aber es gibt auch sozusagen einfach Gründe, eine zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation auch genuin bleiben zu wollen. Aber diese Schmerzen dieser Lehrstelle empfinde ich absolut so.
Ja, aber wenn zum Beispiel der Sekretär oder die Sekretärin der Kultusministerkonferenz der Länder auf Jugendtag zugekommen wären, dann ist das, wir wollen das in unsere Lehrpläne haben, dass ihr werdet quasi bundesdigital Jugend... Also wir wollen das quasi als ein festes Bestandteil und Angebot reinbekommen. Können wir das unter diesem Namen oder könntet ihr euch vorstellen, dass ihr quasi als sowas wie die Blaupause dafür schreibt und den Lehrplan oder die Struktur dafür entwickelt. Und dann wird das... Da gibt es aber quasi ganz, ganz viele tolle Sachen so auf dieser Graswurzel-Ebene. Aber es gibt eben, weil es niemand in der Politik gibt, der überhaupt auch institutionell dazu verpflichtet ist, solche Dinge zu tun. Und es gibt auch... Niemand nimmt das auf, um das dann auf die nächste Ebene zu heben. Und das ist ein so eklatantes Versagen breitester Teile dieser politischen Teils unserer Gesellschaft. Und das darf man, das dürfen wir uns nicht mehr gefallen lassen. Und wir haben uns das zu lange angeschaut. Nur ich sehe niemanden in der mir bekannten Aktivistenszene. Und das sind ja schon die entscheidenden Leute. Und auch Sascha Lobo hat das schon vor Jahren noch mal bei der Republika gesagt. Ihr seid alle Versager, weil ich bin die Person, die man anruft, wenn man was übers Internet wissen will.
Ja, das fand ich auch eine geile Ansage.
Wie kommt so ein Typ, der erst so spät zur Party gekommen ist und nur weil ich mir einen roten Niro gemacht habe und ich mir für nichts zu schade bin, habe ich etwas erreicht, wofür von diesen 1000 Leuten, die ihr mir zuhört, mindestens die Hälfte viel qualifizierter wäre als ich. Und der CCC stand aber schon seit sehr, sehr lange in diesem Rampenlicht. Wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen und ich meine, da hätte mehr passieren müssen.
Ich glaube, dass in Deutschland die Politik inzwischen halt auch so weit verroht ist, dass ohne Lobbyismus nichts mehr passiert. Und ich glaube, dass man viele Entscheidungen der Politik eigentlich auch nur noch über Lobbyismus begreifen kann. Und ich denke, wo man eigentlich ansetzen muss, ist dieses Spiel des Lobbyismus tatsächlich mitzuspielen. Ich weiß nicht, ob der CCC da der richtige Ansprechpartner ist, aber vielleicht hätte er den Atem in diesem Lobbyismus Spiel mitzuspielen und tatsächlich die Leute zu den Abgeordneten zu schicken und zu sagen.
Ja, kleine Informationen. Das ist schon so.
Das ist schon so?
Ja. Die wesentliche politische Gestaltung und der größtmögliche Hebel, den wir haben, ist nicht in Deutschland. Der ist in Brüssel. Dort gibt es Edri seit vielen Jahren. Der Club hat Edri mitgegründet, mitfinanziert, teilweise auch Leute gestellt und dort ist eine Menge bewirkt worden. Es ist nicht so, dass man nicht bei allem gewonnen hat, etc. Aber Netzneutralität, etc. Da ist schon eine Menge bewirkt worden und das ist meiner Meinung nach auch das Feld, auf dem man das aufziehen muss, weil eigentlich diese ganze nationale Leier greift nicht weit genug. Hier kannst du bestenfalls darüber diskutieren, wie eine europäische Richtlinie dann konkret umgesetzt wird. Aber entscheidend sind eigentlich die Gesetzgebungsrichtlinien bzw. die Grundverordnungen auf europäischer Ebene. Ich denke, dass es letzten Endes auch ein Erfolg des Chaos ist. Das ist weit mehr als nur Chaos Computer Club, dass so eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung durchgekommen ist, die vielleicht nach den Umweltgesetzen von Rot-Grün, der größte Exportschlager in der Welt im politischen Bereich, sich anzuschaffen droht. Das wird de facto in den nächsten zehn Jahren der Weltstandard werden, weil sich dem sowieso jetzt gar keiner entziehen kann.
Ich glaube, die Amis sind alle hintenüber gefallen, dass so etwas überhaupt möglich ist. Also diese ganzen amerikanischen Firmen, die plötzlich hektisch gesagt haben, wir machen nichts mehr mit Europäern, die machen ja Datenschutz. So war glaube ich ein extremes Aha-Ding, ob man jetzt Facebook damit knackt, das steht noch aus.
Ich gebe mir trotzdem auch recht, Gregor, natürlich bleibt viel zu wünschen übrig. Und vielleicht können wir uns auch nur darin sonnen, vor allem Abwehrgefechte zumindest teilweise ohne Verletzung überlebt zu haben, anstatt jetzt wirklich kolossal Landgewinne gemacht zu haben. Vor zehn Jahren, also visionär waren sie immerhin, haben sich da Frank und Rob hingesetzt und haben gesagt, da gab es ja viel Aufregung auch im Club. Ja, hier Leute, übrigens, we lost the war. Hat alles nicht funktioniert, Überwachungsstart kommt. Sorry, aber alles scheiße. Also wie könnt ihr denn das überhaupt sagen? Und hier die Wahlcomputer und wir haben noch irgendwie und so, na Wahlcomputer kam danach, aber trotzdem passte irgendwie nicht in die Selbstvorstellung der modernen Superhelden Hacker rein, dass man da vielleicht schon verloren hat, aber man hat ja dann gesehen, dass das im Wesentlichen so kam, wie sie es prophezeit haben.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang brauchen wir so einen Talk mal wieder?
Ist es jetzt nach zehn Jahren wieder auf dem Kongress dann?
Hat da auch solche Wellen geschlagen?
Nein, weil war ja jetzt kein neuer Titel, aber trotzdem ein guter Talk, kann ich nur sehr empfehlen. Sollten wir vielleicht gleich mal verlinken, die beiden Will-of-Boros.
Die Frage, brauchen wir so einen Talk, war natürlich, brauchen wir so einen Talk, der so radikal wieder Wellen schlägt, damit alle wieder wach werden?
Ja, ich glaube, wir brauchen noch viel mehr so total dystopische Talks, die uns sagen, dass wir verloren haben. Keine Ahnung, was weiß ich, was wir brauchen.
Aus dem Talk von Frank und Rob habe ich auf jeden Fall eines meiner absoluten Lieblingszitate. Nämlich, we need people that are post depression and are not afraid of complexity. Das finde ich ist ein hervorragender Leitspruch.
Post-Depressions-Menschen.
Und es ist aber ein Unterschied zwischen CCC, Menschen, die sich auf die Bühnen stellen und dort auch kluge Sachen sagen, und zum Beispiel dem Penn-Chapter, wo Schriftsteller sich irgendwie über die Gesellschaft aufregen, weil der Schriftsteller in der Regel wirklich belletristisch schreibt, die keinerlei direkten Bezug hat zu der Gesellschaft, die er kritisiert. Meine Kritik ist aber, dass wirklich bestimmt 80-90% der Leute, die im CCC ihre Meriten haben, ja wirklich auch diese Meriten deswegen haben, weil sie an entscheidender Stelle als Fachleute in nicht unbedeutenden Projekten dieser Gesellschaft, in der Industrie und der Wirtschaftspolitik ja integriert sind. Das ist, finde ich, der Unterschied. Du kannst nicht immer sagen lost the war, aber nebenher mache ich halt irgendwie mein Ding und werde als Sicherheitsinspektor für dies oder das bei irgendeinem Großkonzern da ein paar Kinken wieder gerade ziehen. Im Sinne von Dienst ist Dienst und Schnaps ist Schnaps, das ist was, was mich ein bisschen stört, weil es wären ja auch Geschäftsmodelle möglich gewesen zu sagen wir machen die Welt besser.
Das behauptest du?
Ich finde es eigentlich super, dass wir auf dieser Metadiskussion sind, vielleicht ein bisschen zu früh. Vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht notwendig, sich über alle Details dieses Kongresses auszukäsen, da könnte man jetzt wahrscheinlich noch tagelang drüber reden. Aber vielleicht räumen wir noch dem einen oder anderen Aspekt etwas Zeit.
Ich muss mich jetzt erst mal runter chillen hier.
Ja, er ist angekommen und so. Ich liebe solche Debatten. Das regt hoffentlich auch Kommentare an. Keep it coming.
Ja, hier Kommentare. Das muss ich noch sagen. Geht da draußen, ich weiß, es gibt so viele Hackspaces und Airfahrkreise. Guckt nicht nach Berlin und zum CCC und sonst was, sondern geht zu euren Rathäusern und erzählt, was ihr da macht und sagt, dass ihr die Zukunft seid, dass ihr eine bildungspolitisch notwendige Aufgabe macht, die der Werkraum in den Schulen nicht leistet. Geht dahin. Diese Politik ist ein System, das braucht extrinsische Motivation. Weil das ist ein in sich selbst rotierendes System. Und Lobbyarbeit ist nur deswegen so erfolgreich, weil dieses System hat keine Ideen für sich selber. Sondern es muss ständig gefüttert werden mit Ideen. Und es nimmt jede Idee, von denen es das Gefühl hat, dass sie erfolgreich für das System ist. Und diese Hacker-Community ist erfolgreich, die ist attraktiv, aber sie muss den Arsch mal zusammenkneifend dahingehen, zu den Rathäusern auf der lokalen Ebene und sagen, hier sind wir.
Auf jeder Ebene.
Auch auf der niedrigsten.
Du kriegst nicht so schnell beim Minister für Forschung und Bildung einen Termin. Aber Rathaus Recklenhausen wird vielleicht schon eher klappen. Dass man auch dem Bürgermeister mal die Meinung sagt oder ihn einlädt und sagt, das ist, was wir hier machen und wir brauchen mehr von uns. Wir brauchen Macht oder nimmt unser Vorbild und überträgt das auf eure Schulen und Berufsschulen. Das wollte ich noch sagen. Also nicht nur Kommentare, sondern...
Nee, du hast total recht. Und das kann man auf allen Ebenen machen. Man kann denen auch irgendwie auch am laufenden Meter erzählen, dass die Gemeinden eigene Internetinfrastrukturen aufbauen sollen und sich nicht von den Providern verarschen lassen sollen. Man kann sie nur ermutigen, mal mehr Hacker Spaces zu fördern oder andere Projekte zu unterstützen. Man kann sie dazu ermutigen, an Schulen Dinge anders anzuhaben. Man kann konkret ihnen sagen, dass sie auch innerhalb ihrer eigenen Parteien politischen Druck von der Straße nach oben leiten sollen und bestimmte Dinge mal anders führen zu lassen. Das ist auf jeden Fall der richtige Ansatz nach das Recht. Wir müssen da vielleicht auch noch mehr drauf drängen.
Und wenn die, die das machen, das schon machen, dann sprech darüber und dass auch so Leute wie ich davon erfahren.
Und ich glaube, es gibt einfach Platz zwischen Edri, was ein super Beispiel auf europäischer Ebene ist und hier gab es doch mal so ein Talk von Frank und Rob. Also ich glaube, einfach dazwischen gibt es eine Menge Platz.
Noch eine Menge Luft, klar. Auf jeden Fall. Das würden wir gerne sehen. Ja, Mensch, das war schon so hoch aufgehängt. Aber ich wollte noch mal so ein paar Sachen vom Kongress zur Sprache bringen, die mir sehr gut gefallen haben. Unter anderem habe ich von dem Twitter-Account at Hälfte erfahren, dass es dem Kongress dieses Jahr gewonnen hat, gelungen ist. 28% aller Vortragenden waren Frauen. Klingt irgendwie immer noch wenig, aber ist im Vergleich zu den Vorjahren ein riesen Sprung.
Was waren denn die Zahlen von vorher? Ich habe den Infrastructure Review Talk irgendwie nie so konsequent geguckt.
Moment, gibt da einen passenden Link. Und zwar den hier. Also 35C3, 72% Männer, 34C3, 77% Männer. Oder kann man hier auch auf Frauen klicken. Wieso sagen sie, wie viele Männer das sind? Sonst sagen sie, wie viele Frauen das sind.
Also ich finde jetzt ehrlich, also ich vor zwei Jahren 82% so.
Wir können alle bis 100 rechnen, glaube ich. Jaja, doch. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass unsere höherer bis 100 rechnen.
Vor zehn Jahren waren wir so im 90% Bereich.
Also diese Frauen an sich ist ja irgendwie kein Güteargument, aber diversere Sprecher ist halt ein Güteargument, weil das ist halt wissenschaftlich bewiesen. Diverse Teams machen halt bessere Ergebnisse.
Auf jeden Fall. Und das gilt auch für den ganzen Kongress.
Halt das kommt das das Computersystem. Welche Eingabe du machst, bestimmt welche Ausgabe rauskommt.
Künstliche Intelligenz braucht eine Vielfalt von Eingaben, damit sie die richtigen Entscheidungen finden.
In diesem Sinne, ich suche noch eine Android-Entwicklerin.
Komm jetzt nicht so. Doch.
Android ist besonders schwierig.
Das ist so ein Teil und deine Perspektive würde mich da auch noch mal interessieren. Dann gab es so eine Aktion von einzelnen Leuten, die so in der Halle 2 auch überall so Fotos aufgehängt haben, so kleine Tempel gemacht haben mit Frauen aus Wissenschaft und Computing, so der Vergangenheit, die irgendwie was gerissen haben. Das tauchte einfach so auf. Das ist auf einmal eine ganz andere Sichtbarkeit. Ich würde sagen auch eine andere Leichtigkeit, eine andere Selbstverständlichkeit, die sich jetzt schon breit macht. Damit man jetzt nicht nur so klar quantifizierbare Größen wie eben dieser Sprecherinnen-Anteil, sondern einfach das Gefühl hat, da schleicht sich langsam eine Normalität rein, die einfach sehr gesund ist.
Na, es gibt halt auch einfach Heroinnen in der Szene, die jetzt einfach langsam gefeiert werden, auch sichtbar. Also es war eines meiner liebsten Zettel, die aufgehängt wurden, also für alle, die nicht auf dem Kongress waren. Es gibt halt viele Türen und entsprechende Glasflächen.
Generell gibt es viele Zettel und Schilder.
Also genau, Schilder, it's a thing, so. Und es gab einen, den fand ich so geil, den wollte ich mir eigentlich abreißen, hab dann aber gedacht, nee scheiße, wenn das der einzige ist, dann ist das irgendwie auch Asi. Das war einfach ein hochkantiger Vierblatt mit wahrscheinlich der Silhouette von einer Frau und drüber stand in so einer Blogschrift Rönike und Streidel und Klingner. Also die, also Katrin Rönike, die ja glaube ich, genau, also Lila Podcast und Bauer Streidel und Susanne Klingner, einfach geile Podcasterinnen sind, da wird man wirklich nicht dümmer, das zu hören. Und es war einfach so, ja das ist halt unsere Band, so, das ist halt einfach, das kann man halt einfach gut hören und macht einen nicht dümmer. Und dieses Lila Podcast, man denkt halt an Lila Latzhosen, ich weiß nicht, was es mit diesem Namen auf sich hat, ich hab das auch lange nicht gehört und ich hab das letztes Jahr für mich entdeckt und es ist einfach, es ist einfach schlaues Hören, kann man wirklich, kann man sich wirklich gut antun und ich mochte dieses, diese, diese Sichtbarkeit und diese, diese kleinen Schreine für Heroinnen, die du gerade erwähnt hast, das war für mich gar nicht überraschend. Ich hatte das über irgendeinen Kanal mitbekommen, das haben die Hexen orchestriert. Also die, der Verbund von Frauen im Club und die hatten das halt so im Wiki dann zusammen organisiert. Genau, also ich finde so, Frauen sind genauso wie Jugend oder so, das ist kein Argument von Güte, aber die Mischung ist halt einfach super wichtig, um bessere Ergebnisse zu erzielen und um Sachen zu sehen. Also von kleinen Beispielen zu, ja mein Kleiderschrank kann nie so leer sein wie deiner, weil ich habe halt einfach Kleidung für einfach andere körperliche Zustände. Bis hin zu, also weiß ich nicht, es muss doch keine Geschlechtsperspektive sein, sowas wie, ich bin Linkshänderin und wie mich das abgefuckt hat früher, dass es halt in Microsoft PowerPoint irgendwie in dem Layout für Handzettel nicht möglich war, die Seite, auf der die Folien abgedruckt waren und die Seite, auf der die Linien abgedruckt waren, zu switchen, weil ich hab halt als Linkshänderin immer die Bilder verdeckt und konnte mir dazu keine Notizen machen. Was für ein blinder Fleck.
Auch Linkshänder.
Ja, hey, guck mal, völlig unrepräsentative 50% hier am Tisch. Also einfach so dieser Blick von, was ist eigentlich alles gerade nicht da, so, den kann man echt nicht genug schärfen. In dem Sinne, danke an meinen Freund, dass ich zum Kongress konnte. Vielen, vielen Dank, falls du noch zuhörst. Alleine vier Tage, wie so ein normaler Mensch. Und irgendwer hat sich um... Ach ja, und danke an meine Mama. Die haben sich um die Kinder gekümmert. Ziemlich gut.
Ich will auch noch mal unterstreichen, was für ein tolles Projekt die podcast ist. Also ich hatte ja gerade mal im CRE und haben uns mal schön ausführlich über Feminismus unterhalten und mich hat das bereichert allein inhaltlich und wir hatten uns auch erst kurz vorher kennengelernt und das war so ein bisschen auch der Beginn einer wunderbaren Freundschaft und sie hat dann halt so ein bisschen diesen Podcast-Virus aber hier mit aus der Metaebene rausgetragen und dann gleich richtig losgelegt. Die sind jetzt auch schon bei 124 Sendungen und Podcast Label gegründet und Pipapo noch irgendwie 1000 Auskopplungen und so. Das freut mich natürlich nochmal besonders aber du hast recht, definitiv absolute Rockstars schon in dem Segment oder auch ganz unabhängig von dem Segment. Also ich finde einfach mit einer der besten Produktionen, die man in Deutschland überhaupt so kriegen kann im Podcastwesen. Und da ist ja auch schon einiges zu kriegen mittlerweile. Also das ist ja auch generell kein Mangel an an guten Sachen mittlerweile. Ich verliere schon richtig den Überblick. In dem Zusammenhang fand ich das auch eine extrem gute Ergänzung dieses Jahr, diese Talklinie mit den Foundation Talks. Habe ich jetzt alle noch nicht so gesehen, aber auch das ist natürlich wieder eine andere Diversität, die hier noch mit reinkam. Wissen wir überhaupt, wovon ich spreche? Also es gab jetzt quasi so eine Kategorie Foundation Talks, die halt explizit Themen für Einsteiger, Anfänger, Leute, die sich ein erstes Mal mit einem Thema beschäftigen, anbieten sollten. Derer gab es eine ganze Menge, wie Frank hat Hackerethik gemacht und ich habe mir jetzt gerade noch den Talk über Deep Learning angeschaut, der hervorragend gemacht ist, hervorragend präsentiert ist. Es gibt sicherlich noch mehr Beispiele, aber die Liste ist noch sehr lang von Dingen, die ich mir anschauen muss. Aber allein die Idee ist gut, weil das natürlich auch eine Lücke schließt und glaube ich sehr wichtig ist für uns, noch mehr Lücken zu schließen und noch mehr dafür zu sorgen, dass der Kongress eben auch interessant bleibt.
Und ich finde, das schließt total gut an, an deine laute Überlegung vorhin, ob es nicht perspektivisch auch dahin gehen kann, das Programm auf den Hauptbühnen etwas zu reduzieren, wenn man sagt, es ist einfach für den Moment alles gesagt und man kann einfach mit der Fülle an Content sowieso nicht haushalten. Also es gab dieses Jahr ein total letztes Jahr einen total guten Adventskalender auf dem, ich glaube, Event-Blog vom CCC.
Weißt du, wer den geschrieben hat?
Ich weiß es nicht. Aber es war, falls du zuhörst oder falls jemand zuhört, der diese Person kennt, das war wirklich der beste Adventskalender im Jahr 2018. Jedes Jahr wurde ein Talk aus dem Schatz von media.ccc.de gehoben. Also da sind ja viel mehr Talks als nur vom Kongress nachzusehen und zu hören, aber das waren vor allem 24 alte Kongrestalks, die also aus irgendwelchen Gründen besonders waren. Und das war eine dermaßen Freude. Und diese Zweit- und Drittverwertung einfach auch noch viel systematischer anzugehen. Also viel von diesen Foundations liegt halt schon da. Also es ist ja völlig problemlos möglich, mich außerhalb der Volkshochschule irgendwie als IT- Security-Spezialistin auszubilden, einfach über media.ccc.de. Also ich finde zum Beispiel diesen ganzen...
Na ja, in der Volkshochschule ja sowieso nicht.
Nein, aber diese Analogie ist halt gar nicht so klar, aber sie ist halt völlig vorhanden. Also Adventskalender, Person, vielen Dank.
Ich gehe mal kurz die Fragen, die wir noch zum Kongress bekommen haben durch. Ich glaube, einige haben wir schon beantwortet. Da wo wir es vielleicht noch nicht haben, können wir es ja einfach mal machen. Okay, das greift schon ein bisschen rein hier. Ist der Kongress so politisch, ist schon schon so ein Running Gag, wie finde ich so ein bisschen, aber die Frage ist natürlich oft gestellt worden oder gab es zu wenig Technik?
Ich glaube, das haben wir abgegrast, oder?
Die Frage, die ist dann auch gar nicht fertig. Kann man sich nur für das ein oder andere begeistern, sollten Technik nur jetzt die Finger von politischen Themen lassen, wie es zu lesen war. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen auch ein Sammelsurium von Diskussionen, die hier halt so laufen. Ich denke, das haben wir in der Tat schon adressiert, aber vielleicht kann man es auch noch mal konkreter beantworten. Zu wenig Technik gab es bestimmt nicht auf diesem Kongress.
Ich hätte einfach in erster Linie zwei Gegenfragen. Also ist ein Kongress möglich, auf dem zu wenig Technik stattfindet? Also die Gegenfrage löst die Frage halt schon auf. Und ich finde auch für den politischen Teil gilt es genauso. Also hätte ich zumindest auch eine Gegenfrage. Also wann ist etwas zu politisch? Das verstehe ich nicht. Also wenn es dann irgendwann in so, was man leider immer noch behelfsmäßig als Lager bezeichnet, links und rechts, darüber, also man kann über die Lager, also man kann über die Kategorien reden und man kann auch über die Ausprägung reden, die das auf dem Kongress hat, aber was heißt politisch? So ist mir nicht klar.
Ich glaube, was so ein bisschen mit rein fliegt, was manche befürchten ist, eine parteipolitische Positionierung in irgendeiner Form oder eine zu klare Lagerverortung. Wo man ja sagen muss, der Club ist natürlich an sich sehr freiheitlich orientiert und von daher hat er auf jeden Fall linke Schlagseite. Aus dem parteipolitischen Geschehen hat sich der Club Gott sei Dank immer gut rausgehalten. Das war auch glaube ich bei den Piraten in der Phase sehr sehr sehr wichtig, diese Linie zu halten. Heißt aber nicht, dass der Club irgendwie jemals nicht politisch war. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich glaube der Club war von Anfang an ein gesellschaftspolitisches Projekt immer gewesen und wird er immer bleiben und von daher, wie du schon sagst, kann man überhaupt zu wenig.
Also ich habe die Frage gesehen auf Twitter. Hast du wahrscheinlich gefragt, also du warst das wahrscheinlich Tim, also was wollt ihr noch wissen zur Sendung oder zum Kongressen?
Ich habe noch Fragen.
Jemand gefragt, ist es zu politisch und vielleicht hat sich das auch nach dieser Einfrage noch bei mehr Leuten angehäuft, aber falls die Person noch zuhört, vielleicht könnte das noch mal spezifizieren. Also was heißt das? Was ist politisch?
Das kam jetzt von Nojume und ich glaube, das war eher eine Sammelfrage.
Ich glaube, dass mit dem zu politisch oder zu wenig politisch, das ist so eine geladene Frage irgendwie, weil man hat so das Gefühl, wenn die Frage gestellt wird, dann kolportiert sie schon irgendwas.
Also ich sehe gerade im Slack, schreibt jemand, politisch ist, wenn es nicht ausgewogen ist, ja dann haben wir einfach ein völlig unterschiedliches Verständnis vom Wort politisch. In dem Zusammenhang würde es ja mit neutral ersetzbar sein.
Ja, was heißt ausgewogen?
In welche Richtung soll gewogen werden?
Also Konstruktivismus.
Google Konstruktivismus. Also alles ist halt konstruiert.
Ja, also ich glaube die Diskussion führt zu uns.
Wie hoch ist der Wirkungsgrad in der Gesellschaft? Ich glaube, das haben wir wirklich ausreichend debattiert. Fanden die dir auch, dass der Kongress diesmal irgendwie zu groß, zu voll und zu unübersichtlich war?
Im Vergleich zum letztes Jahr nicht unwesentlich.
Er war größer, aber nicht zu groß. Also ich fand, er hat, obwohl er größer geworden ist, war er übersichtlicher. Aber auch das haben wir glaube ich schon.
Die Diskussion, die führen wir wahrscheinlich jedes Jahr, wenn wir da nicht schon raus sind.
Ich sag einfach mal nein.
Ich sag auch nein.
Skaliert der Kongress noch? Das ist eine schöne Nerdfrage, da steckt ein bisschen drin.
Ist die gleiche Frage wie die andere?
Nein, das ist ja also räumlich, technisch, sozial, impactmäßig, aber überall ja.
Ja, also organisatorisch reißt es an manchen Stellen.
Die Hotelpreise?
Nein, nein, nein, Einspruch. Also eben als ich gesagt hab, hier Burnold Kultur und so, waren alle nein, das ist für alle. Alle machen das voll in ihrem Maß und wenn das mal nicht passt und so, also.
Maria, du darfst wiederkommen.
Entschuldigung, ich passe um 23.30 Uhr noch auf. Verdammt, das hätte ich bei meiner Bewerbung angeben.
Ich meine, hier stecken ja zwei Sachen drin. Skaliert noch ist irgendwie, hat er dieses Jahr skaliert und die andere Frage ist, wird er in Zukunft weiter so skalieren und da gibt es natürlich jetzt verschiedene Vektoren, die man da verfolgen kann. Ich denke, da geht schon noch was und auch wenn Belastungsgrenzen erreicht wurden, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass man nicht auch irgendwas auf 120 Prozent mal fahren kann und wir haben ja auch gesehen, es wächst ja nach und immer in dem Moment, wo irgendwas schief läuft, wird es dann beim nächsten Mal gefixt. Ich denke ja.
Ich bin da auch zu versichtlich.
Die andere Frage, die so ein bisschen da drin steckt, ist natürlich auch, kann der Kongress auch noch funktionieren, wenn wir 23.000 Teilnehmer haben?
Die Frage kann keiner beantworten.
Wir werden es sehen.
Und ist er ja auch schon geworden. Im Viertel hat man ja den Kongress 3.0 erwähnt, der 21C3 war, was er auch war, mit Ansage so ein bisschen, dann wurde diskutiert, bei welcher Versionsnummer wir jetzt so sind. Also meiner Meinung nach sind wir jetzt in der Kongress 5-Ära, über die Miner-Version kann man sich jetzt unterhalten.
Hamburg ist vier oder was?
Hamburg ist vier, aber halt mit dem 30C3. Also interessanterweise ist es immer das zweite Jahr an einem neuen Ort, was wirklich die neue Ära einleitet. Der 30C3 war eine totale Weiterentwicklung auf allen Ebenen.
Das war doch mit der super crazy Seidenstraße damals, mit der Seidenstraße, mit dem Partyraum, mit geiles Intro.
Einfach alles mal wieder eine ordentliche Eröffnung. Und alles war viel besser. Und es war vor allem so ein Signal. Ich meinte immer so, ja, da haben wir mal richtig Aufwand geschoben. Das können wir natürlich nicht jedes Jahr machen.
Oh ja, falls die Frage noch nicht kommt, will ich sie trotzdem beantworten, was ich vermisst habe. Ich habe wirklich die Seidenstraße vermisst, aber ich kann komplett verstehen, dass es...
Wieso gab es keine? Gab es noch welche?
B1, ja, aber nur so...
Bisschen?...
kestimentär an einigen Stellen.
Ach so, na vielleicht ist da ein bisschen die Luft raus aus dem Projekt.
Nee, B1, Brandschutz B1. Du kannst natürlich... Was?
Diese Teile da?
Ja, nein, die brennen doch wie sonst was.
Du kannst natürlich nicht durch Türen, Feuerschutztüren, die im Zweifelsfall zugehen müssen, wenn Feuer ist, eine Seidenstraße durchlegen.
Ich meine, 2, 25 Hektar sollten ja wohl ausreichen für eine ordentliche Seidenstraße und Insta.
Ja, aber dann hast du ja halt nur in einer Halle.
Oh, ist trotzdem größer als das ganze CCH.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Aber vielleicht ist auch so ein bisschen die Luft raus, dass der Seidenstraße, ich weiß es nicht. Wenn da draußen jetzt jemand Challenge accepted denkt, dann verfolge diesen Ansatz ruhig weiter.
Bleib bei deinem Gedanken, ein guter Gedanke.
Verfolge diesen Ansatz mal weiter, das ist ein guter Ansatz.
Ja, ich finde den Vorschlag ja auch sehr schön. Man könnte den nächsten Kongress doch in der Wüste stattfinden lassen und dann einen riesigen Mann aus Holz bauen und abfangen.
Wir haben nur keine Wüste in diesem Land. Ja, doch eine ganz kleine, aber egal.
Ja, dann gab es noch die Frage.
Ich habe zur Skalierung noch eine Idee. Bei mir fehlte ein bisschen das Gefühl der Internationalität. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die ist in absoluten Zahlen, sind die Teilnehmer aus dem Ausland wahrscheinlich gleich oder größer geworden. Aber relativ gesehen habe ich das Gefühl, hat das abgenommen. Den Eindruck hatte ich auch. Und das finde ich aus verschiedenen, und damit einhergehend auch generell die Diversität. Also das war irgendwie in Hamburg anders. Also es hat für mich wieder etwas homogeneres Gefühl ausgelöst, nur so vom Zuschauen. Und das sollte nicht so sein. Und da ist noch Luft nach oben im Sinne von Skalierung. Und eine Idee, die ich da hätte, wäre sich von der Buchmesse in Frankfurt inspirieren zu lassen. Ich glaube, da stoße ich nicht bei jedem auf Gegenliebe, es quasi so ein Hacker-Gastland einzuladen.
So wie die Cebit das macht.
Die Zizizibit.
Die deutsche Messe.
Welche Cebit gibt es noch?
Also man müsste dann sozusagen das Konzept von Ländern mögen, aber es ist ja nicht für alle scheiße.
Heute machen wir aber auch alles.
It's complicated. Aber die Idee finde ich super.
Wir haben am Anfang ja darüber gesprochen. Und meine Vorstellung wäre es zum Beispiel, anzufangen mit einem Land der Europäischen Union, wo aber, wo einfach die Hütte brennt. Also zum Beispiel Partnerland, ungarische Hacker.
Oder Polen, oder Nassau, aber Kai LA brennt auch den Baum.
Also wo man dann sagt, kommt zu uns und ihr habt eine Programmschiene und ihr erzählt mal, was ihr so macht. Und ob die groß oder klein ist, die haben ein eigenes Assembly oder wo auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, sie sind irgendwie sichtbar. Und die Idee ist, dass das in diesem Land einfach auch...
Zum Sog führt.
Zum Sog führt, dass sich viele Einzelne, die sich vielleicht vorher gar nicht wussten, dass es sie gibt, dass sie sich auf dem Kongress treffen und dass sie mit auch dieses...
Das ist eine super Idee.
dieses organisatorische Energie dann in ihre Länder mitbringen und dann auch so was machen. Und das kann man dann auch ausweiten. Die Republika macht das ja ein bisschen vor, aber die kann das auch, weil die ist einfach anders strukturiert. Das ist ja auch ein Unternehmen, das will Geld verdienen, das will skalieren. Also Republika Tesaluniki, Republika Acra und was sie alles machen. Aber ein bisschen könnte man sich davon abschauen, dass man erstmal quasi Leute einlädt, die zum Teil sowieso schon da sind, aber die dann nochmal mehr mitbringen. Und dass man das jedes Jahr mit einem anderen Partner, Organisationen, das kann ja auch ein Sprachraum sein. Oder ich hab zum Beispiel gesehen, mit hohem Interesse, da will ich unbedingt hin. Es gibt den Novi Sad im September. Hab ich auch gesehen, will ich auch hin. Voll gut. Gibt es einen Balkan-Con? Und so was wäre dann ja auch eine mögliche... Also dass man nicht sagt, wir wollen hier Montenegro als Gast anhaben. Nee, dann würde man natürlich sagen, ihr versteht euch als größeren Community im ex-jugoslawischen Nachfolgestarten. Und dann kommt ihr alle zusammen.
Wir fordern die Balkanisierung des Kongresses.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Ich glaube, dass das wirklich eine Wirkung hätte auf die zivilgesellschaftlichen, auf die politischen Strukturen in den jeweiligen Ländern. Deshalb ist jetzt wieder in dieser Idee mit der Verantwortung, was ich vorhin mit Ströbele gemeint habe, wenn sich so viele Menschen mit so viel Energie versammeln, das kann was bewegen. Und dann sollte das auch irgendwie die Initialzündung sein, um anderen zu helfen und sie zu unterstützen.
Und ich finde die Idee hervorragend, weil wir auch einfach in der Lage sind, mal einen kurzen Verschnaufpunkt und eine Abfeierei für Communities aus anderen Ländern zu ermöglichen, wo es halt einfach um Leben und Tod geht. Wir betrauen den Verlust unserer Privatsphäre, aber da geht es halt um völlig andere Sachen. Jan Kucsjak und so, könnt ihr immer nachgucken, das sind halt einfach, it's real Leute. Jan Kucsjak, ein Journalist in der Slowakei, der ja halt ermordet wurde.
Italienische Mafiastrukturen mit der Regierung.
Ich glaube letztendlich wurde sein Adresse rausgefunden, weil die bei einer Informationsfreiheitsanfrage irgendwie in Behörden weitergegeben wurde. Also das sind, ja genau, großes plus eins.
Ist ein guter Punkt. Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ich hatte mal so eine Phase, wo ich mehr unterwegs war. Vielleicht verständlicherweise hat das etwas abgenommen, aber ich war auch mal in Kroatien, habe da ja mal ein paar Podcasts aufgenommen. Und wo war ich denn noch? Italien. Jetzt war ich in England, da gibt es ja ganz gute Beziehungen, aber natürlich ist jetzt der Westen, ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht schon erschlossen. Also französische Präsenz ist ja schon ausreichend stark oder zumindest, was heißt ausreichend, aber ist auf jeden Fall sichtbar. Und so ein Lückenschluss gen Osten ist auf jeden Fall wichtig. Aber dazu muss es natürlich auch Leute geben im Club, die diese diplomatischen Beziehungen auch nicht nur herstellen, sondern in gewisser Hinsicht auch repräsentieren. Also müssen sich so Freundschaftsbande erzielen, sonst findet das unter Umständen nicht die ausreichende Unterstützung. Aber das ist jetzt schon Umsetzungsklimpe, die Idee ist auf jeden Fall valide. Kann nicht immer Kongress sein? Wie geht ihr mit der Post-Kongress-Depression um?
Freuen, vorbereiten aufs Camp.
Wie war das Abbauen? Nicht den kalten Entzug, sondern beim Abbau helfen und ganz langsam die Dosis reduzieren.
Ich bin am 2. Januar abgereist. Ich hab erst mal den 31. im Wesentlichen durchgeschlafen und bin erst mal wieder klargekommen. Das war natürlich auch dieser Wohnwagen, diese Wohnwagensituation. Habt ihr die mitgeschnitten?
Ich war mit dem Camper auf dem Campingparkplatz.
Du warst mit dem Camper da, Gregor schüttelte mit dem Kopf.
Ich hätte das gemacht, hätte ich gewusst, dass es den Trailerpark gibt.
Gab es eine Wagenburg-Party, die ich verpasst habe?
Nein, das war vielleicht auch. Vermutlich hast du auch eine Party verpasst, weil du wirst wahrscheinlich sehr viele Sachen verpasst haben.
Ich weiß sogar von einer Party, die ich verpasst habe. Ich war auch nicht in der Sauna. Letztes Jahr gab es schon die Vorhut, weil als klar war, dass man da irgendwie parken kann, da gehörte ich gleich mit den ersten Wohnwagen galore. Ich wollte dieses alte Hotel direkt neben dem Event. Man will ja auch gar nicht weg eigentlich, dieses ganze nach Hause fahren, durch eine Stadt fahren usw. Das fand ich schon immer das Schlimmste. Deswegen so. Und dann war das so schnell der Knaller. Ich glaube, letztes Jahr waren da vielleicht so 20, 30 Wohnwagen, vor allem hier von der Küchentruppe usw. die eh so fahrendes Volk sind. Und ja, da ist das gleich eskaliert. Und dieses Jahr waren das schon 235 Wohnwagen und Wohnmobile.
Man musste sich aber ein offizielles Campingticket klicken.
Ja klar, weil da wurde ja auch Aufwand getrieben.
Und die waren auch irgendwann ausverkauft.
Die waren ausverkauft. Also der komplette Außenbereich der Messe, das ist das Irre.
Ich weiß, ich bin da zweimal am Tag vorbeigefahren. Und hab gedacht, wie schön mein Bulli aussähe.
Aber der Gedanke, dass wir im Winter nicht nur das Messegelände mittlerweile schon nahezu komplett belegen, sondern auch noch das Außengelände. Das ist schon irgendwie crazy. Es gibt aber da noch Potenzial. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das ziehen können wird. Aber es gibt außerhalb dieses Kerngelände gibt es tatsächlich noch mal ein explizit für Wohnwagen vorgesehenen Bereich, wo noch mal 200 hinpassen. Das könnte theoretisch auch noch mit erschlossen werden. Und dann müsste man aber wahrscheinlich über eine andere, da müsste man dieses Nordtor noch betreiben. Also ist dann auch wieder mit Kosten verbunden. Aber das ließe sich ja darüber unter Umständen auch finanzieren. Also mit Kosten verbunden, weil dann halt Personal da präsent sein muss. Sonst müsste man halt immer so riesige Wege gehen. Und das ist ja auch nichts. Aber das ist durchaus noch eine Option, die man ziehen kann. Also hier kam die Frage, Turnhalle, also es gab diese Schulen, glaube ich, wo geschlafen werden konnten. Da habe ich jetzt mit niemandem gesprochen, der das Angebot angenommen hat. Deswegen kann ich das überhaupt nicht sagen.
Ich habe mit jemandem gesprochen. Allerdings blieb es nur bei der Erwähnung. Insofern kann ich dazu jetzt nichts sagen. Und ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr, wer das war.
Zumindest ist da viel passiert. Also locker hat allein diese Wohnwagensituation und die Schulenbeschlafungssituation. Das ist jetzt von mir eine geschätzte Zahl. Ich würde mal sagen, sowas in der Größenordnung von 500, 600, 700 Plätzen, die nicht Druck auf Hotel gemacht haben.
Ja, trotzdem waren die Hotelpreise krass.
Die Hotelpreise waren teilweise krass. Und nur über so eine Maßnahme kriegen wir diese Hotelpreise gedrückt.
Ich habe mir Herrn Kemper ausgeliehen.
Waren die denn auch noch am Schluss krass, die Preise?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist nämlich die Frage. Die haben ja alle hochgepokert und manche sind vielleicht auf diesen Deal eingegangen. Aber das heißt aber lange nicht, dass sich das auch wirklich bis zum Ende gehalten hat.
Keine Ahnung. Ich stand ja letztes Jahr, also das Mal davor, irgendwie beim vierten Tag, quasi Abreisetag, stand ich dann im Hotel unten in der Lobby und wollte für nächstes Jahr reservieren. So wie einige andere auch. Und die haben nur gesagt, nein, also da muss erst der Chef drüber gucken. Und ja, nee, das machen wir erst im Januar. Da können wir noch nichts zu sagen, auf gut Deutsch. Hier war so viel los, der Laden hat so gebrummt.
Wir müssen uns nochmal neu berechnen.
Wir müssen erst mal höhere Preise berechnen, bevor wir hier irgendwelche Reservierungen annehmen können.
In welchem Hotel redest du denn jetzt?
Ich glaube, das war das NH.
Ja, die Hotels, die in der Nähe sind, da gibt es ja auch Vereinbarungen im Club und Kontingente und so weiter, damit wir da sozusagen auch für einzelne Leute Angebote machen können. Deswegen ist das eh klar, dass die das erst öffnen werden, wenn klar ist, dass der Kongress da erst mal wieder stattfindet, das wissen die ja auch nicht. Und in welchem Modus dann verfahren wird. Aber das ist ein großes Thema. So, hier.
Duschen fragt ihr ja noch zu dem Thema Wohnwagen.
In den Schulen weiß ich nicht genau, wie es da aussah.
Da gab es Duschen und ich fand die ein bisschen problematisch, weil da war halt ein Haken, da konnte man alles hinhängen. Und dann war da so eine Wand davor, die war ungefähr eine Handbreit. Und es war relativ schwierig so zu duschen, dass nicht alles nass wurde.
Ich wollte so lachen.
Besonders, weil halt die Dusche, also da hing halt der Duschkopf oben. Aber dann war da noch ein Spiegel und ein Waschbecken. Und man konnte halt nicht duschen, ohne entweder dieses Waschbecken am Arsch oder halt vorne am Pillermann zu haben. Und es war irgendwie doch relativ nervig.
Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz sicher, ob das nicht mehr Details sind, als ich wissen wollte. Oder auch nur die Person, die ihr gefragt hat. Sagen wir einfach, es gab Duschen.
Es gab Duschen, die waren nicht optimal, aber schon okay. Und außerdem sehr warm.
Darfst ruhig dein Mikrofon einschalten beim Lachen. So, hier sagt jemand, ich bin noch nie da gewesen. Wie sieht es denn mit veganem Essen aus? Also es gab welches?
Don't go there. Bring deinen eigenen Studentenfutter mit.
Ja, das Essen ist generell da noch ein Problem. Und ehrlich gesagt, das finde ich auch ein bisschen enttäuschend.
Das Bier übrigens auch.
Dass die Messe da mal nichts nachgeliefert hat.
Da muss man auch sein eigenes mitbringen. Ja, gut, aber da steht Premium drauf, aber da ist kein Premium drin. Dieses Zeug, das trinkt man irgendwie einen Abend. Und dann ist das geht halt echt nicht.
Ich mag Premium, Pils.
Ich mag Premium auch, aber ich fand es auffällig. Ich konnte nämlich dadurch, dass ich endlich mal so privat privat auf dem Kongress war, konnte ich endlich auch engeln. Und ich habe natürlich eine Barschicht gemacht. Und wir kamen halt mit dem Kühlschrank beladen nicht so schnell hinterher, wie die Nachfrage war. Und manche sind dann tatsächlich von Bier zurück auf Mate umgestiegen, wenn sie gehört haben, dass sie das Premium Bier nur halb warm bekommen können. Also du bist auf jeden Fall nicht alleine damit.
Das kannst du nur eiskalt trinken, weil du musst dir irgendwie die Geschmacksknospen betäuben. Das ist ganz schlimm, das Zeug.
Das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Es ist gruselig.
Aber jeder hat andere Geschmäcker.
Das mag sein. Ich habe mir zwei Kästen Bier mitgebracht. Und die haben auch sehr willige Abnehmer gefunden.
Also genau, Leute, bringt euch Bier mit. Bringt euch einen Fahrbahnuntersatz mit, außer ihr seid wirklich extrem körperlich potente Flaneure wie Gregor. Else bring your own Roller.
Genau, bring your Roller oder viel Zeit mit.
Also ich war gar nicht so viel. Ich glaube, 20 km bin ich an einem Tag gelaufen. Geht doch.
Ja, das muss man halt können. So muss der Körper schon machen.
Wie hieß denn die Bar gegenüber vom Späti? Die haben richtig gute Cocktails gemacht.
Das war die Cocktailbar. Ich glaube, die hat keinen speziellen Namen. Die hat wirklich, wirklich gute Cocktails.
Das war wirklich...
Allerdings...
Klar teuer, aber das war mir in dem Fall egal, weil dafür ist nur einmal im Jahr Konzert.
Die habe ich diesmal nur einmal besucht. Aber das Mal davor habe ich da echt viel Geld gelassen. Weil wir hatten dann auch unseren Barkeeper, der hat dann auch irgendwann verstanden, was wir wollten, und das war halt tödlich.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das war für mich ein Ausgleich dafür, dass es beim Essen... Ja, es war so eine Grundversorgung.
Was Gruppen essen, sind wir in Trinken.
Unser Nachtrag zu den Hotels aus dem Chat hier war von 180 Euro die Nacht, vier Tage vor dem Kongress die Rede. Okay, also die Nachfrage war wohl nachhaltig. Und in der Schule gab es eine Dusche. Eine? In einer Schule gab es eine Dusche. Also es gab ja mehrere Orte. Wie gesagt, wir wissen da zu wenig drüber. Ich bin schlicht an niemand geraten, der da Erfahrung hat. Dann gibt es noch die Frage, warum sie Shirts immer ausverkauft?
Das frage ich mich, seit ich den Kongress kenne.
Ja, die Antwort ist, glaube ich, ich bin da nicht wirklich autorisiert, das final zu analysieren. Aber das gibt mir vielleicht auch die Freiheit, hier ein bisschen zu ranten. Es ist immer so ein Drama. Anfang des Jahres denkt man sich so, ach, weißt du, machen wir doch einfach das Motto, schon mal fest für den nächsten Kongress. Dann machen wir da einen Design draus.
Und dann haben wir gar keinen Stress.
Dann haben wir gar keinen Stress. Klappt nie. Gregor weiß, wovon ich rede. Und wobei wir haben das, glaube ich, mal hinbekommen mit dem 21C3, oder? Da waren wir doch relativ früh.
Wir waren vor der großen Sommerpause, glaube ich, schon durch.
Das war auf jeden Fall ein Schritt nach vorne.
Aber unbekannte Ehrenrettung, also ein Motto, ein Jahr vorher festzulegen, ist halt hart.
Bei den Motto glaube ich nicht.
Also sowas wie Refreshing Memories, ist halt jetzt nichts von der Tagesaktualität, dass man das nicht auch in einem Februar...
Da wüsste ich auch mal gerne, es gibt ja offensichtlich ein anderes Motto, dass sowas von sprechend und so geil war, und ich mich frage, warum das nicht genommen worden ist. Und vor allen Dingen...
Welches?
Everything is a target.
Ach so, das war aber so ein Fake auf Twitter.
Egal, das ist das Motto dieser Zeit gewesen. Und gerade jetzt ein paar Tage nach dem Kongress ist auf einmal der Sprecher, das CCC, hochgebrachte Person bei Markus Lanz, dem Ersatzparlament im ZDF, und das ist genau das Thema. Jeder ist... das ist Digitalisierung. Jeder ist jetzt ein Ziel. Und ich habe davon gehört und dachte, wow, das ist das Motto zur Zeit. Und dann war das ein Hoax oder keine Ahnung oder sonst was.
Ja, die Motto sind in letzter Zeit etwas rückwärts gewandt.
Refreshing Memories, das ist wohl sehr close to the metal, aber ich habe es als nicht techie nicht so richtig verstanden. Man hat es mal versucht zu erklären und hat jetzt also... Refreshing Memories, auch bei Markus Lanz in der Mediathek.
Damit alle wissen, wovon wir reden. Linus war bei Lanz in der Sendung, die am 8. ausgestrahlt wurde oder wie auch immer das gemeint ist.
Und es war wirklich gut.
Ja, ich habe da jetzt erst heute von erfahren, das muss ich mir erstmal runterladen und zu Müte führen. So, geht das mit YouTube.de?
Wenn es nicht mit YouTube.de geht, geht es nicht.
Geht mit YouTube.de. Zum T-Shirt Design muss ich sagen, ich habe dann die T-Shirts gesehen, also das Refreshing Memories. Ich war noch nicht so komplett überwältigt, das geht jetzt gar nicht gegen das Design oder sonst was. Ich habe es einfach noch nicht so ganz verstanden gehabt, weil auch die Relevanz des Motto, also Grafik steht nicht für sich allein, sondern erst durch das Motto zusammen wird das so zu einem richtigen Impact, zu einem Gesamtkunstwerk. Und da ich Refreshing Memories nicht so verstanden hatte, wurde ich so über die Vorbereitungszeit noch nicht so richtig mit dem Design so warm, was aber okay ist, weil das wird dann ja auch erst im Laufe der Veranstaltung entfaltet sich das ja in voller Pracht. Und als ich dann aber die fertigen T-Shirts gesehen habe, muss ich sagen, das war das war schon irgendwie ein Kunstwerk, weil das ist ein typografisches Signet. Wenn man genau hinguckt, kann man das 35C3 erkennen. Und wenn man es aber nicht weiß in diesem Vexier-Spiel, sieht man halt so eine Löt-Platin-Kunst-Optik-Kunstwerk. Und das sieht einfach als Motiv auf dem T-Shirt deswegen toll aus, weil es wirklich wie so ein nerdiges Tribal, da es mal drauf gedruckt ist. Und erst wer es weiß, wer es zu lesen weiß, also so ein bisschen den Hintergrund hat, der erkennt dann das Kongress-Ziffer. Also das ist ein ganz großartiges Design, das hat mir sehr gut gefallen, dann in dieser finalen Ausprägung.
Das Einzige, was mich gestört hat, da hatte ja jemand so ein Ding gebaut, womit man seine eigenen Logos, so ein Generator, genau. Und dieser Generator hat sowohl das amerikanische Symbol für Widerstand, als auch das deutsche Symbol für Widerstand in der gleichen Schaltung verwendet. Das hat mich total irre gemacht.
Es gibt da zwei verschiedene?
Ja, das deutsche Symbole ist ein Kasten. Und das amerikanische Symbol ist so eine Zickzack-Linie.
Ah, naja, das ist halt eine internationale Veranstaltung.
Ja, aber du findest keinen Schaltplan, wo man diese beiden Symbole mixt, weil das verwirrt wirklich jeden. Es ist nämlich so, dass in Deutschland die Spule ein Gefüllterkasten ist. Und ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht sicher, die Amerikaner machen die Spule mit so einer runden Wicklung. Also es ist alles irgendwie so schwierig.
Jetzt ist mir was Neues, das war mir bisher noch nicht klar.
Das hat mich so ein bisschen kirrig gemacht, aber vielleicht...
Na ja, gut, darauf kam es jetzt auch nicht unbedingt an. Grundsätzlich finde ich es ja toll, und man muss das wahrscheinlich zunehmend einpreisen, dass es sich jetzt so manifestiert, dass welches Logo du auch immer bringst, es auf dem Kongress sein Leben erfüllt. Das heißt, man ist jetzt mittlerweile im Designauftrag, wenn man mit dieser Tätigkeit verbunden ist, muss man schon deutlich über ein reines Logodesign nachdenken. Lach doch einfach danach, nicht während ich rede.
Was ist denn?
Eben hast du gesagt, ich soll mich nicht muten. Roddy hat einen Witz gemacht.
Ich hab nur gesehen, dass im Chat fängt die Diskussion an über...
Entweder Din oder Iso, nicht beides.
Entweder Din oder Iso, nicht beides. Und da sieht man es nochmal. Das ist diese Zickzack-Linie, das amerikanische.
Keiner sieht das, das ist ein Podcast.
Und im Chat. Und die Kiste ist des Din.
Ich wollte nochmal zur Auflage mit den T-Shirts. Also erstmal, oder wahrscheinlich wolltest du das sagen, es wird relativ spät bestellt, deswegen...
Genau, das Ding ist, also was, ich sag mal andersrum, was müsste eigentlich passieren? Bisher bei dem Motto irgendwie abgezogen. Eigentlich müsste man frühzeitig sich auf was einigen. So, vielleicht trifft das Motto den Zeitgeist am Ende des Jahres. Vielleicht nicht, ist auch egal. Ja, dann macht man Design, zumindest so ein Basisdesign. Und dann kann man auch schon mal sich für ein paar T-Shirts dann auch mal festlegen. Spätestens, wenn Ticket Sale angesagt ist. Weil dann kann man die auf eine Webseite packen und sagen, so sehen die aus. Und dann können die Leute beim Kaufen des Tickets sofort sagen, ich will aber auch noch Shirts, hier zwei XL, Pipapo, irgendwie tailliert etc. PP, fünf Stück, nehme ich gleich alle mit und noch einen Hoodie. Und hier ist auch gleich noch die Kohle und fertig.
Oder man zahlt 50% an, ohne das Logo zu kennen. Und wenn man es dann nicht haben will, dann sind sie halt weg, die 50%. Wäre ich auch noch okay mit.
Also das sind Details, würde ich sagen, um eure beiden Positionen zusammenzubinden. Also ich glaube, es gibt Optimierungspotenzial.
Moment, das ist natürlich eine generelle Diskussion, die hier geführt wird, weil du hast dann immer so, oh, was ist da mit den Shirts, die nicht abgeholt werden? Weil Leute krank geworden sind, da kannst du nicht einfach sagen, kriegste nicht. Weil es ja auch unter Umständen viel Geld ist für Leute. Die dann vielleicht ihr Ticket verkauft haben, aber nicht die Shirts, egal. Dann kann man halt immer noch sagen, okay, alle Shirts, die nicht abgeholt wurden, die liegen ja dann auch noch da.
Es gibt halt einen Markt immer noch.
Die sind einfach weggelegt. Die kannst du dann entweder online freigeben. Das heißt, du kannst halt auf die Webseite gehen. Da müsste man natürlich alles bauen, aber ist ja alles lösbar. Du sagst, okay, was weiß ich, verschenken oder zuschicken. Hier gibt es nochmal Versandkosten, nochmal extra. Man muss halt nochmal Versandkosten zusätzlich ablegen und eine Lieferadresse, die vorher nicht erforderlich ist. Oder du sagst halt Spender oder was auch immer. Das kann man schon machen, müsste man halt nur machen. Und ist halt ein Prozess, der so noch nicht drin ist, weil sich der Club immer sehr schwer tut in der ganzen Motto-Diskussion, weil das auch zu hoch aufgehängt ist.
Aber wie viele T-Shirts fehlen denn? Also ich bin nicht so ein T-Shirts-Sammler.
Keiner weiß, was die tatsächliche Nachfrage ist, aber es ist halt in der Regel immer alles ausverkauft.
Was ich halt auch so ein bisschen schwierig finde, ist, dass vorher nicht klar ist, was ist das für eine Qualität. Also der letzte Kongress, da war da halt, weiß ich nicht, 20 Prozent Plastik in den Hoodies drin, wo du dir denkst, wer macht denn sowas? Hackern irgendwie Kunstfaser verkaufen, wo gleichzeitig gepredigt wird, dass alle bitteschön einmal am Tag duschen sollen. Weißt du ja so, hallo?
Ja, da bin ich ganz bei dir. Ich find jetzt, also das mit den Duschen verstehe ich jetzt nicht, zusammen machen nicht, aber...
Naja, weil das einfach stinkt.
Schneller stinkt.
Also wenn du Plastik trägst, stinkst du halt.
Die Bakterien mögen das deutlich lieber, die zu dem Gestinke führen, wenn du Kunst machst.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht so klar.
Ja, kannst mal sehen.
Ich trag ja auch keine Kunst.
Auf jeden Fall die...
Tim, wenn du Marie Kondo zu Ende geguckt hast...
Was? Dann passiert mir das nicht mehr.
Nein, dann weißt du das... Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht referiert sie auch über Plastik.
Na schauen mal.
Also ich weiß, die Vorkosten für die Produktion sind relativ hoch, vielleicht im Gesamtkosten der Veranstaltung wieder relativ klein, aber zumindest, wenn man dafür verantwortlich zeichnet, und ich hatte ja mit den entsprechenden Personen zu tun, die sind sich dieser Verantwortung bewusst und des Risikos auch, dass wenn das irgendwie falsch läuft, dass die vielleicht nicht verkauft werden, weil es den Leuten nicht gefällt. Deswegen in der Rückschau von den Pflichtanteilen in meinem Design-Pflichtenheft, es gab auch noch freiwillige Zusatzbonussachen, die man noch machen konnte, im Sinne von wenn du noch Zeit hast. Aber es gab so einen Pflichtenheft und bei der Erfüllung würde ich sagen, zwei Drittel meiner Arbeit bezog sich auf den Merch.
Das ist aber okay, finde ich. Also jetzt aus meiner Perspektive.
Warum?
Wo kommt welches Logo hin, in welcher Größe, welcher Lack, welche Farbe, welcher Anteil von Glitzerelementen haftet, ist das groß genug? Wie unterscheidet sich das Engel-T-Shirt vom normalen T-Shirt? Wie haben wir für die Kiddies das T-Shirt? Was haben wir für ein Girlie-Shirt? Das muss weit oben sein, damit es nicht auf den Brüsten ist. Und unter Umständen bei Frauen, die mehr Vorbau haben, dass es dann irgendwie so gewölbt ist und dann sieht das wieder komisch aus. Und jedes einzelne musste dann an Mustern ausprobiert werden, die aber dann eben, weil dann doch nicht vielleicht der richtigen Charge entsprochen haben, sondern nur, also, es war richtig bis hin zur... Ich habe, ich war in der Produktion.
Ja, aber gerade dann ist es ja schade, wenn nicht jeder, der eins haben will, auch eins kaufen kann.
Also eigentlich müsste man sagen, wie Tim, dass beim 21C3 irgendwie einfach drei Monate früher und im Prinzip mit dem Motto schon zum 1. September draußen sein, dann könnte man es schaffen, dass man zumindest sowas wie gestalterisch halbwegs, da kann man immer noch schreiben, Änderungen vorbehalten. Das sind dann aber so Sachen, die ich machen kann. Wir hatten zum Beispiel eine Krasgradierung. Also es gab den Stealth-Hoodie, der hatte nur das reine Signet, den Phasenprüfer. Dann hatten wir das T-Shirt, das hatte den Slogan, 2Watt und den Phasenprüfer. Und dann hatten wir quasi den 2Watt Complete Hoodie, wo sowohl der Phasenprüfer als auch der Spruch, als auch die Ziffer mit dem Spruch auf einem Textil war. Du hattest so Unterschiede. Du konntest eins so total geheim, aber du konntest auch alle drei kaufen. Und alle zusammen haben erst quasi komplementär alle Informationen preisgegeben. Und sowas muss man dann halt auch erstmal lang... Klassisches Progress-Ding.
Warum soll ich was tun, wenn ich es nicht übertreiben kann?
Nein, diese Shirts sind echt wichtig. Und die werden ja auch Jahre noch getragen.
Aber das widerspricht sich ja gar nicht.
Ich hab jemanden getroffen, der hatte ein nagelneues 16C3-Shirt. Ich hab den gepackt und hab gesagt, Alter, das ist 19 Jahre her. Woher hast du das? Der zieht das, das wird irgendwie in, keine Ahnung...
Rituell ausgepackt.
Das wird so kondomäßig zusammengefaltet. Und in irgendeinen speziellen Umidor gelagert. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Fasern. Das sah aus wie aus, das war nahe genäht. Der wird das wahrscheinlich nur an einem Tag bei der Veranstaltung alle paar Jahre mal anziehen. Weil er wahrscheinlich alle anderen T-Shirts auch hat. Und das wurde mir halt dann auch auf den Weg gegeben. Was du jetzt hier gestaltest, das wird dich über Jahre begleiten. Also achte darauf, dass du keinen Scheiß machst.
Da fragen sich die Leute immer wieder, warum es mir immer noch nicht gelungen ist, mit meinen T-Shirts rauszukommen. Weil genau solche Fragen machen mich auch fertig. Ich kann das gut nachvollziehen.
Und Nachtrag zu dem, oh Gott, Frauen-T-Shirts sind schwierig. Wir hatten mal bei Jugendhack ein Jahr, wo wir so einen Schweif über den ganzen Körper gemacht haben. Und dann habe ich einen befreundeten Nerd mit Bauch gefragt, das mal Probe anzuziehen. Und wir haben ihm das dann so mit Papier draufgeklebt. Und das hat einfach seinen ganzen Bauch so vorgehoben. Das ging halt gar nicht. Also auch da sozusagen gibt es auf allen Seiten Schwierigkeiten mit dem Design und Körperproportionen.
Ich weiß, wir sind da ja auch fast in Fallstrecke geraten beim Engel-Shirt von Tuvaat. Aber das ist offensichtlich nur so in einigen Leuten aufgefallen. Und hat keinen weiter gegen den Shipstorm erzeugt.
Die Engel, diese Engelflügelchen, die bei einigen Frauen aussahen, wie Hände, die sie gerade anfangen.
Aber wenn man es nicht weiß, ich finde, man sieht es nicht sofort. Also ich war blind dafür, wir alle waren blind dafür. Und dann waren sie draußen. Haben das denn nur Männer gemacht? Bei der Abnahme? Offensichtlich.
Auf das fehlende Gucken. Gerade dann, wenn man sich so viel Aufwand macht, ist es halt schade, wenn es nicht reicht. Wenn nicht jeder, der was kaufen will, was kaufen kann.
Man muss auch das Potenzial auch einfach nutzen, schlicht und ergreifend, weil natürlich auch der Merch erheblich dazu beiträgt, dass diese Veranstaltung sich trägt. Und der Kongress ist sehr viel teurer geworden für den Club im Vergleich zu der Situation in Hamburg. Also in Hamburg hatten wir eine bessere Balance zwischen den Kosten. Und der war für uns pro Teilnehmer billiger. Und die Preise sind ja schon ein bisschen gestiegen. Und so wie sich das jetzt entwickelt. Und wir stehen hier und sagen, das muss mehr Labyrinth und Paradies und, weißt du, Ecken hier, Ecken da.
Aber ich hab von den letzten zwei Kongressen keinen Merch, weil ich halt nicht zum richtigen Zeitpunkt da unten stand.
Das geht mir schon seit Jahren so.
Beziehungsweise weil halt niemand da war, der gesagt hat, ich geh runter, ich bring dir was mit.
Ich weiß bis zum heutigen Tag nicht, wo die Shirts überhaupt verkauft werden. Also es ist einfach ein Vorgang, die ich nicht mitkomme.
Die waren unter der Brücke. Also wenn du vom Eingang guckend...
War der Garderobe oder was?
In der Glaswurst, ja, aber nicht... Die Garderobe war ja links und es gab irgendwie rechts außen nochmal eine Garderobe und da wurde das verkauft.
Und wenn man die Schlange sieht, weiß man woher der Begriff Blockbuster kommt. Einfach einmal die Halle drumherum einfach eingenommen, durch so einen riesen...
Und das Mal davor waren sie irgendwie da so im Erdgeschoss von dem Kongresszentrum, wo die Leute dann draußen anstehen mussten.
Aber man sollte es wirklich ändern, weil da gehen ja Zehntausende von möglichen Erlösen einfach flöten, weil ich bin mir sicher, dass da 1000, 2000, 3000... Ich hab zum Beispiel auch keinen...
Also wenn ich das zum Ticket klicken könnte, würde ich das sofort machen.
Ja, das glaub ich auch. Das würden viele tun.
Und dann hätte man auch nicht den Stress, dass man jetzt zum so und so Punkt da sein muss und sich eine halbe Kilometer Schlange anstellen muss. Also das ist so...
Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen Gestrick. Oder? Lässt sich das nicht mit Zukunft irgendwie anders lösen?
Also, wir schauen mal. Ich denke, alle Beteiligten tun jedes Mal, was sie können.
Ich hab irgendwann mal im BCC ein T-Shirt bekommen, das schon ausverkauft war, nur weil ich ein T-Shirt anhatte. Was der Frau, die da in dem T-Shirt stand, so gut gefallen hat, dass sie meinte, ich glaube, ich hab in der Größe doch noch so ein T-Shirt.
Bück-Ware, ja?
Ich hab nicht mal danach gefragt.
Late Confessions.
Na ja, ist ja jetzt über zehn Jahre her. Da kann man das so machen. Auf jeden Fall.
Wollen wir nochmal die Fragen?
Außerdem ist es nicht meine Schuld.
Ihr seid ja wirklich nicht zu bremsen. Ich finde das ja ganz toll. Wollen wir noch die Fragen vielleicht noch abarbeiten und dann kommen wir auch langsam zum Ende. Aber da ergibt sich ja nochmal ein bisschen was. Dann wurde nochmal die Glaubproblematik angesprochen. Es gab halt einen Vorfall. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, wie viele Vorfälle es vielleicht dann auch noch gegeben hat, dass irgendwie Laptops abhanden gekommen sind. Da hatten wir auch schon, weil auch Bundespolitik darauf hingewiesen, dass sah nach einem gezielten Angriff aus, weil da so viele auf einmal in einem Ort weggekommen sind. Das kann man schwer einschätzen, was da passiert ist. Aber das ist natürlich sehr, sehr, sehr bedrückend, weil der Kongress eigentlich immer eine extreme, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen Safe Zone war, aber da herrscht schon ein Vertrauen im Umgang mit Gerät. Das ist enorm so. Und man macht sich immer nicht so ganz klar, was da so an Werten so rumsteht und irgendwie trifft einen dann doch ins Herz. Jetzt ist es natürlich so, wir können nicht kontrollieren, wer da kommt. Das wollen wir auch gar nicht. Und es kann auch sein, dass Leute da hingekommen sind, um genau das zu machen. Weil sie davon Kenntnis haben.
Ich weiß auch wirklich nicht, ob es Diebstahl... Also ich glaube, es gibt viele verschiedene Fälle, von wirklich weg bis hin zu nur mal kurz ausgeliehen und dann vergessen wieder, also ausgeliehen ohne zu fragen und vergessen wieder zurückzubringen und dann doch wieder gefunden.
Hier schreibt einer neun Laptops im Chaos West.
Ja, ja, also bei neun Laptops an einem Ort ist das kein ausgeliehen.
Ich war gerade beim Thema Roller, weil da fand ich, durch die Roller wurde das besonders groß.
Ja, das war eine soziale Anpassung, glaube ich. Viele haben so gedacht, oh, hier stehen ja so Roller rum, haben nicht wirklich drüber nachgedacht. Da kamen ja dann schnell diese Schilder mit, die Roller sind nicht shared. Und dann habe ich auch seitdem danach nichts mehr gehört. Also das hat sich, glaube ich, ganz gut eingedingst.
Na gut, aber ganz früher gab es ja dieses wirklich brutale Regime des Labellings bei der Hardware auf den Kongressen, wo wirklich jedes einzelne Gerät, was du rein transportierst, wurde mit so einem kleinen Sticker irgendwie versehen.
Das war eine scheiße Idee. Das hat überhaupt nicht skaliert. Das hat auch irgendwie nichts geholfen. Das war am Ende einfach nur ein Nerv.
Und als dann jeder ein Laptop hatte, wurde es aufgegeben. Genau. Als dann die Geräte wirklich zum Klauen auch waren, dann hat es niemanden mehr interessiert. Und vorher, als jeder seinen komischen Tower da auf so einen komischen Bollerwagen hochtransportiert, musste jedes einzelne von diesen tonnenschweren Equipment, wurde irgendwie mit so einem Label versehen. Vielleicht gibt es da auch eine technische Lösung, dass man irgendwie so einen kleinen Pilsender sich da draussen...
Pilsender auf den Kongress. Ich glaube, dass wir hier...
Für jeden, der das wichtig ist.
Ich glaube, dass wir hier in eine diskursative Falle fallen, die unsere Bundesregierung auch gern mal einnimmt. Da passiert irgendwie ein Vorfall, der im Gesamtzusammenhang des Universums jetzt nicht wirklich groß ist. Und dann macht man eine Maßnahme, die dann für alle Beteiligten scheiße ist. Und das hat einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn. Ich meine, dass man überhaupt auf so einer Veranstaltung sein Kram rumstehen lassen kann, die meiste Zeit ohne dass was passiert, finde ich sehr außergewöhnlich. Und ich persönlich würde mich da drauf einfach nicht verlassen. Und klar ist es schön, wenn man zu allen 13.000, 15.000, wieviel waren es Teilnehmern, so ein Vertrauen haben kann, dass nichts wegkommt. Aber bei so vielen Leuten sind halt welche dabei, die dann mal zugreifen. Also das wird man nicht ändern können. Da gibt es glaube ich keine Lösung für.
Vielleicht, naja, vielleicht gibt es keine. Ich habe mir darüber Gedanken gemacht, was man denn empfehlen könnte. Und ich denke, es müsste eine Mischung aus verschiedenen Ansätzen sein. Wer jetzt individuell besorgt ist, da gibt es halt schon die Möglichkeit, gerade so Laptops, weiß nicht, welche Laptops haben heutzutage noch diese, früher hatten die doch immer noch diesen kleinen...
Kensinken hieß das Ding.
Kensinken, das ist irgendwie mittlerweile nicht mehr so verbreitet.
Manche würden das vielleicht haben. Also Apple hat damit vor Jahren schon aufgehört.
Ja, weil das wahrscheinlich wenig benutzt wurde. Und ich glaube, sie verwenden selber solche USB-Alarmanlagen. Also du hast halt da ein USB-Dings drinstecken. Und wenn der rausgezogen wird, dann macht der Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep.
Das hat ja in Paris gut funktioniert.
Ja, ich meine, wenn da jetzt Leute mit Bulldozer fahren, dann wird nicht so viel. Gibt keiner was auf Piep, Piep, Piep.
Nein, aber das kann natürlich.
Und die Tränengas schwaden so durch.
Technische Lösung für soziale Probleme ist ja nur, sowas hätte vielleicht unter Umständen hier schon helfen können. Also neuen Laptops, die geklaut werden, wenn du davon ausgehst, dass sie alle gesichert sind. Gut, ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt realistisch, aber ich sage nur, das wäre ein Ansatz, wenn man jetzt selber besorgt ist, soll man sich einfach mal vielleicht über eine gewisse physische Sicherung Gedanken machen. Das andere denke ich ist, dass wir halt einfach mehr darauf hinweisen sollten, dass vielleicht man mal sich seiner Umgebung vergewissert. Also gerade wer jetzt an solchen Tischen sitzt. Wir reden ja jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Rechnern, die irgendwo mal rumstanden. Sondern wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, sind die aus so einer Assembly heraus geklaut worden. Da ist für mich ehrlich gesagt schon fast ein Rätsel. Ich muss sagen, ich habe jetzt mit den Betroffenen auch noch nicht gesprochen, aber es ist schon so okay. Also an einem einzigen Ort sind euch gleich neun Geräte abhanden gekommen. War da niemand mehr? Oder waren die Leute, die da waren, haben die gar keinen Blick gehabt oder so? Also ich will jetzt keine Mutmaßung machen, wer da jetzt irgendwie was richtig oder falsch gemacht hat. Darum geht es mir nicht, ich will da jetzt keine Schuld zu schieben mit, ihr hättet mal besser aufpassen können. Das würde ich nicht verstanden werden. Ich sage nur, grundsätzlich muss sich vielleicht jede Assembly eine Strategie zulegen, je nachdem wie ihr Schutzbedarf so ist, wie ihr Abwesenheitsbedarf ist, wie viele Geräte da ist. Sich selber überlegen, wie man das organisiert, dass jemand da ist, dass man vielleicht mal was wegschließt, dass man sich so ein lockerer Prinzip baut oder so. Und halt generell einfach auch diese Awareness bei den Leuten so nach dem Motto, wenn ihr irgendwo sitzt und Platz habt, verständigt euch mal mit den Leuten drum herum, was gehört denn an wem. Das ist ja so ein Plan ab und wenn jemand was nimmt, dass man mal fragt, dass man nicht einfach alles so hinnimmt. Okay, ich kriege ein paar Hinweise, über einen längeren Zeitraum passiert, das kann natürlich auch sein, aber klar, wenn dann mal was wegkommt, sollte man natürlich auch schon reagieren. Also ich will jetzt diesen konkreten Fall nicht kommentieren, weil dafür kenne ich ihn zu wenig. Grundsätzlich müssen wir aber in diese Richtung, glaube ich, gehen. Jetzt haben wir noch eine spezifische Frage. Alleinreisender Dad mit 3-jähriger Tochter. Nächstes Jahr mit Camper und Tochter anreisen oder noch ein Jahr warten?
3D ist dann 4.
Ja, besser als kein Kongress.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn er kein Problem damit hat, länger im Kids-Base zu sein, ist es auf jeden Fall kein Ding. Oder aber, wenn er sich mit irgendjemanden zusammen tut, mit weiteren Kindern und so. Aber ansonsten, also ich würds mir nicht zutrauen.
Drei, vier, ich mein da hängste dann schon, da ist es schon schwierig.
Ich würds mir nicht zutrauen, aber ich bin ja nicht der. Also keine Ahnung.
Also der Radius ist, wenn du keine andere erwachsene Person hast, mit der du so die Kinderbetreuung irgendwie teilen kannst, die kannst du dir auf dem Kongress kennenlernen, dann hast du halt einen geringen Radius. Das heißt nicht, du hast trotzdem Kongressgefühl, aber du bist halt nicht für dich selber. So ist es halt in der Kinderbetreuung. Und ich finde drei, vier kommt dir auch ein bisschen drauf an, wie weit dein Kind ist. Aber drei, vier ist noch nicht so, hier ist Junghackertag, geh mal löten, und wir treffen uns irgendwie drei Stunden. Das ist echt, und vor allem...
Deswegen sag ich im Kidspace, also für einen Vierjährigen ist im Kidspace sicherlich genug los.
Ja gut, aber dann Camper heißt ja auch, lässt ja das Kind dann auch nicht unbedingt da allein. Also du bist dann halt auch an den Schlafzyklus gebunden. Man kann das machen, aber man ist dann...
Man hat halt einen kleineren Radius. Und man muss sich klar machen, dass man auch wiederum einen anderen Kongress hat. Ich wurde auch gefragt, warum ich eigentlich meine Kinder nicht mitgebracht habe, weil alles so kinderfreundlich sei. Und ich finde, beides stimmt. Erstens sind die halt sau klein. Und zweitens, nur weil es Kinder 1 und 3 sind, sind meine Kinder. Und nur weil es Kinderangebot gibt, gibt es ja keine Verpflichtung, die eigenen Kinder mitzubringen. Und tatsächlich wird es einfach für alle Beteiligten, also Kinder und Erwachsene glaube ich interessanter, je älter sie werden, weil die Kinder eben auch inhaltlich mehr mitbekommen. Und es ist halt auch einfach so für den Biorhythmus nicht so das Biotop. Also es ist düster, es gibt keine frische Luft, man muss halt eh mit den raus. Ja, also genau, du musst halt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen resilient sein gegenüber 17.000 Leuten, die irgendeinen Scheiß verbringen.
Der Kidspace war ja nun da direkt an der Scheibe, das war ja da hell. Also zumindest der Kidspace selber war ja okay.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob er da bleiben wird.
Also Holgi meinte seine Kinder haben sich beschwert, dass da zu hell wäre, wir hätten es gerne dunkler gehabt. Ich weiß es nicht. Also sicherlich ist die Veranstaltung deutlich besser für Kinder als alles Vergleichbare. Aber es ist jetzt natürlich auch kein direkter Kinderspielplatz. Also das ist so...
Am Kidspace kann man auf jeden Fall mit einem vierjährigen Kind gleichgesinnte Treffen, die ein ähnliches Problem haben. Es ist nicht so, dass es die nicht gibt. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Lichtblick.
Es gibt auch genug Lego Duplo.
Ja, und vielleicht reist der Dad ja nächstes Jahr dann schon nicht mehr alleine zum Kongress. Da können wir ja auch Leute kennenlernen. Und von daher wollen wir deinen Forschungsdrang gar nicht groß schmälern.
Es wird auf jeden Fall ein Abenteuer. Wenn er das macht, hat er hinterher was zu erzählen. Das ist auf jeden Fall interessanter als bei den Großeltern, glaube ich.
Und noch ein Argument, der KidsBase ist auch so geil, dass es auch völlig gangbar ist, die Leute, die du als Erwachsener treffen willst, die aber keine Kinder mit haben, zum KidsBase zu lotsen, um dich dort zu treffen. Also das ist, wir hatten uns darüber unterhalten, Tim auf dem Kongress. Also, was für ein guter Ort.
Der KidsBase ist super, aber ich glaube nicht, dass er da bleiben wird, wo er jetzt war. Hier wird auch gerade im Chat nochmal darauf hingewiesen, etwas nah dran an den Rolltreffen.
Das war in Hamburg deutlich schlimmer. Das war ja direkt an den Treppen. Ich bin da die Treppen damals hochgekommen. Und das war halt kurz nachdem mein Jüngster irgendwie den Stunt mit dem Bobbikar die Treppe runtergemacht hat. Und ich als sehr unangenehmes Wochenende mit ihm im Krankenhaus verbracht hab. Und ich komm da die Treppe hoch und an mir düsen zwei Kids auf dem Bobbikar vor den Füßen vorbei. Und ich wär fast in Ohnmacht gefallen. Weil das hat mich halt total schockiert. Einfach weil ich diese Erfahrung gerade gemacht hatte. Und da ist, weiß ich nicht, fand ich jetzt an dem Kidspace zu nah an den Rolltreppen nicht das Problem. Das Problem war eher, dass diese Rampe für die Fahrzeuge mehr oder weniger direkt in die wartende Menge für den Saal, der da war, ging.
Das war zu klein.
Na ja, man hätte es ein Stück weiter nach hinten.
Nee, das ist einfach zu eng da. Vorher war der Kidspace mega groß.
Ja, aber da ist halt das Licht. Das ist halt der Punkt.
Scheiß aufs Licht. Dann baust du halt eine Tageslichtsimulation dahin. Mein Gott. Ja, kreativ rangehen. 24 Stunden Außenatmosphäre mitfilmen und dann da rein auf runden Gasen reinblenden.
Der Kidspace muss nicht nur den Kids gefallen, sondern auch den Eltern.
Ja, da fand ich, also für Eltern fand ich das letzte Mal geiler, weil er halt irgendwie mitten in der Halle war und da gab es oben und da gab es unten und das war irgendwie tiktiert. Also das war einfach besser.
Du, ich will die Entscheidung, den dahin zu tun, auch gar nicht verteidigen.
Gut, nächste Frage. Wann, ne, Entschuldigung, falsche Abteilung hier.
Viele Touristen, ist das eine Frage?
Ja, naja, mit diesen Touristen. Also das Wort Tourist stört mich ja extrem. Das finde ich ja, ist so ein bisschen, naja, ich will jetzt mal nicht.
Was ist denn damit gemeint? Fragen wir mal so rum.
Also ein Flaneur wie ich, ich war Tourist.
Ach Quatsch.
Doch.
Als jemand, der schon zwei Kongresse designt hat und so weiter, bist du kein Tourist mehr.
Also Tourist ist in Berliner Ohren total despektierlich. Das ist so richtig, du bist nicht Inner Circle, du bist irgendwie Zaungast.
Ich hatte kein Projekt. Ich hatte keinen Vortrag. Ich habe keine Engelschicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist dein Frame, wie du...
Ich bin erst seit neunzehn Jahren auf dem Kongress. Ich spiele nur eine Randrolle. Also mal ehrlich gesagt, für mich klingt so ein bisschen Tourist auf dem Kongress, klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie Ausländer raus. Das ist irgendwie nicht okay. Der Begriff, ich find den scheiße. Und man kann das vielleicht auch irgendwie positiv biegen, aber ich werd damit nicht warm. Weil was soll denn das bitte sein? Das ist auch Quatsch.
Ich meine, es ist so schwierig, an Karten zu kommen. Da gibt's keine Touristen. Weißt du, wer auf diesen Kongress will und sich diese Tortur antut, irgendwie Karten zu organisieren, der ist kein Tourist mehr.
Na, ich dreh es mal andersrum. Und wenn schon. Also, was soll denn diese Kategorisierung von Leuten, die noch nicht da sind. Erstbesucher lassen es ja noch mal durchgehen, aber Tourist, als ob die Leute da hinfahren würden, um sich irgendwie so Hacker live in so einem Zoo anzuschauen, oder was? Also, das finde ich...
Zweit ziehen wir ein paar Fotos und dann weiter mit dem Bus.
Ja, ich finde auch alles daran verkehrt, je länger ich darüber nachdenke.
Dieses Verhalten gibt es da gar nicht. Ich hab das nicht kennengelernt, ich hab das nicht gesehen, und ich finde, das ist eine unangemessene Ausgrenzung, und ich hab da gar keinen Bock, da weiter drüber zu reden.
Gut, Tonqualität in den Sälen steht hier noch. Kann ich nichts zu sagen, ich war kein...
Sind halt Messer allen, ne?
Bei uns war die Tonqualität gut, aber wir hatten auch den guten Saal.
Die Aufnahmetonqualität war an sich ganz gut, wenn es der Toncrew gelungen ist, immer das richtige Mikrofon zuzuschalten. Also in Aufzeichnungen ging es da teilweise wild hin und her, weil sich halt auch die Sprecher dann wild abgewechselt haben und die dann halt immer dynamisch die einzelnen Spuren rein und raus genommen haben und dann vielleicht nicht schnell genug waren. Das scheint mir so ein offenes Rennen zu sein, seitdem die sich da entschieden haben, alles da in Realtime abzumixen, was generell bessere Ergebnisse erzielen kann, aber nicht unbedingt halt immer ein Volltreffer ist, wenn man dann halt eben vergisst, das zu machen, weil man einfach nicht damit rechnet.
Das muss jemand machen, der das gut kann.
Ich finde ja Vorträge mit drei oder vier oder fünf Leuten, was es teilweise gibt, ohnehin gar gar. Also was, ihr braucht keine drei, vier verschiedenen Stile und Geschwindigkeiten und so. Da kann man sich dann irgendwie auch auf eine oder zwei Personen vielleicht einigen. Und wenn das Problem ist, dass ihr irgendwie das Ticket nicht bezahlen könnt, schreibt halt noch eine Mail dazu. Wir ersparen euch einen Vortragsantrag mit drei Speikern, aber vielleicht könnt ihr uns ja irgendwie hier noch einen Discount geben. Ich will jetzt nicht allen unterstellen, dass es ist. Teilweise hat es halt auch was damit zu tun, dass irgendeine Gruppe halt schon gemeinsam an irgendwas arbeitet. Aber dazu müssen dann nicht unbedingt immer alle auch onstage sein oder so. Also ich finde es verwirrend und selten sinnvoll. So, Tonqualität hängt jetzt aber natürlich nicht nur davon ab. Grundsätzlich wird gutes Equipment eingesetzt. Und es ist halt einfach nur ein Aufwandsproblem. Also die Audio-Code hat da schon eine Menge zu tun, weil es auch sehr viele Quellen gibt, glaube ich. Das ganze Audio-Video-Ding ist ja irgendwie sowieso auch im Kongress wieder so völlig explodiert. Also es wird ja alle einzelnen Quellen aus jedem Saal werden mittlerweile über ein eigens geschaltetes Glasfasernetzwerk in Echtzeit in diesen Kontrollraum übertragen. Du lupst die Braue, so ist es. Du musst ja für die Streams das beste Ergebnis haben. So können sie verhindern, dass sie in jedem Saal ein Team haben müssen. Sie können zentral in einem einzelnen Raum alle sitzen und das Audio machen.
Aber sie brauchen trotzdem für jeden Stream jemanden, der das macht. Ja, aber sie können ja nicht einer drei Streams machen. Okay, vielleicht ist das auch der Grund.
Sie sitzen aber nebeneinander in einem Teamraum und können sich da absprechen und können Probleme sofort erfassen und sind direkt beim Wok im CCL etc. Das macht schon alles Sinn. Das ist auf jeden Fall die Realität. Und sie arbeiten da aber, glaube ich, mit extrem vielen Quellen. Also es hat irgendwie verschiedene Heldzellen, Handmikrofone, Saalmikrofone, Tischmikrofone etc. Und es gibt dann irgendwie immer so zehn Quellen zur Auswahl. Und bei jedem Talk wird halt ein anderes Subset genutzt. Und es ist halt vorher nicht unbedingt immer ganz klar, macht der Sprecher jetzt mit Headset, macht der Sprecher mit Handmikrofone, macht der Sprecher am Tisch. Und wann werden Saalmikros angeschaltet etc.
Das Einzige, was ich halt auch oder etwas, was ich daran halt schwierig finde, ist, dass du, glaube ich, als jemand, der in so einem Übertragungswagen sitzt, bist darauf angewiesen, über die Videostreams zu erfahren, was auf der Bühne passiert. Und wenn jetzt gerade keiner der Kameramänner dahin leuchtet, wo jemand ein Mikrofon genommen hat und anfangen will zu sprechen, dann weißt du auch nicht, dass du ihm das Mikrofon jetzt aufmachen musst. Also wenn du in der Halle sitzt und hast eine gute Position, dann kannst du die Bühne komplett überprüfen, überblicken. Dann siehst du, dass da jemand von rechts aus dem Dunkeln kommt und das Mikrofon hoch nimmt und kannst ihn anmachen.
Ich weiß aber trotzdem nicht, welches Mikrofon dann in der Hand ist, wenn es dann mehrere gibt und so. Also das funktioniert ja meistens.
Klar, je mehr Eingabequellen du hast, desto komplexer wird das Mixing und desto mehr musst du jemand sein, der sowas öfter gemacht hat und kann. Ich würde gar nicht behaupten, dass ich so jemand bin, weil bin ich nicht. Und ich fand das, was wir auf der Bühne an Setup hatten, schon schwierig genug. Klar, fünf Hatsets und irgendwie ein Saalmikro und ein Moderationsmikro und dann noch einmal Klinke für Zuspieler.
Du musst halt auch sehen, wenn du im Saal sitzt, dann bist du ja auch noch der Saalakustik und der PA dort ausgeliefert. Wenn du halt den Ton abmischen sollst für Recording und Stream, dann ist für dich die Wiedergabe im Saal vollkommen irrelevant, weil du mixt ja ganz anders ab.
Das ist richtig, aber das kannst du mit einem guten Kopfhörer.
Du hast da deine Theorie. Ich denke, die werden da schon drüber nachgedacht haben.
Ja, ich finde mich wundert, wenn sie das als vorteilhaft sehen, dann ja, meine Fing.
Warum sollst du nicht alles in einem Raum machen? Das ist ein schön ruhiger Ort. Die müssen nicht die ganze Zeit von Saal zu Saal rennen. Die können sich gegenseitig helfen. Also, macht doch total Sinn.
Da ich es nicht gemacht hab.
Die Qualität vor Ort ist so eine Sache. Also, viel Hall, ja klar, ist da viel Hall. Das ist Messerhallen.
Das sind leere Hallen. Das ist der im Namen.
Oh Gott, Messerhallen.
Ja, das ist der im Namen.
Ist das der selbe Wortstamm?
Ja, Halle macht Hall. Ja, natürlich.
Aber ist das der selbe Wortstamm?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Willst du jetzt eine etymologische?
Die Etymophries sollen hier mal gucken, dass sie da an den Start kommen. Aber ja, klar, also eine Messerhalle hat halt eine Akustik wie eine Messerhalle. Das ist halt extrem schwierig. Und du wirst auch nicht genug schallabsorbierendes Material aufhängen können, dass du das letzten Endes in den Griff kriegst. Also wenn du so ein Saal hast wie in Hamburg, der ist dafür gebaut, eine richtig gute Akustik zu haben. Und dann ist sie halt auch gut. Das ist irgendwie...
So, die Fragen kommen nach wie vor rein hier. Ich war beeindruckt, das erste Mal Kongress, aber Satch etwas verloren. Wie kann man das ändern? Einfache Antwort. Engeln.
Satch, wie war die Frage?
Ich war beeindruckt, von dem Kongress das erste Mal da, fühlte sich aber etwas verloren. So, wie man das erinnern könnte.
Ja, also für mich sind nach wie vor die Leute der Kongress. Und wenn man die nicht kennenlernt, ist man da verloren. Das stimmt schon irgendwie. Ob man vorher zu irgendwelchen Ortsvereinen, sag ich jetzt mal, geht und schon Leute kennenlernt und sich dann mit denen vernetzt und dann mit denen auf dem Kongress aufzuschlagen oder ob man es irgendwie anders macht, muss jeder selber wissen. Aber ich glaube, man hat von dem Kongress einfach deutlich mehr, wenn man da mit seiner Peer-Group da ist und Leute kennt.
Und Engeln hat aber nochmal den Bonus, dass man die Möglichkeit hat, ein besseres Essen zu kommen. Und zweitens, man hat auch nochmal diese Hinterbühne, dieses Back-Office, also das ist so ein Frontend und Backend vom Kongress. Und eigentlich kriegt man das komplette Bild, wenn man beide Welten auch gesehen hat. Und so ein Logistiklager, das ist ja auch schon ganz beeindruckend.
Besonders die Getränke, alter Schwede.
Die Menge.
Das war wieder super beeindruckend, fand ich.
Was genau, die Getränke als solche oder die Menge?
Dieser von Weitem so aussehende, dieser Block an Kisten. Einfach so dieses von weiter weg hatte das so was.
So Minecraft-mäßig aus Marte.
Ja, aber das hat so was Massives, so als hätte da jemand mehrere Überseecontainer nebeneinander gestellt. Weil diese Kisten auch, weil die halt so in ihrer Menge halt auch so gerade stehen und das so eine massive Masse von etwas ist. Das fand ich super beeindruckend. Ist mir die anderen Jahre nicht so aufgefallen.
Also die Antwort ist Engeln, eine Assembly suchen, wo man reinpasst. Und damit ist man eigentlich schon relativ weit. Insbesondere die Engelei ist einfach die beste Möglichkeit Leute zu treffen. Vor allem halt entweder trifft man Leute, denen es genauso geht oder man trifft Leute, die schon viel Erfahrung haben. Also best of both worlds. Wird es einen 36C3 in Klammern 2019 geben und wird dieser in Leipzig stattfinden?
Erster Teil ziemlich sicher, zweiter Teil weiß man nicht. Also wir zumindest nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Sagen wir mal so, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Niemand weiß das gerade. Also oder sagen wir es mal so. Es gibt jetzt noch keinen veröffentlichten, konkreten Plan, wie das jetzt läuft. Denn jetzt ist erst mal Camp. Und da fokussiert sich jetzt alles drauf hin. Und derzeit denke ich mal...
Ist schon klar, dass das an der alten Location ist?
Ja, in Wildenberg. Und das wird wahrscheinlich für viele Leute ohnehin eine Enttäuschung werden. Weil ich mir einfach vorstelle, dass die Tickets nicht lange halten werden. Und sicherlich die Voucher-Phase nicht nennenswert. Also das ist schwer zu sagen. Die Nachfrage nach den Veranstaltungen vom Club sind enorm. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet, dass wir im zweiten Jahr in Leipzig noch in der Situation sein werden, dass es vorher ausverkauft ist. Hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht. Und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wie viel das noch werden sollen, können, müssen, wollen. Werden wir sehen. Wir müssen langsam an den Ende. Ihr seid ja wirklich hart hier. Wir haben jetzt schon 5 Stunden durch. So lange wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht machen. Aber ich finde es war super, super, super Diskussion. Vielleicht können wir das an der Stelle abschließen. Vielleicht wollt ihr noch ein letztes Wort haben. Also jetzt nur zum Thema Kongress meine ich. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was ihr aus dem Herzen...
Ich würde wieder hingehen.
Du würdest wieder hingehen. Ich glaube, das vereint uns eh alle. Weil es ist schon immer wieder eine Veranstaltung. Also im Vorfeld habe ich ja angekündigt, hier wir reden über einen Kongress. Wieder so ein Insider Talk und so. Und hier Kongress und wen interessiert denn das schon? Gehe ich ja eh nicht hin. Ja, okay, klar sehe ich auch. Es ist noch nicht die gesamte Bundesrepublik Deutschland dort vor Ort. Aber ich kann halt nur wieder feststellen, dass alle, aber wirklich ausnahmslos alle Leute, die das erste Mal da waren, unisono eigentlich wieder von denselben Dingen erzählt haben. So, dass das hier irgendwie eine echt spezielle Atmosphäre ist, dass man das so mit Worten eigentlich schwer beschreiben kann, dass die allermeisten Leute vor allem sich auch sofort willkommen gefühlt haben und akzeptiert gefühlt haben und dass halt der Level an intellektuellem Diskurs deutlich über dem Schnitt liegt, wie man das so aus anderen Welten vielleicht kennt. Und das finde ich jetzt schon mal eine ganze Menge so. Und das übersteigt, glaube ich, vieler Leute Erwartungen von vornherein schon. Und dann gibt es halt immer noch mal eine ganze Menge obendrauf.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt einem Kollegen beschrieben, Kongress ist halt das, was du draus machst. Ja, aber es ist so. Also ich meine, man kann sich die Vorträge angucken, man kann Leute treffen, man kann halt alles machen. Das ist halt irgendwie schwierig. Man kann auch einen schlechten Kongress haben, wenn man irgendwie nichts macht.
Genau. Zum Schluss muss ich auch nochmal eine Veranstaltung ankündigen. Weil das nämlich jetzt auch gerade online gegangen ist, bringe ich das jetzt nochmal in nahezu eigener Sache. Ich habe ja auch schon mehrere Veranstaltungen gemacht. Nicht nur den Kongress für ein paar Jahre, sondern ich hatte auch irgendwann mal dieses Podcast Meetup zusammengerufen. Das war ursprünglich mal ein Developer Workshop. Das war so der erste Versuch, da so ein bisschen Initiative reinzukriegen. Hat sich rausgestellt, war der falsche Ansatz. Dann haben wir es umgedreht und haben gesagt, das ist jetzt für Podcaster und Developer dürfen auch gerne kommen. Dann hat es super funktioniert. Dann hieß das eine Weile Podcaster Workshop, was ein bekloppter Name war, auch wenn die Abkürzung sich gut suchen lässt auf der Festplatte. Aber dann haben wir halt irgendwann gesagt, jetzt brauchen wir mal was geschmeidigeres. Und haben das Ding ja unbenannt Indie. Subscribe, was ein brauchbarer Name war. Und wir haben sogar Subscribe.de noch bekommen.
Die sich aber nicht mehr googeln lässt.
Ja, das war uns natürlich klar, dass es von der Gugelbarkeit her Einschränkungen hat. Aber you can't have it all. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist die Veranstaltung dann eigentlich ganz gut losgegangen. Dann hatten wir aber so ein bisschen Location-Pech. Wir haben dann ums Verrecken nichts mehr in Berlin gefunden. Dann gab es noch so diverse andere Sachen. Dann hatten wir die Subscribe 7, 8, 9. Zuletzt in München. Dann dachten wir so, jetzt aber Berlin. Dann ging es irgendwie gar nicht. Auch weil ein paar der wichtigen Kräfte hinter den Kulissen mit anderen Lebensherausforderungen klarkommen mussten. Sodass dieses ganze Engagement nicht mehr so gefahren werden konnte. Jetzt gibt es aber wieder Bewegung in dem ganzen Sport. Und es wird eine Subskribe geben und das auch relativ bald. Das ist dann erstens die zehnte. Zweitens ist das die erste, die weder in Berlin noch in München stattfindet, sondern in Köln. Und zwar im März. Und jetzt müssen wir gleich hier mal gucken, wo wir die schöne Webseite dazu haben. Ich bin nicht wieder in meinem Dingsvertur. Die Subskribe Nummer 10 oder heißt es X? Nein, wir haben ganz bewusst hier einfach dezimal durchgezählt vom 22. bis zum 24. März. Konkret heißt das immer, es geht am 22. das ist ein Freitag, geht es am Nachmittag los. Und da findet man sich ein und dann gibt es ein paar Eröffnungstalks und ein bisschen Ringelpiz ohne Anfassen, aber mit Abendessen. Und dann am Samstag ist richtig Programm und am Sonntag auch noch. Das Ganze findet statt im Funkhaus Köln vom Deutschlandfunk. Wir sind nämlich dort zu Gast und kriegen den tollen Konzertsaal als Hauptbühne und noch drei, vier andere Räume, in denen man wunderschöne Workshops machen kann. Wer noch nicht auf der Subscribe war, aber trotzdem in irgendeiner Form mit dem Podcasting-Thema oder Radio-Thema oder verwandten Publikationsformen harmoniert, vielleicht nochmal kurz, was so das Modell ist. Also wir nennen das eine Podcasting-Konferenz. Wir haben aber nur einen Single Track. Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich nur in dem Hauptsaal so richtig Vorträge. Das heißt, wir haben da so eine Vortragung, wo wir dann wahrscheinlich am Freitag und am Samstag und am Sonntag mehr oder weniger durchgehen. Und die anderen vier Räume, die so zwischen so 20, 30 Personen halten können, gibt es Workshops. Workshops heißt eigentlich nur, das organisieren wir jetzt nur so weit, dass wir die Raumzuteilung machen. Das kommt von den Teilnehmern. Das heißt, ihr seid dazu aufgerufen, nicht nur zu kommen, sondern ihr könnt sagen, ich will was machen zu X. Und dann wird sich da schon ein Slot für finden, weil wir eben sehr viele zur Verfügung haben. Also bei vier oder wir können glaube ich sogar noch einen fünften Raum klar machen, haben wir da einfach sehr viele Möglichkeiten, Slots unterzubekommen und für Podcaster oder Entwickler, die im Podcasting-Bereich irgendwie was machen wollen oder was lernen wollen, gibt es also von daher die Möglichkeit, dieses ganze Wochenende mit locker zehn unterschiedlichen Themen oder Workshops zu füllen und sehr abwechslungsreich hin und her zu gehen. Wir verkaufen ein Ticket. Das Ticket covert unsere überschaubaren Kosten. Wir zahlen da nichts für die Miete. Das macht das alles ein bisschen entspannter. Aber vor allem ist halt das Essen mit drin. Das ist uns immer ganz wichtig. Man muss also nicht weg, sondern man kauft das Ticket die es jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt gerade noch nicht gibt, weil die Kalkulation noch nicht ganz fertig ist. Aber das wird in einem überschaubaren Rahmen sein. Und das bedeutet, dass ihr quasi Freitags, Samstags, Sonntags Futter habt und euch eigentlich über nichts Gedanken machen müsst, außer natürlich eine Unterkunft finden in Köln. Das lässt sich nicht verhindern. Das können wir eigentlich auch noch mit reinschmeißen. Also wir wollen es affordable machen für alle Leute. Wir haben da einen ähnlichen Vibe wie der Kongress. Das kann ich euch versprechen. Das ist da wirklich super nice. Sehr, sehr, sehr nette, hilfsbereite Leute. Wer auf dem Kongress schon mal im Sendezentrum angedockt ist, dürfte wissen, wie das gemeint ist. Weil ich glaube, das ist in dieser ganzen Zuckerwatte-Community teilweise wirklich noch mal die kleine Kirsche obendrauf.
Wir haben Einhörner.
Wir haben Einhörner. Wir haben die Podcastpartinnen, die da irgendwie immer viel geholfen haben. Und ich habe die ganze Podcast-Szene schon immer als eine Szene kennengelernt, die voll ist mit Leuten, die Wissen vermitteln wollen. Das ist irgendwie eine Triebfehler für viele Podcasts. Das war für mich auf jeden Fall schon immer so gewesen. Und das drückt diese Subscribe halt aus. Das ist einfach ein Community-Treffen. Das ist aber auch eine Möglichkeit, sich technisch da weiterzubilden. Das ist die Möglichkeit, auch über eigene Erfahrungen und Vorträge, eigene Erfahrungen und Projekte vorzutragen, dort Informationen und Erfahrungen auszutauschen, andere interessante Leute kennenzulernen. Keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute kommen. Wir sind ein bisschen knapp dran mit der ganzen Ankündigung. Aber ich denke, es wird sich auf jeden Fall lohnen. Letztes Mal waren wir so 150. Ich hoffe, dass wir in dem Bereich wieder landen können. Platz hätten wir sogar noch für einige mehr. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine überschaubare Geschichte. Also wenn ihr jetzt die 18.000 vom Kongress oder 17.000 abgeschrägt habt, hier das Ganze durch 100. Und das tolle Prozent trifft sich. Und ich hoffe natürlich sehr, dass insbesondere der Raum NRW sich hier auch mal glücklich schätzt. Die haben nämlich immer rumgemäkelt. Warum wir denn immer so im Osten und im Süden und überhaupt, wo kommen wir denn dahin? Und wenn ihr alle kommt und wir den Rest aus Berlin und München und anderen Regionen, die immer noch kommen, auch noch eingesammelt bekommen, denke ich mal, wird das alles ganz prima sein. Ich bin ganz froh, diesmal machen eine ganze Menge Leute mit, die so bisher noch nicht reingerufen haben. Das ist auch gut so, weil ihr wisst ja, ich, Barcelona, weit weg, ich kann da nicht viel reißen und habe mich ohnehin um die Contentorganisationen nicht gekümmert. Das haben immer Ralf und Claudia gemacht, die können aber diesmal auch nicht. Also es gibt da ein komplett neues Team, die sich alle gerade im Slack gegenseitig die Hände reichen. Wer Lust hat, hier vielleicht auch noch inhaltlich mitzumachen oder vor Ort zu organisieren, kann sich gerne melden. Und dann wird es alles ganz toll. Also 22. bis 24. März 2019. It's soon, it's in Köln, es ist im Funkhaus. Toller Ort, tolle Leute, tolles Thema. Alles super, die Sonne scheint, die Vöglein zwitschern, alles wird gut. War das ausreichend Werbung?
Im März zwitschern befürchtet.
Ich weiß nicht, hat noch jemand Fragen zu subscriben?
Habt ihr Fragen zu subscriben? Könnt ihr vielleicht Fragen stellen, von denen ihr denkt, dass die jetzt Leute fragen würden, nachdem ich das jetzt gesagt habe? Kannst du dir vorstellen, was da stattfindet?
Absolut.
Na, dann.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, da hinzukommen?
Ich bin halt keine Podcasterin.
Noch keine Podcasterin.
Dann solltest du vielleicht kommen.
Wer war noch gleich deine Heldin? Also ich finde, du machst dich ja hier ganz gut am Mikrofon. Das hat durchaus Mitteilungsbedürfnis und Fähigkeiten auch. Also Podcast, ich meine, hat man heutzutage einfach.
Man hat halt ein Podcast.
Man hat halt ein Podcast. Wie, du hast kein Podcast?
Wollen wir aber, bist du jetzt so Richtung schließen? Wollen wir noch, falls es das Ende ist, diesen super guten Thread von Grauhut vorlesen?
Das machen wir gleich noch. Ich werde gerade noch darauf hingewiesen, dass ich noch in eigener Sache auch nochmal werben muss, weil ich habe ja einen neuen Podcast gestartet. Auf dem Kongress im Übrigen. Also kündige ich das auch noch an, aber ihr wisst es wahrscheinlich alle schon. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir immer Gedanken darüber gemacht, wo ich denn eigentlich so meinen Sonderbedarf an Hirnabfall noch so reinlegen kann und wo ich auch so experimentell an ein paar neuen Formaten rumzuppeln kann, etc. Da habe ich mir vor Jahren schon mal einen Namen ausgedacht, der mir dann irgendwann mal so einfiel, siedend, heiß und habe mir vor allem die grandiose Domain dazu gesichert, ukw.fm, unsere kleine Welt. Wir haben immer alle erzählt, wenn man richtig Reichweite haben will und Relevanz haben will, dann muss man auf UKW sein. Das meinten immer diese Radioläute. Vielleicht haben die ja recht. Also jetzt bin ich auf UKW und hoffe, in Barcelona das ein oder andere auch fern produzieren zu können. Denn das ist jetzt mal endlich so ein Kanal, wo ich auch sage, ja, ja zu Remote, ja zu Telefon, ja zu egal wie. Hauptsache mal mit Leuten reden und bin gespannt, was dabei herauskommt. Angefangen habe ich hier mit Nicolas und Reinhard. Die Leute haben schon gefragt, ob die jetzt immer dabei sein werden. Also nee, das waren jetzt nur die Gäste für die Pilotfolge. Das war so ein bisschen für mich der Kickoff, der Auslöser, weil ich gesehen habe, dass die ihre eigene Show diesmal nicht eingereicht haben auf einen Kongress. Dann hat die mir, wenn ihr nichts zu tun habt, dann könnt ihr auch gleich bei mir auflaufen. Dann quatschen wir mal so ein bisschen über das Leben und den ganzen Rest. Das haben wir auch getan. Das ist, glaube ich, eine halbwegs unterhaltsame Pilotsendung. Aber geht man nicht davon aus, dass das jetzt schon den Stil definiert, da geht es bestimmt noch anders ab. Hoffe ich zumindest.
Das war auf jeden Fall sehr lustig, weil irgendwie, ich glaube, fünf Minuten bevor es losgehen sollte, standen da die beiden und so. Ja, wo ist denn Tim jetzt?
Was für ein Espenlaub.
Was sollen wir denn jetzt machen? Er hat uns gar nicht verraten, was jetzt passiert. Und ich nur so, ich dachte, ihr wisst das. Ja, nee, wir wissen auch nichts.
Ja, immer diese Plane irgendwie. Ich glaube, das war das erste Mal, wo sie wirklich gemerkt haben, wie ich arbeite. Bisher war das für sie immer nur so Mythos.
Das ist dein wievielter Podcast, Tim?
Podcast-Kanal, den ich so insgesamt aufmache. Ich weiß nicht, hab ich nicht gezählt, der 11. oder so. Also die laufen natürlich nicht alle. Also nicht mehr alle oder weiß nicht. Ich mache halt einen Kanal auf, wenn ich der Meinung bin, ich brauch einen, weil...
Dann gibt es halt keine.
Oder hast du schon mal eins begraben?
Ja, doch, es sind schon ein paar auch zu Ende. Ich muss mir gerade noch mal was überlegen, wie man das vielleicht auch mal so darstellen kann, dass die auch wirklich so richtig zu Ende sind. Also ich hab mal irgendwie dieses mit Sascha Lobo, nicht mit Sascha Lobo, sondern irgendwie, der hat das irgendwie angestoßen, diese C-Bild-Geschichte, das hab ich mit Max mal gemacht. Und dann hab ich diesen Gesellschaftspodcast gemacht für Aktion Mensch und so. Das ist wirklich abgeschlossen. Genau, das sind die Projekte. Und meine eigenen Kanäle, naja, im Lautsprecher hab ich schon lange jetzt nichts mehr gemacht. Aber im Prinzip, wenn ich mal wieder so Inside Baseball Podcasting mit irgendjemand rede, da hab ich schon noch ein paar Ideen, was ich mal machen müsste bzw. schon versucht, mal Termin zu finden, ist gescheitert. Dann werf ich was halt in den Lautsprecher rein. Raumzeit soll auf jeden Fall wieder weitergehen. Guck mal, ich versage schon dabei überhaupt meine eigenen Podcasts aufzuzählen. Und ich muss auch mal UKW hier auf der Meter-Ebene überhaupt mit aufführen. Ja, gut, es gibt CRE. Das war auch ein bisschen dünner dieses Jahr. Oder letztes Jahr, tut mir leid. Freak Show lief gut, Logbuch lief sehr gut. Fuchs Europa mach ich halt hier für die Böll-Stiftung. Das ist nicht so viel, wie ich möchte. Aber waren auf jeden Fall ein paar solide Sachen dabei. Forschergeist läuft eigentlich relativ beständig. Ein paar ganz tolle Sachen. Die Raumzeit war dünner, aber was kam, war gut. News of the World ist glaube ich vorbei. Das war so ein Experiment. Das habe ich mit Bicycle Mark zusammen gemacht auf Englisch. Da finden wir einfach die Zeit nicht mehr zusammen. Und NSFW, naja, NSFW ist jetzt bei 99 Folgen. Ich glaube, wir machen noch eine. Aber ich weiß nicht wann. Aber eine machen wir noch. Und dann irgendwie angemessen. Genau. Lautsprecher, wie gesagt. Kolophon mache ich ab und zu was. Es kommen immer ein paar schöne Sachen raus, weil das halt so mit Autoren ist und so. Da habe ich gerade wieder ein paar Sachen gemacht. Aber was richtig durch ist, Bundesradio, das war mal ein Experiment mit Philipp Banzer. Der macht jetzt Lage der Nationen. Stark Glücklich Gesellschafter ist durch. Und dieser 01 Podcast. Da kommt jetzt UKW noch dazu. Da habe ich 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. Naja und davon 2 weg, 9, also irgendwie so was in der Größenordnung. Eigentlich zu viele für einen Menschen. Aber naja, macht man halt so.
Muss auch mal seine Podcasts aufräumen, ne?
Alle auf den Tisch schmeißen. Wie schön du den Bogen wieder zum Beginn der Sendung gemacht hast.
Genau, nimmst du jeden mal in die Hand.
Alles auf den Haufen. Dann mal gucken, ob ich, wenn ich es mir anfasse, ob es noch Liebe ausstrahlt.
Und alle mal durchhören.
Das stimmt allerdings. An der Stelle passt es super. Frau Kondo, ich glaube...
It's a date.
Sie hat sich hier immer so richtig reingetindert. Vielen, vielen Dank, Gregor, Maria. Das war toll. Du darfst wiederkommen. Du darfst auch wiederkommen, Odi.
Ja, da bin ich ja froh.
Wollen wir jetzt diesen geilen Thread noch vorlesen?
Ja, mach das.
Erstmal kontextualisieren. Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Ich musste auch erst zweimal überlegen.
Lies einfach.
Oh Gott, vielleicht krieg ich gleich den übelsten Nachles.
Also du liest einen Twitter-Thread vor. Ich lese einen Twitter-Thread vor von Ed Grauhut. Gerade klingelte im CCC das Telefon. Sir, I'm calling from Microsoft and we have detected an issue with your Windows installation. Ich wurde zu jemandem verbunden, der Deutsch sprach. Wie praktisch. Die nette Dame half mir auch den RDP-Zugang in der Windows 7 VM aufzusetzen. Sie hat mich dann durch einen längeren Prozess geführt. Das System sei infiziert. Man könne das am Terminal Output, nur echt in rot gefärbt, deutlich sehen. Es gibt eine Service-Pauschale, um das System zu reinigen. Ich habe meine Kreditkartendaten in einer Datei gespeichert. Moment. Die Dame hat die Datei dann direkt auf ihren eigenen Computer kopiert. Danach wurde es still in der Leitung. Möglicherweise war die an den File gekoppelte Ransomware dafür verantwortlich, die sonst als Test-Payload für Kundensysteme dient. Natürlich verschlüsselt die Variante nur fünf Dateien und hört dann auf. Also wenn man das so einstellt. Viel Gefluche und das Gespräch wurde abrupt von ihrer Seite unterbrochen. Grübel-Emoji. Zurückrufen, sich als Microsoft-Mitarbeiter ausgeben und anbieten, den Rechner zu desinfizieren?
Da gab es auch mal einen Vortrag von irgendeinem Typen, der tatsächlich auch so einem Nigeria-Spammer so geantwortet hat, dass der ihm dann quasi in die Falle gegangen ist.
Steht tatsächlich in dem Reply zu dem Threat auf Twitter. Ich glaube, der Talk heißt A Trip to India und war bei der SAA.
Keine Ahnung, war so ein englischer Vortrag.
So, Leute.
Die Endmusik haben wir die 5 Stunden geknackt, die 6 Stunden.
So war es von locker, mit Ableton Live Fails alles schon im Eimer. Aber wir haben hier Ultraschall, das Gute. Da kann uns nichts passieren. Also wir sagen Tschüss. Wir sehen uns in 2 Wochen wieder. Dann gibt es wieder Freak Show. Und dann sind auch ein paar von den anderen wieder da.